i remember the reaction where he had
drawn these characters and he was slowly
moving around and like people had no
experience with 3d navigation it was all
still keyboard we didn't even have mice
and set up at that time but slowly
moving going up picked up a key go to a
wall the wall disappears in a little
animation and there's a monster like
right there and he practically fell out
of his chair it was just like ah
and
games just didn't do that you know the
games were the god's eye view you were a
little invested in your little guy you
can be like you know happy or sad when
things happen but you just did not get
that kind of startle reaction you
weren't in somebody
something in the back of your brain some
reptile brain thing is just going oh
[ __ ] something just happened
and that was one of those early points
where it's like yeah this is going to
make a difference this is going to be
powerful and it's going to matter
the following is a conversation with
john carmack widely considered to be one
of the greatest programmers ever
he was the co-founder of id software and
the lead programmer on several games
that revolutionized the technology the
experience and the role of gaming in our
society including commander keen
wolfenstein 3d
doom and quake
he spent many years as the cto of oculus
vr helping to create portals into
virtual worlds and to define the
technological path to the metaverse and
meta
and now he has been shifting some of his
attention to the problem of artificial
general intelligence
this was the longest conversation on
this podcast at over five hours and
still i could talk to john many many
more times and we hope to do just that
this is the lux treatment podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's john
carmack
what was the first program you've ever
written do you remember
yeah i do so i remember being in a radio
shack going up to the trs 80 computers
and learning just enough to be able to
do 10 print john carmack i am and it's
kind of interesting how of course i you
know carnegie and richie
kind of standardized hello world as the
first thing that you do in every
computer programming language and every
computer but not having any interaction
with the cultures of unix or any other
standardized things it was just like
well what am i going to say i'm going to
say my name and then you learn how to do
go210 and have it scroll all off the
screen and that was definitely the first
thing that i wound up doing on a
computer can i ask your programming
advice i was always told in the
beginning that you're not allowed to use
go to statements that's really bad
programming is this correct or not
jumping around code can can we look at
the philosophy and the technical
uh aspects of the go-to statement that
seems so convenient but it's supposed to
be certainly back in the day in basic
programming languages you didn't have
proper loops you didn't have four whiles
and repeats you know that was the land
of pascal for people that kind of
generally had access to it back then so
you had no choice but to use go-to's and
as you made what were big programs back
then which were a thousand line basic
program is a really big program they did
tend to sort of degenerate into madness
uh you didn't have good editors or code
exploration tools so you would wind up
fixing things in one place add a little
patch and there's reasons why structured
programming generally helps
understanding but go-to's aren't
poisonous sometimes they're the right
thing to do
usually it's because there's a language
feature missing like nested breaks or
something where it's it can sometimes be
better to do a go to clean up or go to
error rather than having multiple flags
multiple if statements littered
throughout things but but it is rare if
you grip through all of my code right
now i am i don't think any of my current
code bases would actually have a go to
but
uh deep within sort of the technical
underpinnings of a major game engine
you're gonna have some go-to's in a
couple places probably
yeah the infrastructure on top of
like the closer you get to the machine
code the more goatees you're gonna see
the more of these like hacks you're
going to see because uh the set of
features available to you in low-level
programming languages is not
uh is limited
so
print john carmack when is the first
time
if we could talk about love that you
fell in love with programming you said
like this this is really something
special it really was something that was
one of those love at first sight things
where just really from the time that i
understood what a computer was even i
mean i remember looking through old
encyclopedias at the black and white
photos of the ibm mainframes with the
reel-to-reel tape decks and
for people nowadays it can be a little
hard to understand what the world was
like then from information gathering
where i would go to the libraries and
there would be a couple books on the
shelf about computers and they would be
very out of date even at that point just
not a lot of information but i would
grab everything that i could find and
you know devour everything whenever time
or newsweek had some article about
computers i would like cut it out with
scissors and put it somewhere it just it
felt like this magical thing to me this
idea that the computer would just do
exactly what you told it to i mean and
there's a little bit of the genie
monkey's paw sort of issues there where
you'd better be really really careful
with what you're telling it to do but it
wasn't going to back talk you it wasn't
going to have a different point of view
it was going to carry out what you told
it to do and if you had the right
commands you could make it do these
pretty magical things
and so what kind of programs did you
write at first so beyond the print john
carmack so i can remember as going
through the learning process where you
find at the start you're just learning
how to do the most basic possible things
and i can remember stuff like uh a
superman comic that radio shack
commissioned to have i it's like
superman had lost some of his super
brain and kids had to use radio shack
trs 80 computers to do calculations for
to help him kind of complete his heroics
and i'd find little things like that i
am and then get a few basic books to be
able to kind of work my way up and again
it was so precious back then i had a
couple books that would teach me
important things about it i had one book
that i could start to learn a little bit
of assembly language from and i'd have a
few books on basic and some things that
i could get from the libraries
but i
my goals in the early days was almost
always making games of various kinds you
know i had i loved the arcade games and
the early atari 2600 games and being
able to do some of those things myself
on the computers was
very much what i aspired to and it was a
whole journey where if you learn normal
basic you can't do any kind of an action
game you can write an adventure game you
can write things where you say what do
you do here i get sword attack troll
that type of thing and that can be done
in the context of basic
i but to do things that had moving
graphics there were only the most
limited things you could possibly do you
could maybe do breakout or pong or that
sort of thing in low resolution graphics
and in fact one of my first sort of
major technical hacks that i was kind of
fond of was
on the apple ii computers
they had a they had a mode called low
resolution graphics where of course all
graphics were low resolution back then
but you know regular low resolution
graphics it was a grid of 40 by 40
pixels normally but they could have 16
different colors
and i wanted to make a game kind of like
the uh the arcade game vanguard just a
scrolling game and i wanted to just kind
of have it scroll vertically up and i
could move a little ship around you
could manage to do that in basic but
there's no way you could redraw the
whole screen and i remember at the time
just coming up with what felt like a
brainstorm to me where i knew enough
about the way the hardware was
controlled where the text screen and the
low resolution graphics screen were
basically the same thing and all those
computers could scroll their text screen
reasonably you could do a listing and it
would scroll things up and i figured out
that i could kind of tweak just a couple
things that i barely understood to put
it into a graphics mode and i could draw
graphics and then i could just do a line
feed at the very bottom of the screen
and then the system would scroll it all
up using an assembly language routine
that i didn't know how to write back
then
so i that was like this first great hack
that sort of had analogs later on in my
career for a lot of different things so
i found out that i could draw a screen i
could do a line feed at the bottom it
would scroll it up once i could draw a
couple more lines of stuff at the bottom
and that was my first way to kind of
scroll the screen which i you know which
was interesting and that that played a
big part later on in the id software
days as well so do efficient school
efficient drawing
where you don't have to draw the whole
screen but you draw from the bottom
using the thing that was designed in the
hardware for text output yeah where so
much of until recently i'm game design
was limited by what you could actually
get the computer to do where it's easy
to say like okay i want to scroll the
screen you just redraw the entire screen
at a slight offset and nowadays that
works just fine computers are
ludicrously fast i but up until a decade
ago or so there were all these things
everybody wanted to do but if they knew
enough programming to be able to make it
happen it would happen too slow to be a
good experience
either just ridiculously slow or just
slow enough that it wasn't fun to
experience it like that so so much of
kind of the first couple decades of the
programming work that i did was largely
figuring out how to do something that
everybody knows how they want it to
happen it just has to happen two to ten
times faster than sort of the
straightforward way of doing things
would make it happen and it's different
now because at this point
lots of things you can just do in the
most naive possible way and it still
works out you know you don't have nearly
the creative limitations or the
incentives for optimizing on that level
and there's a lot of pros and cons to
that but i do generally you know i'm not
going to do the the angry old man
shaking my fist at the clouds bit where
back in my day programmers had to do
real programming you know it's it's
amazing that you can just kind of pick
an idea and go do it right now and you
don't have to be some assembly language
wizard or deep gpu arcanist to be able
to figure out how to make your wishes
happen well they're still
see that's true but let me put on my old
man with a
hat and say that probably the thing that
will define the future still requires
you to
operate at the limits of the current
system so we'll probably talk about this
but if you talk about building the
metaverse
and building a vr experience that's
compelling it probably requires you to
not
to go to assembly or
maybe not literally but sort of uh
spiritually to go to the limits of what
the system is capable of yeah and that
really was why virtual reality was um
specifically interesting to me where it
had all the ties to you could say that
even back in the early days i have some
old magazine articles that's talking
about doom as a virtual reality
experience back when just seeing
anything in 3d uh so you could say that
we've been trying to build those virtual
experiences from the very beginning and
in the modern era virtual reality
especially on the mobile side of things
when it's standalone you're basically
using a cell phone chip to be able to
produce these
very immersive experiences it does
require work it's not at the level of
what an old-school console game
programmer would have operated at where
you're looking at hardware registers and
you're scheduling all the dn dma
accesses but it is still definitely a
different level than what a web
developer or or even a pc steam game
developer usually has to work at and
again it's great there's opportunities
for people that want to operate it
either into that spectrum there and
still provide a lot of value to the
world
let me ask you uh
sort of a big question about preference
what would you say is the best
programming language
your favorite
but also the best you've seen
throughout your career you're considered
by many to be the greatest programmer
ever i mean it's so difficult to place
that label on anyone if but if you put
it on anyone it's you so let me ask you
these kind of ridiculous questions of
what's the best band of all time but in
your case what's the best programming
language
everything has all the caveats about it
but so what i use so nowadays i i do
program a reasonable amount of python
for aiml sorts of work uh that's i'm not
a native python programmer it's
something i came to very late in my
career i understand what it's good for
you don't dream in python i do not and
it has some of those things where
there's some amazing stats when you say
if you just start if you make a loop you
know a triply nested loop and start
doing operations in python you can be
thousands to potentially a million times
slower than a proper gpu tensor
operation and these are staggering
numbers you know you can be as much
slower as we've almost gotten faster in
our uh you know our pace of progress and
all this other miraculous stuff so your
intuitions about inefficiencies within
the python sort of it keeps hitting me
upside the face where it just it's
gotten to the point now i understand
it's like okay you just can't do a loop
if you care about performance in python
you have to figure out how you can
reformat this into some big vector
operation or something that's going to
be done completely within a c plus plus
library but the other hand is it's it's
amazingly convenient and you just see
stuff that people are able to cobble
together by you just import a few
different things and you can do stuff
that nobody on earth could do 10 years
ago and you can do it in a little
cookbook thing that you copy pasted out
of a website so that is really great
when i'm sitting down to do what i
consider kind of serious programming
it's still in c plus and it's really
kind of a c flavored c plus plus at that
where i'm not big into the modern
template meta programming sorts of
things i see a lot of train wrecks
coming from some of that over
abstraction
i spent a few years really going kind of
deep into the kind of historical lisp
work um and the haskell and some of the
functional programming sides of things
and there's
there is a lot of value there in the way
you think about things and i changed a
lot of the way i write my cnc plus plus
code based on what i learned about uh
the value that comes out of not having
this random mutable state that you kind
of lose track of
because something that
many people don't really appreciate
until they've been at it for a long time
is that it's not the writing of the
program initially it's the whole
lifespan of the program and that's when
it's not necessarily just how fast you
wrote it or how how fast it operates but
it's how can it bend and adapt as
situations change and then the thing
that i've really been learning in my
time at meta with the oculus and vr work
is it's also how well it hands off
between a continuous kind of revolving
door of programmers taking over
maintenance and different things and how
you get people up to speed in different
areas and there's all these other
different aspects of it so c plus plus a
good language for handover between
engineers probably not the best i and
there's some really interesting aspects
to this where in some cases languages
that are not um that are not generally
thought well of for many reasons like c
is derided pretty broadly that yes
obviously all of these security flaws
that happen with the memory and uh
unsafeness and
buffer overruns and the things that
you've got there but there is this
underappreciated aspect to the language
is so simple anyone can go and you know
if you know c you can generally jump in
someplace and not have to learn what
paradigms they're using because there
just aren't that many available i think
there's you know and there's some really
really well-written c code like it's i
find it great that if i'm messing around
with something in open bsd say i mean i
can be walking around in the kernel and
i'm like i understand everything that's
going on here uh it's not hard for me to
figure out what's i you know what i need
to do to to you know make whatever
change that i need to
while you can have you know more
significant languages like
it's a downside of lisp where i don't
regret the time that i spent with lisp i
i think that it i it did help you know
help my thinking about programming in
some ways but the people that are the
biggest defenders of lisp are saying how
malleable of a language it is that if
you write a huge list program you've
basically invented your own kind of
language and structure because it's not
the primitives of the language you're
using very much it's all of the things
you've built on top of that and then a
language like racket kind of one of the
more modern lisp versions it's
essentially touted as a language for
building other languages and
i understand the value of that for a
tiny little project but the idea of that
for one of these long term supported by
lots of people kind of horrifies me
where all of those abstractions that
you're like okay you can't touch this
code till you educate yourself on all of
these things that we've built on top of
that and it was interesting to see how
uh when google made go a lot of time
criticisms of that are it's like wow
this is not a state-of-the-art language
this language is just so simple and
almost crude and you could see the
programming language people just looking
down at it but it does seem to be quite
popular as basically saying this is the
good things about c everybody can just
jump right in and use it you don't need
to restructure your brain to write good
code in it so i i wish that i had more
opportunity for doing some work
in go uh rust is the other modern
language that everybody talks about that
i'm not fit past judgment on i've done
you know a little bit beyond hello world
i wrote some like video decompression
work in rust just as an exercise but
that was a few years ago and i haven't
really used it since you know the best
programming language is the one that
works generally that you're currently
using because that's another trap is in
almost every case i've seen when people
mixed languages on a project that's a
mistake i would rather
stay just in one language so that
everybody can work across the entire
thing and we have i get meta we have a
lot of projects that use kind of react
frameworks so you've got javascript here
and then you have
c plus plus for real work and then you
may have java interfacing with some
other part of the android system and
those are all kind of horrible things
and that was
you know one thing that
i
i remember talking with uh with baz at
facebook about it where like man i wish
we could have just said we're only
hiring c plus plus programmers i am and
he just thought from the from the
facebook meta perspective well we just
wouldn't be able to find enough i
you know with the thousands of
programmers they've got there it is
not necessarily a dying breed but you
can sure find a lot more java javascript
programmers
and i i kind of mentioned that to elon
one time and he was kind of
flabbergasted about that it's like well
you just you go out and you find those
programmers and you don't hire the other
programmers that don't do the languages
that you want to use
but right now i guess yeah they're using
javascript on a bunch of the the spacex
work for the ui side of things when you
go find ui programmers they're
javascript programmers i wonder if
that's because there's a lot of
javascript programmers because i do
think
that great programmers are rare
that it's not
you know if you just look at statistics
of how many people are using different
programming languages that doesn't tell
you the story
of what the great programmers are using
and so you have to
really look at what you were speaking to
which is the fundamentals of a language
what does it encourage how does it
encourage you to think what kind of
systems does it encourage you to build
there is something about c plus plus
that has elements of creativity but
forces you to be an adult
about your programming which it expects
you to be an adult expectantly not
forced you do and so
it's
so it brings out people
that are willing to be creative in terms
of building large systems and coming up
with interesting solutions but at the
same time have the sort of the
good software engineering
practices that amend themselves to
real-world systems
let me ask you about this other language
javascript
so if we you know aliens visit
in thousands of years and humans are
long gone
something tells me that most of the
systems they find would be running
javascript i kind of think that if the
simula if we're living in a simulation
it's really it's written in javascript
um you know for the longest time even
still
javascript didn't get any respect
and yet it runs so much of the world in
an increasing
number of the world is it possible that
all everything will be written in
javascript one day so the engineering
under javascript is really pretty
phenomenal uh the
the systems that make javascript run as
fast as it does right now
are kind of miracles of modern
engineering in many ways it does feel
like
it is not an optimal language for all
the things that it's being used for or
an optimal distribution system to you to
build huge apps in something like this
uh without type systems and so on i am
but i think for a lot of people it does
reasonably the necessary things it's
still a c flavored language it's still
uh you know a braces and semicolon
language uh it's not hard for people to
be trained in javascript and then
understand the roots of where it came
from
i think garbage collection is
unequivocally a good thing for most
programs to be written in it's funny
that i still just this morning i was on
i was seeing a twitter thread of a bunch
of really senior game dev people arguing
about the the virtues and costs of
garbage collection and you will run into
some people that are top-notch
programmers that just say no this is
literally not a good thing
because it makes you lazy yes that it
makes you not think about things and i
do disagree i think that
there is so much objective data on the
the vulnerabilities that have happened
in cnc plus plus programs sometimes
written by the best programmers in the
world it's like nobody is good enough to
avoid ever shooting themselves in the
foot with that you write enough c code
you're going to shoot yourself in the
foot and garbage collection is a very
great thing for the vast majority of
programs it's only when you get into the
tightest of real-time things that you
start saying it's like no the garbage
collection has more costs and it has
benefits for me there but that's not 99
plus percent of all the software in the
world
so javascript is not
terrible in those ways and
i am
and so much of programming is not the
language itself it's the infrastructure
around ever you know that surrounds it
all the libraries that you can get and
the different stuff that you can ways
you can deploy it i am the portability
that it gives you and javascript is
really strong on a lot of those things
where
for a long time and it still does if i
look at it the the web stack about
everything that has to go when you do
something really trivial in javascript
and it shows up on a web browser to kind
of x-ray through that and see everything
that has to happen for your one little
javascript statement to turn into
something visible in your web browser
it's
very very disquieting just the the depth
of that stack and the fact that so few
people can even comprehend all of the
levels that are going on there
but it's again i have to
caution myself to not be the in the good
old days old man about it because
clearly there's enormous value here the
world does run on javascript to a pretty
good approximation there and it's not
falling apart there's a bunch of scary
stuff where you look at console logs and
you just see all of these bad things
that are happening but it's still kind
of limping along and nobody really
notices
but
so much of my systems design and systems
analysis goes around you should
understand what the speed of light is
like what would be the best you could
possibly do here and it sounds horrible
but in a lot of cases you can be a
thousand times off your speed of light
velocity for something and it's still be
okay and in fact it can even sometimes
still be the optimal thing in a larger
system standpoint where there's a lot of
things that you don't want to have to
parachute in someone like me to go in
and say make this
this web page run a thousand times
faster you know make this web app into
uh a hardcore native application that
starts up in 37 milliseconds and
everything responds in less than one
frame latency that's just not necessary
and if somebody wants to go pay me
millions of dollars to do software like
that when they can take somebody right
out of a boot camp and say spin up an
application for this uh often
being efficient is not
really the best metric it's like there's
that applies in a lot of areas where
it's kind of interesting how a lot of
our appliances and everything are all
built around energy efficiency sometimes
at the expense of robustness in some
other ways or higher costs in other ways
where there's interesting things where
energy or electricity could become much
cheaper in a future world and that could
change our engineering trade-offs for
the way we build certain things where
you could throw away efficiency and
actually get more benefits that actually
matter i mean that's one of my you know
i one of the directions i was
considering swerving into was uh nuclear
energy when i was kind of like what do i
want to do next it was either going to
be uh cost-effective nuclear fission or
artificial general intelligence
and one of the one of my pet ideas there
is like you know people don't understand
how cheap nuclear fuel is and there
would be ways that i you could be a
quarter the efficiency or less but if it
wound up making your plant 10 times
cheaper that could be a radical
innovation in something like that so
there's like some of these thoughts
around like direct fission energy
conversion fission fragment conversion
that you know maybe you build something
that doesn't require all the steam
turbines and everything even if it winds
up being less efficient so that applies
a lot in programming where
there's always it's always good to know
what you could do if you really sat down
and took it
took it far because sometimes there's
discontinuities like around user
reaction times there are some points
where the difference between
operating in one second and 750
milliseconds uh
not that huge you'll see it in web page
statistics but most of the usability
stuff not that great but if you get down
to 50 milliseconds then all of a sudden
this just feels amazing you know it's
just like doing your bidding instantly
rather than you're giving it a command
twiddling your thumbs waiting for it to
respond so sometimes it's important to
really crunch hard to get over some
threshold but there are there are broad
basins in the value metric for lots of
work where it just doesn't pay to even
go that extra mile and they're craftsmen
that you know they just don't want to
buy that and more power to them you know
if somebody just wants to say no i'm
going to be
i'm my pride is in my work i'm never
going to do something that's not as good
as i could possibly make it i respect
that and sometimes i am that person but
i try to focus more on the larger value
picture and you do pick your battles and
you deploy your resources in the play
that's going to give you sort of the
best user value in the end well if you
look at the evolution of life on earth
as a kind of
programming effort
it's uh it seems like efficiency isn't
the thing that's being optimized for
like natural selection is very
inefficient but it kind of
adapts and through the process of
adaptations building more and more
complex systems they're more and more
intelligent the final result is kind of
pretty interesting and so i think of
javascript the same way
it's like this giant mess
that you know things naturally die off
if they don't work and they if they if
they're becoming useful to people they
kind of naturally live and then you
build this community large community of
people that are generating code and some
code is sticky some is not and nobody
knows
the
the inefficiencies or the efficiencies
or the breaking points like how reliable
this code is and you kind of just run it
assume it works and then get
unpleasantly surprised and that's very
kind of the evolutionary process so
that's a really good analogy and we can
go a lot of places with that where in
the earliest days of programming when
you had finite you could count the bytes
that you had to work on this you had all
the the kind of hackers playing code
golf to be one less instruction than the
other person's multiply routine to kind
of get through and and it was so
perfectly crafted it was a crystal piece
of artwork when you had a program
because there just were not that many
you couldn't afford to be lazy in
different ways and in many ways i see
that as akin to the symbolic ai work
where again if you did not have the
resources to just say well we're gonna
do billions and billions of programmable
weights here you have to turn it down
into something that is symbolic and
crafted like that but that's definitely
not the way dna and life and
biological evolution and things work i
you know on the one hand it's
it's almost humbling how little
programming code is in our bodies you
know we've got a couple billion base
pairs and it's like this all fits on a
thumb drive for years now and then our
brains are even a smaller section of
that you've got maybe 50 megabytes and
this is not like shannon limit perfectly
uh information dense uh
conveyances here it's like these are
messy codes you know they're broken up
into amino acids a lot of them don't do
important things or they do things in
very awkward ways but it is this process
of just accumulation on top of things
and you need
you need scale both you need scale force
or the population for that to work out
and in the early days in the 50s and 60s
the the kind of ancient era of computers
where you could count when they said
like when the internet started even in
the 70s there were like 18 hosts or
something on it it was this small finite
number and you were still optimizing
everything to be as good as you possibly
could be but now it's billions and
billions of devices and everything going
on and you can have this very much
natural evolution going on where
lots of things are tried lots of things
are blowing up venture capitalists lose
their money
when a startup invested in the wrong
tech stack and things completely failed
or failed to scale
but you know but good things do come out
of it and it's interesting to see the
the mimetic evolution of the way
different things happen like mentioning
hello world at the beginning it's funny
how some little thing like that where
everybody every programmer knows hello
world now and that was a completely
arbitrary sort of decision that just
came out of the
dominance of unix and c and early
examples of things like that so
millions of experiments are going on all
the time but some things do kind of rise
to the top and win the fitness war for
whether it's mind space or programming
techniques or anything like there's a
site on stack exchange called
code golf where people compete
to write the shortest possible program
for particular tasks in all the
different kinds of languages and it's
really interesting to see
folks kind of
their masters of their craft
really play
with the limits of programming languages
it's really beautiful to see and across
all the different programming languages
you get to see
some of these weird programming
languages and mainstream ones by the
difference between python two and three
you get to see the difference between c
and c plus plus in java and you get to
see javascript all of that and
it's kind of
inspiring to see how much depth of
possibility there is within programming
languages that code golf kind of tasks
reveal
most of us if you do any kind of
programming you kind of do boring kind
of
very vanilla type of code that's the way
to build large systems but it's nice to
see that the possibility of creative
genius is still within those languages
it's
laden within those languages so given
that given that you are once again one
of the greatest programmers ever
what do you think makes a good
programmer
maybe a good modern programmer
so i just gave a long rant slash lecture
at meta uh to the tpm organization and
my
my biggest point was everything that
we're doing really should flow from user
value you know all the good things that
we're doing it's like we're we're not
technical people it's like
you shouldn't be taking pride just in
the specific thing like code golf is the
sort of thing it's a fun puzzle game but
that really should not be a major
motivator for you it's like we're
solving problems for people or we're
providing entertainment to people we're
doing something of value to people
that's displacing something else in
their life so we want to be providing a
net value over what they could be doing
uh but instead they're choosing to use
our products and that's where i mean it
sounds trite or corny but i
fundamentally do think that's how you
make the world a better place if you
have given more value to people than it
took you and your team to create
then the world's a better place people
have they've gone from something of
lesser value chosen to use your product
and their life feels better for that and
if you've produced that economically
that's that's a really good thing
i you know on the other hand if you
spent ridiculous amounts of money you've
just kind of shoveled a lot of cash into
a wood chipper there and you should
maybe you know not feel so good about
what you're doing
so
being proud about like a specific
architecture or specific technology or a
specific code sequence that you've done
it's great to get a little smile like a
tiny little dopamine hit for that but
the top level metric should be that
you're building things of value now you
can get in the argument about how you
you know what is user value how do you
actually quantify that and there can be
big arguments about that but it's easy
to be able to say okay this pissed off
user there is not getting value from
what you're doing this user over there
with the big smile on their face i am
the moment of delight when something
happened there's a value that's happened
there i mean if you you have to at least
accept that there is a concept of user
value even if you have trouble exactly
quantifying it you can usually make
relative arguments about it well this
was better than this uh we've improved
things
so
you know being a you know being a
servant to the user is your job when
you're doing when you're a developer you
want to be producing something that i
you know other people are going to find
valuable and if you are technically
inclined then finding the right levers
to be able to pull to be able to
make a design that's going to produce
the most value for the least amount of
effort and it always has to be i kind of
divide there's a ratio there where you
it's a problem at the big tech companies
you know whether it's you know meta
google apple microsoft amazon companies
that have almost infinite money i i mean
i know their cfo will complain that it's
not infinite money but from most
developer standpoints it really does
feel like it and it's almost
counterintuitive that
if you're working hard as a developer on
something there's always this thought if
only i had more resources more people
more ram more megahertz i
then my product will be better and that
sense that at certain points it's
certainly true that if you are really
hamstrung by this removing an obstacle
will will make a better product make
more value
but if you're not making your core
design decisions in this fiercely
competitive
way where you're saying feature a or
feature b you can't just say let's do
both uh because then you're not making a
value judgment about them you're just
saying well they both seem good i don't
want to necessarily have to pick out
which one is better or how much better
and tell team b that uh sorry we're not
going to do this because a is more
important
but that i am that notion of always
having to really critically value what
you're doing your time the resources you
expend even the opportunity cost of
doing something else
that's you know super important well let
me ask you about this the big debates
that you're mentioning of how to measure
value
is it possible to measure it kind of um
numerically
uh or can you do the sort of johnny eye
the designer route of imagining
sort of uh somebody using a thing and
imagining a smile on their face
imagining the experience of love and joy
that you have when you use the thing
that's from a design perspective or if
you're building more like a low lower
level thing for like linux you imagine a
developer that might come across this
and use it and become
uh
happy and better off because of it so
where do you land on those things is it
measurable so i imagine like meta
and google
will probably try to measure the thing
they'll try to it's like you try to
optimize engagement or something let's
measure engagement and then i think
there is a kind of
i mean i admire the designer ethic of
like
think of a future that's immeasurable
and you try to make somebody in that
future that's different from today happy
so i do
usually favor if you can get any kind of
a a metric that's good by all means
listen to the data but you can go too
far there where we've had problems where
it's like hey we had a performance
regression because our fancy new
telemetry system is doing a bazillion
file rights uh to kind of archive this
stuff because we needed to collect
information to determine if we were
doing you know if our plans were good
so
when information is available you should
never ignore it i mean for the actual
users using the thing
human beings using the thing large
number of human beings and you get to
see sort of at least so there's the zero
to one problem of when you're doing
something really new you do kind of have
to make a guess but one of the points
that i've been making at meta is
we have more than enough users now that
anything somebody wants to try in vr we
have users that will be interested in
that you do not get to make a completely
green field blue sky pitch and say i'm
going to do this because i think it
might be interesting i challenge
everyone there are going to be people
whether it's you know working in vr on
your i'm
like on your desktop replacement or
communicating with people in different
ways or playing the games
there are there are going to be
probably millions of people or at least
in if you pick some tiny niche that
we're not in right now there's still
going to be thousands of people out
there that have the headsets that would
be your target market and i tell people
pay attention to them don't invent
fictional users don't you know make an
alice bob charlie uh that fits whatever
matrix of uh of tendencies that you want
to break the market down to because it's
a mistake to think about imaginary users
when you've got real users that you
could be working with but you know on
the other hand there is
there is value to having a kind of
wholeness of vision for a product and
i
companies like meta have
you know they understand the trade-offs
where you can have a company like spacex
or you know apple in the the steve jobs
era where you have a very powerful
leading personality that i you know they
can micromanage at a very low level and
can say it's like no that handle needs
to be different or that that icon needs
to change the tint there and they
clearly get a lot of value out of it
they also burn through a lot of
employees that have horror stories to
tell about uh working there afterwards
my position is that
you're at your best when you've got a
leader that is at their limit of what
they can kind of comprehend of
everything below them uh and they can't
have an informed opinion about
everything that's going on and you take
somebody it's you've got to believe that
somebody that has 30 40 years of
experience you would hope that they've
got wisdom that the the just out of boot
camp person uh contributing doesn't have
and that if they're like well that's
wrong there you probably shouldn't do it
that way or or even just don't do it
that way do it another way
so there's value there but it can't go
beyond a certain level i am i mean i
have steve jobs stories of him saying
things that are just wrong right in
front of me about technical things
because he was not operating at that
level
i
but when it does work and you do get
that kind of passionate leader that's
thinking about the entire product and
just really deeply cares about not
letting anything slip through the cracks
i i think that's got a lot of value but
the other side of that is the people
saying that well we want to have these
independent teams that are bubbling up
the ideas because like it's it's almost
it's anti-capitalist or anti-free market
to say it's like i want my grand you
know my great leader to go ahead and
dictate all these points there where
clearly free markets bring up things
that you know you don't expect like in
vr we we saw a bunch of things like it
didn't turn out at all the way the early
people thought were going to be the key
applications and things that you know
would not have been approved by uh you
know the the dark cabal making the
decisions about what gets into the store
turn out in some cases be extremely
successful uh so
yeah i definitely kind of wanted to be
there at the point where i did make a
pitch it's like hey make me vr dictator
and i'll go and get [ __ ] done i am and
that's just it's not in the culture at
meta you know and they they understand
the trade-offs they i and that's just
not the way that's not the company that
they want the team that they uh that
they want to do
it's fascinating because vr and we'll
talk about it more
it's still
it's still unclear to me
in what way vr will change the world
because it does seem clear that vr will
somehow fundamentally transform this
world
and it's unclear to me how yeah yeah and
it's let me know when you want to get
into that
you being the best programmer ever okay
in the early days when you didn't have
when you didn't have adult
responsibilities of leading teams and
all that kind of stuff and you can focus
on just
being a programmer what did the
productive day in the life of john
carmack look like how many hours is the
keyboard how much sleep what was the
source of calories that fueled the brain
what was it like what time did you wake
up
so i was able to be remarkably
consistent about what was good working
conditions for me for a very long time
um
i was never one of the programmers that
i that would do all-nighters going
through work for 20 hours straight it's
like my brain generally starts turning
to mush after 12 hours or so
i am
but the hard work is really important
and i would work for for decades i would
work 60 hours a week i would work a 10
hour day 6 days a week and try to be
productive at that now my schedule
shifted around a fair amount when i was
young without any kids i am any other
responsibilities i was on one of those
cycling schedules where i'd kind of get
in an hour later each day and roll
around through the entire time and
i'd wind up kind of pulling in at two or
three in the afternoon sometimes and
then working again past you know
midnight or two in the morning
and
that was i am
when it was just me trying to make
things happen i am and i was usually
isolated off in my office people
generally didn't bother me much uh at id
and i could get a lot of programming
work done
that way
i did settle into a more normal schedule
when i was taking kids to school and
things like that
so kids were the forcing function that
got you to wake up and
at the same time it's not clear to me
that there was a much of a difference in
the productivity with i with that where
i kind of feel if i just get up when i
feel like it it's usually a little later
each day but i just recently made the
focusing decision to try to push my
schedule back a little bit earlier to
getting up at eight in the morning and
trying to to shift things around like
i'm
i'm often doing experiments with myself
about what should i be doing to to be
more productive and one of the things
that i did realize was happening in
recent months where i would i would go
for a walk or a run i cover like four
miles a day and
and i would usually do that just as the
sun's going down at here in texas now
and it's still really damn hot but i'd
go out at 8 30 or something and cover
the time there and then the showering
and it was putting a hole in my day
where i would have still a couple hours
after that and sometimes my best hours
were at night when nobody else is around
nobody's bothering me but that hole in
the day was a problem so just a couple
weeks ago i made the pin the change to
go ahead and say all right i'm going to
get up a little earlier i'm going to do
a walk or get out there first so i can
have more uninterrupted time so i'm
still playing with factors like this as
i kind of optimize my
my work efforts but it's always been
you know it's it was 60 hours a week for
a very long time to some degree i had a
little thing in the back of my head
where i was almost jealous of some of
the programmers that would do these
marathon sessions and and i had like
dave taylor one of the guys that he had
he would be one of those people that
would fall asleep under his desk
sometimes and all the the kind of
classic hacker tropes about things and a
part of me was like i was a little
bothered that that wasn't me that i i
wouldn't go program
20 hours straight because i'm just i'm
falling apart and not being very
effective after 12 hours i mean yeah 12
hour programming that's fine when you're
doing that but
it never you're not doing smart work
much after at least i'm not but there's
a range of people i mean that's
something that a lot of people don't
really get in their gut where there are
people that work on four hours of sleep
and are smart and can continue to do
good work but then there's a lot of
people that just fall apart so i do tell
people that i always try to get eight
hours of sleep it's not this you know
push yourself harder get up earlier i
just do worse work where
uh you know there's you can work a
hundred hours a week and still get eight
hours of sleep if you just kind of
prioritize things correctly but i do
believe in working hard working a lot i
there was a comment that game dev made
that
that i know there's a backlash against
really hard work in a lot of cases and i
get into online arguments about this all
the time but he was basically saying
yeah 40 hours a week that's kind of a
part-time job and
if you were really in it you're doing
what you think is important what you're
passionate about
working more gets more done and i it's
just really not possible to argue with
that if you've been around the people
that that work with that level of
intensity and just say it's like no they
should just stop and we had
i kind of came back around to that a
couple years ago where i was using the
fictional example of
all right some people say they'll say
with a straight face they think no you
you are less productive if you work more
than 40 hours a week and they're
generally misinterpreting things where
your your marginal productivity for an
hour after eight hours is less than in
one of your peak hours but you're not
literally getting less done there is a
point where you start breaking things
and getting worse
worse behavior and everything out of it
where you're literally going backwards
but it's not at 8 or 10 or 12 hours and
the fictional example i would use was
imagine there's an asteroid coming to
impact you know to crash into earth
destroy all of human life i do you want
elon musk or the people working at
spacex that are building the interceptor
that's going to uh to deflect the
asteroid do you want them to clock out
at five because damn it they're just
going to go do worse work if they work
another couple hours and you know it
seems absurd
and that's a hypothetical though and
everyone can dismiss that but then when
coronavirus was hitting and you have all
of these medical personnel that are
clearly pushing themselves really really
hard and i'd say it's like okay do you
want all of these scientists working on
treatments and vaccines and caring for
all of these people are they really
screwing everything up by working more
than eight hours a day and of course
people say i'm just an [ __ ] to say
something like that but it's i you know
it's the truth working longer gets more
done well so that's kind of uh the layer
one but i'd like to also say that
at least i believe depending on the
person depending on the task
working more and harder
will make
you better for the for the next week in
those peak hours
so there's something about
a deep dedication to a thing
that's kind of gets deep in you so it's
the the hard work isn't just about the
raw hours of productivity it's the
it's the thing it does to you
in the in the weeks and months after too
you're tempering yourself in some ways
and i think you know it's like jiro
dreams of sushi if you really dedicate
yourself completely to making the sushi
like to really putting in the long hours
day after day after day
um you become a true craftsman of the
thing you're doing
now there's of course discussions about
are you sacrificing a lot of personal
relationships are you sacrificing a lot
of other possible
things you could do with that time but
if you're talking about purely
being
a master or craftsman of your art
that more hours isn't just about
doing more it's about becoming better at
the thing you're doing yeah and i don't
gain say anybody that wants to work the
minimum amount they've got other
priorities in their life my only
argument that i'm making it's not that
everybody should work hard it's that if
you want to accomplish something working
longer and harder is the path to getting
it accomplished
well let me ask you about this then uh
the the mythical work-life balance
is for an engineer it seems like that's
one of the professions in the
for programmer
where
working hard does lead to greater
productivity in it
but it also raises the question of um
sort of personal relationships and all
that kind of stuff family and
um how are you able to find work-life
balance is there advice you can give
maybe even outside yourself have you
been able to arrive at any wisdom on
this part in your years of life i do
think that there's a wide range of
people where different people have
different needs it's not a one size fits
all i am certainly what works for me i i
can tell enough that
i'm you know i'm different than a
typical average person and the way
things impact me the you know the things
that i want to do my goals are different
and sort of the levers to impact things
are different where
you know i've literally never felt
burnout and i know there's lots of
brilliant smart people that that do
world-leading work that get burned out
and it's never hit me i'm you know i've
never been at a point where i'm like i'm
i just don't care about this i don't
want to do this anymore but i've always
had the flexibility to work on lots of
interesting things you know i can always
just turn my gaze to something else and
have a great time working on that and so
much of that and so much of the ability
to actually work hard is the ability to
have multiple things to choose from and
to use use your time on the most
appropriate thing like there are there
are time periods where i am it's the
best time for me to read a new research
paper that i need to really be thinking
you know hard about it then there's a
time that maybe i should just scan and
organize my old notes because my you
know i'm just not on top of things then
there's the time that all right let's go
you know bang out a few hundred lines of
code for something
so switching between them
has been real valuable
so you'll always have kind of joy in
your heart for all the things you're
doing and that that is the kind of
work-life balance as a first sort of
step yeah you're always happy i do
happy yeah i mean that's like i a lot of
people would say that often i look like
kind of a grim person you know with just
sitting there with a neutral expression
or even like knitted brows and a frown
on my face as i'm staring at something
that's what my goodness looks like for
you yeah
it's it's kind of true or that that's
like okay i'm pushing through this i'm
making progress here
i am you know i know that doesn't work
for everyone i know it doesn't work for
most people i am but what i'm always
trying to do in those cases is i don't
want to let somebody that might be a
person like that be told by someone else
that no don't try it don't even try that
out as an option where
i you know work life
balance versus kind of your life's work
where
there's a small subset of the people
that can be very happy being obsessive
about things and you know obsession can
often get things done that just
practical prudent pedestrian work won't
or at least won't for a very long time
there's legends of uh your nutritional
intake uh in the early days uh what can
you say about
sort of as a you know
being a program as a kind of athlete so
what
what what was uh the nutrition that
fueled i have never been that great on i
on really paying attention to it where
i'm good enough that i i don't eat a lot
you know i've never been like a big
heavy guy but
uh it was interesting where one of the
things that i can remember being an
unhappy teenager not having enough money
and like one of the things that bothered
me about not having enough money is i
couldn't buy pizza whenever i wanted to
so i got rich and then i bought a whole
lot of pizza that was defining like
that's what being rich
like i could buy all the pizza and comic
books and video games that uh that i
wanted to and it really didn't take that
much but uh the pizza was one of those
things and it's absolutely true that for
a long time it did software i had a
pizza delivered every single day you
know the delivery guy knew me my name
and i didn't find out until years later
that apparently i was such a good
customer that they just never raised the
price on me and i was using this
six-year-old price for the pizzas that
they were still kind of sending my way
every day so you were doing um eating
once a day
or were you uh it would be spread out
you know you have a few pieces of pizza
you have some more later on and i'd
maybe have something at home i it was
one of the nice things that facebook
meta is they do they feed you quite well
you get a different i guess now it's
doordash sorts of things delivered but
uh they take care of making sure that
everybody does get well fed i probably
had better food those six years that i
was working in the meta office there
than i used to before but i've it's
worked out okay for me my health has
always been good i get a pretty good
amount of exercise and
i don't eat to excess and i avoid a lot
of other kind of not so good for you
things so i'm still doing quite well at
my age did you have a
a kind of
i don't know spiritual experience with
food or
coffee or any of that kind of stuff i
mean
you know the programming experience you
know with music and or
or like i listen to brown noise in a
program or like creating an environment
and the things you take into your body
just everything you construct can become
a kind of ritual that empowers the whole
process of the program did you have that
relationship with pizza or um it would
really be with diet coke there still is
that sense of you know drop the can down
crack open the can of diet coke all
right now i mean business we're getting
to work here but still to this day yeah
it's diet coke still part yeah probably
eight or nine a day
nice okay uh what about your setup how
many screens
what kind of keyboard is there something
interesting what kind of i
ide
emacs vim or something modern
uh linux what operating system laptop or
any any interesting thing that brings
you joy so i kind of migrated cultures
where early on through all of game dev
there was sort of one culture there
which was really quite distinct from the
more uh the silicon valley venture you
know uh culture for things it's they're
different groups and they have pretty
different mores in the way they think
about things where
and i still do think a lot of the big
companies can learn uh can learn things
from the the hardcore game development
side of things where it still boggles my
mind how
i am how hostile to debuggers and ides
that so much of the the kind of big
money get billions of dollars silicon
valley venture-backed funds are well
that's interesting sorry so you're
saying like
like uh big companies that google and
meta are hostile to they are not big on
debuggers and ides like so much of it is
like emacs bim for things and we just
assume that debuggers don't work most of
the time
for the systems and a lot of this comes
from a sort of linux bias on a lot of
things where i did come up through the
the personal computers and then the dos
and then i am you know windows and
and it was borland tools and then visual
studio and
do you appreciate the buggers
very much so i mean a debugger is how
you get a view into a system that's too
complicated to understand i mean anybody
that thinks just read the code and think
about it that's an insane statement in
the you can't even read all the code on
a big system you have to do experiments
on the system and doing that by adding
log statements recompiling and
re-running it uh is an incredibly
inefficient way of doing it i mean yes
you can always get things done even if
you're working with stone knives and you
know and bear skins that's that is the
mark of a good programmer is that given
any tools you will figure out a way to
get it done
but
it's amazing what you can do with
sometimes much much better tools where
instead of just going through this
iterative compile run debug cycle and
you have the
you have the old lisp direction of like
you've got a repel and you're working
interactively and doing amazing things
there but in many cases a debugger has a
very powerful user interface that can
stop examine all the different things in
your program set all these different
break points and of course you can do
that with gdb or whatever there but
this is one of the user interface
fundamental principles where when
something is complicated to do
you won't use it very often there's
people that will break out gdb when
they're at their wit's end and they just
have beat their head against a problem
for so long but for somebody that kind
of grew up in game dev it's like they
were running into the debugger anyways
before they even knew there was a
problem and you would just stop and see
you know what was happening and
sometimes you could fix things even
before you you know
even before you did one compile cycle
you could be in the debugger and you
would say well i'm just going to change
this right here and yep that did the job
and fix it and go on and for people who
don't know gdb is a of popular i guess
linux debugger
uh
primarily for c plus plus
they they handle most of the languages
but it's you know it's based on c as the
the original kind of unix heritage and
it's kind of like command line it's not
user friendly it's not it doesn't allow
for clean visualizations and you're
you're exactly right so you're using
this kind of debugger usually when
you're what's end and there's a problem
that you can't figure out why by just
looking at the codes they have to find
it that's how i guess normal programmers
use it but you're saying there should be
tools that kind of
visualize and help you as part of the
programming process
just the normal programming process to
to understand the code deeper yeah when
i'm working on like my cc plus code i'm
always running it from the debugger you
know just i type in the code i i run it
many times the first thing i do after
writing code is set a breakpoint and
step through the function now other
people say it's like oh i do that in my
head well your head is a faulty
interpreter of all those things there
and i've written brand new code i want
to step in there and i'm going to single
step through that examine lots of things
and see if it's actually doing what i
expected it to
it is a kind of companion the debugger
like it you're you're now coding in an
interactive way with another
being
uh a debugger is a kind of dumb being
but it's a reliable being it's that is
an interesting question of what role
does ai play in that kind of
with codex and these kind of
ability to generate code
might be you might start having tools
that
understand the code in interesting deep
ways that can work with you because
there's a whole spectrum there from
static code analyzers and various kind
of dynamic tools they're up to ai that
can conceivably grok these programs that
no literally no human can understand
they're they're too big too intertwined
and too interconnected but it's not
beyond the possibility of understanding
it's just beyond what we can hold in our
heads as kind of mutable state while
we're working on things
and
and i'm a big proponent again of things
like static analyzers and some of that
stuff where
you'll find some people that don't like
being scolded by a program for how
they've written something where it's
like oh i know better and sometimes you
do but that was something that
i was it was very
very valuable for me when
and not too many people get an
opportunity like this to have this is
almost one of those spiritual
experiences as a programmer an awakening
to
i am the in software code bases were a
couple million lines of code and at one
point i had used a few of the different
analysis tools but i made a point to
really go through and scrub the code
base using every tool that i could find
and it was eye opening where we had a
reputation for having some of the the
most robust strongest code you know
where there were some you know great
things that i remember hearing from like
microsoft telling us about crashes on
xbox and we had this tiny number that
they said were were probably literally
hardware errors and then you have other
significant titles that just have
millions of faults that are getting
recorded all the time so i was proud of
our code on a lot of levels but when i
took this code analysis squeegee through
everything
it was
it was shocking how many errors there
were in there things that you can say
okay this was this was a copy paste not
changing something right here lots of
things that were you know the most the
most common problem was something in a
printf format string that was the wrong
data type that could cause crashes there
and you know you really want the
warnings for things like that then the
next most common was missing a check for
null that could actually happen that
could blow things up and those are
obviously like top cc plus things
everybody has those problems but the
long tail of all of the different little
things that could go wrong there and we
had good programmers and my own codes
that i'd be looking at it's like oh i
wrote that code that's definitely wrong
we've been using this for a year and
it's this submarine you know this mine
sitting there waiting for us to step on
and
it was humbling it was uh and i reached
the conclusion that
anything that can be syntactically
allowed in your language
if i'm it's going to show up eventually
in a large enough code base i you're not
going to good intentions aren't going to
keep it from happening you need
automated tools and guardrails for
things and those start with things like
static types and or even type hints in
the more dynamic languages but
the people that rebel against that that
basically say uh that slows me down
doing that there's something to that i
get that i've written you know i've
cobbled things together in a notebook i
am like wow this is great that it just
happened but yeah that's kind of sketchy
but it's working fine i don't care it
does come back to that that value
analysis where sometimes it's right to
not care
but when you do care if it's going to be
something that's going to live for years
and it's going to have other people
working on it i and it's going to be
deployed to millions of people then you
want to use all of these tools you want
to be told it's like no you've screwed
up here here and here and that does
require kind of an ego check about
things where you have to
to be open to the fact that everything
that you're doing is just littered with
flaws it's not that oh you occasionally
have a bad day it's just whatever stream
of code you output there is going to be
a statistical regularity of things that
you just make mistakes on
and i'm and i do think there's the whole
argument about test driven design and
unit testing versus kind of analysis and
different things
i am more in favor of the analysis and
the stuff that just like you can't run
your program until you fix this rather
than you can run it and hopefully a unit
test will catch it in some way yeah in
my private code i have asserts
everywhere yeah uh it's just there's
something
pleasant to me pleasurable to me about
sort of the dictatorial rule of like
this should be true at this point
in too many times
i've
made mistakes
that shouldn't have been made
and i would assume i would i wouldn't be
the kind of person that would make that
mistake but i keep making that mistake
therefore and assert really catches me
uh really helps all the time so my co i
would say like 10 to 20 of my private
code just for personal use is probably a
certain and they're active comments one
of those things in theory they don't
they don't make any difference to the
program and if it was all operating the
way you expected it would be then i they
will never fire but even if you have it
right and you wrote the code right
initially then circumstances change the
world outside your program changes and
in fact that's that's one of the things
where i'm kind of fond in a lot of cases
of static array size declarations where
i went through this period where it's
like okay now we have general collection
classes we should just make everything
variable i because i had this history of
in the early days you get doom which had
some fixed limits on it then everybody
started making crazier and crazier
things and they kept bumping up the
different limits this many lines this
many sectors uh and it seemed like a
good idea well we should just make this
completely generic it can go kind of go
up to whatever
and
there's cases where that's the right
thing to do
but it also the other aspect of the
world changing around you is it's good
to be informed when the world has
changed more than you thought it would
and if you've got a continuously growing
collection you're never going to find
out you might have this quadratic
slowdown on something where you thought
oh i'm only ever going to have a handful
of these but something changes and
there's a new design style and all of a
sudden you've got 10 000 of them
so i kind of like in many cases
picking a number some you know nice
round power of two number and setting it
up in there and having an assert saying
it's like hey you hit the you hit this
limit you should probably think are the
choices that you've made around all of
this still relevant if somebody's using
10 times more than you thought they
would yeah this code was originally
written with this kind of world view
with this kind of set of constraints you
were you were thinking of the world in
this way
if something breaks that means you got
to rethink the initial stuff and that's
it's nice for it to afford for it to do
that is there any stuff like uh keyboard
or
monitors i'm fairly pedestrian on a lot
of that where i i did move to triple
monitors like in the last several years
ago i had been dual monitor for a very
long time and i am and it was one of
those things where
probably years later than i should have
i'm just like well the video cards now
generally have three output ports i
should just put the third monitor up
there that's been a that's been a pure
win i've been very happy with that
but no i don't have fancy keyboard or
mouse or anything really the key things
is an ide that has uh helpful debuggers
has helpful tools so it's not the emax
vim route and then diet coke yeah so i
did spend you know i spent uh one of my
week-long retreats where i'm like okay
i'm gonna make myself use uh is actually
classic vi which i know people will say
you should never have done that you
should have just used vim directly but
you know i gave it the good try it's
like okay i'm being in kind of classic
unix developer mode here and i worked
for
a week on it i used anki to like teach
myself the the different little key
combinations for things like that and in
the end it was just like all right this
was kind of like my civil war
reenactment phase you know it's like i'm
going out there doing it like they used
to in the old days and it was kind of
fun in that regard so many people right
now
screaming as they're listening to this
so again the out is that this was not
modern vim but still i yes i was very
happy to get back to my visual studio at
the end yeah i'm actually i struggle
with this a lot because
so use a kinesis keyboard and um
i use emacs primarily
and i i feel like i can
exactly as you said i can understand the
code i can navigate the code there's a
lot of stuff you could build within
emacs with using lisp you can customize
a lot of things for yourself to help you
uh introspect the code like to help you
understand the code and visualize
different aspects of the call you can
even run debuggers but it's it's work
and uh the world moves past you and the
better and better ideas are constantly
being built and that that puts a
kind of
i need to take the same kind of retreat
as you're talking about but now i'm
still fighting the civil war i need to
kind of move into the 21st century and
it does seem like the world is or a
large chunk of the world is moving
towards visual studio code which is kind
of interesting to me against the
javascript ecosystem on the one hand and
ids are one of those things that you
want to be infinitely fast you want them
to just kind of immediately respond
and like i mean heck i've got there's
someone i know i'm an old school game
dev guy that still uses visual studio
six and on a modern computer everything
is just absolutely instant on something
like that because it was made to work on
a computer that's
ten thousand or a hundred thousand times
slower so just everything happens
immediately and all the modern systems
just feel
you know they feel so crufty when it's
like oh why is this refreshing the
screen and moving around and updating
over here and something blinks down
there and you should update this and
there's
you know there there are things that
we've lost with that incredible
flexibility but
uh lots of people get tons of value from
it and i am super happy that that seems
to be winning over even a lot of the old
vim and emacs people that they're kind
of like hey visual studio codes maybe
you know not so bad i am that may be the
final peacekeeping solution where
everybody is reasonably happy with i
with something like that
so can you explain what a dot plan file
is and what role that played in your
life does it still continue to play a
role
back in the early early days of id
software uh one of our big things that
was unique with what we did is i had
adopted next stations or kind of next
step systems from i steve jobs is
out in the out in the woods away from
apple company
and
i they were basically it was kind of
interesting because i did not really
have a background with the unix system
so many of the people they get immersed
in that in college and i you know and
that's you know that sets a lot of
cultural expectations for them and i
didn't have any of that uh but i knew
that
my background was i was a huge apple ii
fanboy i'm i was always a little
suspicious of the mac i was not really
what i what kind of i wanted to to go
with but when steve jobs left apple and
started next uh this computer did just
seem like one of those amazing things
from the future where it had all of this
cool stuff in it and we were still back
in those days working on dos everything
blew up you had reset buttons because
your computer would just freeze if
you're doing development work literally
dozens of times a day your computer was
just rebooting constantly
and so this idea of yes any of the the
unix workstations would have given a
stable development platform where you
don't crash and reboot all the time but
next also had this really amazing
graphical interface and it was great for
building tools and it used uh objective
c as the kind of an interesting oh wow
dead interesting next was unix-based
it said objective-c so it has a lot of
the elements that became mac i mean the
kind of reverse acquisition of apple by
next where that took over and became
what uh what the modern mac system is
and to find some of the developer um
like uh the tools and the whole
community yeah you've still got if
you're programming on apple stuff now
there's still all these ns somethings
which was originally next step objects
of different kinds of things
but one of the the aspects of those
those unix systems was they had this
notion of a dot plan file where you know
a dot file is a you know an invisible
file you unless usually in your home
directory or something and there was a
trivial server running on most unix
systems at the time
that i
that when somebody ran a trivial little
command called finger you could do
finger and then somebody's address it
could be anywhere on the internet if you
were connected correctly then all that
server would do was read the the dot
plan file in that user's home directory
and then just spit it out to you and
originally the idea was that could be
whether you're on vacation what your
current project was it's supposed to be
like the plan of what you're doing and
people would use it for you know various
purposes but all it did was dump that
file over the to the terminal of whoever
issued the the finger command
and
you know at one point i started just
keeping a list of what i was doing in
there which would be what i was working
on in the day and i would have this
little
syntax i kind of got to myself about uh
here's something that i'm working on i
put a star when i finish it i could have
a few other little bits of punctuation
and at the time it was it started off as
being just like my to-do list and it
would be these trivial obscure little
things like i you know fixed something
with collision detection code made imp
fireball do something different and just
little one-liners that people that were
following the games could kind of
decipher
but i did wind up
starting to write much more in-depth
things i would have
little notes of
thoughts and insights and then i would
eventually start having little essays i
would sometimes dump into the dot plan
files interspersed with the work logs of
things that i was doing so in some ways
it was like a super early proto blog
where i was just kind of dumping out
what i was working on but it was
interesting enough that there were a lot
of people
that uh that were interested in this so
most of the people didn't have unix
workstations so there were the websites
uh back in the day that would follow the
doom and quake development that would i
would basically make a little service
that would go grab all the changes and
then people could just get it with a web
browser and there was a period where
like all of the little kind of dallas
gaming diaspora of people that were at
all in that orbit there were a couple
dozen plan files going on which was
and this was some years before blogging
really became kind of a thing and it was
kind of a
i'm a premonition of sort of the way
things would go and there was
it's all been collected it's available
online in different places and it's kind
of fun to go back and look through what
i was thinking uh what i was doing in
the different areas have you had a
chance to look back is there some
interesting
very low level specific to do items
maybe things you've never completed all
that kind of stuff and high level
philosophical essay type of stuff uh
there's some yeah there's some good
stuff on both where
a lot of it was low-level nitpicky
details about game dev and
i'm you know i've learned enough things
where there's no project that i worked
on that i couldn't go back and do a
better job on now i mean you just you
learn things hopefully if you're doing
it right you learn things as you get
older and you should be able to do a
better job at all of the early things
there's stuff in wolfenstein doom quake
that's like oh clearly i could go back
and do a better job at this whether it's
something in the rendering engine side
or how i implemented the the monster
behaviors or managed resources do you
see the flaws in your thinking now
looking back yeah i do i mean sometimes
i'll get the
you know i'll look at it and say yeah i
had a pretty clear view of i was doing
good work there
and i haven't really hit the point where
there was another programmer graham
devine who was i he had worked at id and
seventh guest and and he made some
comment one time where he said he looked
back at some of his old notes he was
like wow i was really smart back then
and i
i don't hit that so much where i mean i
look at it and i always know that yeah
there's all the you know with aging you
get certain changes in in how you you're
able to work problems but all of the
problems that i've worked i i'm you know
i'm sure that i could do a better job on
all of them oh wow so you can still step
right in if you could travel back in
time and talk to that guy you would
teach him a few things yeah absolutely
that's awesome
um what about the high level
philosophical stuff is there some
insights that stand out that you
remember
there's things that
that i was understanding about
development and i'm you know in the
industry and so on that were in a in a
more primitive stage where
i am
i definitely learned a lot more in the
later years about business and
organization and team structure
there were
i mean there were definitely things that
i was not the best person or even a very
good person about managing like how a
team should operate internally how
people should work together i was just
i'm you know the
just get out of my way and let me work
on the code and do this and more and
more i've learned how
in the larger scheme of things how
sometimes relatively unimportant some of
those things are where it is this user
value generation that's the the
overarching importance for all of that
and i i didn't necessarily have my eye
on that ball correctly through a lot of
my you know my earlier years
and there's things that
you know i could have i could have
gotten more out of people handling
things in different ways i am you know i
could have made
you know in some ways more successful
products by following things in
different ways there's mistakes that we
made that we couldn't really have have
known how things would have worked out
but it was interesting to see in later
years companies like activision showing
that hey you really can just do the same
game make it better every year and you
can look at that from a negative
standpoint and say it's like oh that's
just being derivative and all that but
if you step back again and say it's like
no are the people buying it still
enjoying it are they enjoying it more
than what they might have bought
otherwise and you can say no that's
that's actually a great value creation
engine to do that if you're in a
position where you can
i you know don't be forced into
reinventing everything just because you
think that you need to
um
you know lots of things about
business and team stuff that could be
done better but the technical work the
kind of technical visionary type stuff
that i late i laid out i still feel
pretty good about there are some classic
old ones about my defending of opengl
versus d3d i'm which
uh turned out to be one of the more
probably important momentous things
there where
it never it was always a rearguard
action on windows where microsoft was
just not going to let that win
but when i look back on it now
that fight to keep opengl relevant for a
number of years there
meant that opengl was there when mobile
started happening and opengl es was the
thing that drove all of the acceleration
of the mobile industry and it's really
only in the last few years as apple's
moved to metal and some of the other
companies have moved to vulcan that
that's moved away
but
really stepping back and looking at it
it's like yeah i sold tens of millions
of games for different things
but
billions and billions of devices wound
up with an appropriate capable graphics
api due in no small part to me thinking
that that was really important that we
not just i you know give up and use
microsoft's um
at that time really terrible api you
know the thing about microsoft is the
apis don't stay terrible they were
terrible at the start but a few versions
on they were actually quite good and
there was a completely fair argument to
be made that by the time dx9 was out it
was probably a better programming
environment than opengl but it was still
a wonderful good thing that we had an
open standard that could show up on
linux and android and ios eventually
webgl still to this day
so uh that was that was one that would
be on my greatest hits list of things
that that i got impacted
on billions of devices yes
so let's talk about it can you tell the
origin story of its software
again one of the greatest game developer
companies ever it created wolfenstein 3d
games that define
my life also in many ways
as a thing that made me realize what
computers are capable of in terms of
graphics in terms of performance it just
unlocks something deep
um in me and understanding what these
machines are all about those games can
do that so wolfenstein 3d doom quake
and uh just all the incredible
engineering innovation that went into
that so how did it all start
so i'll caveat up front that i usually
don't consider myself the the historian
of the software side of things i usually
do
i kind of point people at john romero
for stories about the early days where
i you know i've never been like i've
commented that i'm a remarkably
unsentimental person in some ways where
i don't really spend a lot of time
unless i'm explicitly prodded to go back
and and think about the early days of
things and i didn't i i didn't
necessarily
make the effort to archive everything
exactly in my brain and the more that i
work on machine learning and ai and the
aspects of memory and how when you go
back and polish certain things it's not
necessarily exactly the way it happened
but you know having said all of that
from from my view the way everything
happened that led up to that
was uh after i was
an adult and kind of taking a few
college classes deciding to drop out i
was doing i was hard scrabble contract
programming work really struggling to
kind of keep groceries and pay my rent
and things and the company that i was
doing the most work for was a company
called soft disk publishing which
had the sounds bizarre now business
model of monthly subscription software
you know before there was an internet
that people could connect to and get
software you would pay you know a
certain amount and every month they
would send you a disk that had some
random software on it and people that
were into computers thought this was
kind of cool and they had different ones
for the apple ii the the 2gs the pc the
mac the uh amiga lots of different
things here so quirky little business
but i was doing a lot of contract
programming for them where i'd write
tiny little games and sell them for 300
and one of the things that
that i was doing again to keep my head
above water here was i decided that i
could make one program and i could
port it to multiple systems so i would
write a game like dark designs or
catacombs and i would develop it on the
apple ii the 2gs and the ibm pc
which apparently was the thing that
really kind of piqued the attention of
the the people working down there like j
wilbur was my primary editor and tom
hall was a secondary editor and they
kept asking me it's like hey you should
come down and work for us here
and i i pushed it off a couple times
because i was really enjoying my freedom
of kind of being off on my own even if i
was barely getting by i loved it i was
doing nothing but programming all day
but i did have enough close scrapes with
like damn i'm just really out of money
that maybe i should um get an actual job
rather than contracting these kind of
one at a time things and and j wilbur
was great he was like fedexing me the
checks when i would need them i
to kind of get over whatever hump i was
at
so i took the i finally took them up on
their offer to come down to shreveport
louisiana i was in kansas city at the
time
drove down um to through the ozarks and
everything down to
louisiana and saw the soft disk offices
went through talked to a bunch of people
met the people i had been working with
remotely at that time but the most
important thing for me was i met two
programmers there john romero and lane
roth that for the first time ever i had
met programmers that knew more cool
stuff than i did where the world was
just different back then i was in kansas
city it was one of those smartest kid in
the school does all the computer stuff
the teachers don't have anything to
teach him but all i had to learn from
was these few books at the library it
was not much at all and there were some
aspects of programming that were kind of
black magic to me like it's like oh he
knows how to format a track on i am you
know on a low-level drive programming
interface
and this was i was still not at all sure
i was going to take the job but i met
these awesome programmers that were
doing cool stuff and when romero had
worked at origin systems and he had done
like you know so many different games
ahead of time
that i did kind of quickly decides like
yeah i'll go take the job down there
and
i
settled down there
moved in and started working on more
little projects and the first kind of
big change that happened down there was
the company wanted to make a gaming
focused a pc gaming focused subscription
uh just like all their others the same
formula that they used for everything
pay a monthly fee and you'll get
a disc with one or two games just every
month and no choice in what you get but
we think it'll be fun and that was the
model they were comfortable with and
said all right we're going to start this
gamer's edge department and
all of us that were interested in that
like me romero i'm tom hall was kind of
helping us from from his side of things
jay would peek in and we had a few other
programmers
uh working with us at the time and we
were going to to just start making games
just the same model i am and we dived in
and it was fantastic you have to make
new games every month every month yeah
and this in retrospect looking back at
it that sense that i had done all this
contract programming and john romero had
done like far more of this where he had
done one of his teaching himself efforts
was he made a game for every letter of
the alphabet it's that sense of like i'm
just gonna go make 26 different games
give them a different theme and you
learn so much when you go through and
you cr crank these things out like on a
bi-weekly monthly basis something starts
to finish so it's not like a night just
an idea it's not just you from from the
very beginning to the very end
it's done it has to be done there's no
delaying it's done and you've got
deadlines and that kind of uh rapid
iteration pressure cooker environment
was super important for all of us
developing the skills that i you know
that brought us to where we eventually
went to i mean people would say like
like in the history of the beatles like
it wasn't them being the beatles it was
them playing all of these other uh you
know early works that that opportunity
to craft all of their skills before they
were famous that was very critical to
their later successes and i think
there's a lot of that here where we did
these games that nobody remembers uh
lots of little things that contributed
to building up the skill set for the
things that eventually did make us
famous
yeah dostoevsky wrote the gambler
i had to write it in a month
just make money
and nobody remembers that probably
because he had to figure out because
it's literally
he
he didn't have enough time to write it
fast enough so to come up with hacks
actually literally but it again comes
down to that point where pressure and
limitation of resources
is surprisingly important
and it's counter-intuitive in a lot of
ways where you just think that if you've
got all the time in the world and you've
got all the resources in the world of
course you're going to get something
better but sometimes it really does work
out that the you know
innovations mother necessity and you
know where you can are yeah resource
constraints and you have to do things
when you don't have a choice
it's surprising what you can do is there
any good games written in that time
would you say some of them are still fun
to go back and play where you get the
they were they were all about kind of
the more modern term is game feel about
how just the exact feel that things it's
not the grand strategy of the design but
how running and jumping and shooting and
those things i feel in the in the moment
and some of those are still if you sat
down at them you kind of go it's a
little bit different it doesn't have the
same movement feel but you move over and
you're like bang jump bang it's like hey
that's kind of cool still so you can get
lost in the rhythm of the game like the
the is that what you mean by feel
just like uh there's something about it
that pulls you in
nowadays again people talk about
compulsion loops and things where it's
that i am that sense of exactly what
you're doing what your fingers are doing
on the keyboard what your eyes are
seeing and there are going to be these
sequences of things grab the loot shoot
the monster jump over the obstacle get
to the end of the level these are
eternal aspects of game design in a lot
of ways but there are better and worse
ways to do all of them and we did so
many of these games that it was i we got
a lot of practice with it so
one of the kind of weird things that was
happening at this time is john romero
was getting some uh some strange fan
mail and back in the days this is before
email so we literally got letters
sometimes and telling him it's like oh i
want to talk to you about your games i
wanna
reached out different things
and
eventually it turned out that these were
all coming from scott miller at apogee
software
and he was reaching out through he
didn't think he could contact john
directly that he would get intercepted
so he was trying to get him to contact
him through like back channel fan mail
because he basically was saying hey i'm
making all this money on shareware games
i want you to make shareware games
because he had seen some of the the
games that romero had done
and you know we looked at uh scott
miller's games and we didn't think they
were very good i am we're like
that can't be making the kind of money
that he's saying he's making 10 grand or
something i am off of this game and we
really thought that he was full of [ __ ]
that it was a lie trying to get
to get him into this but so that was
kind of going on at i am you know at one
level he was
and it was funny the moment when romero
realized that he had some of these
letters pinned up on his wall of like
all of his fans and then we noticed that
they all had the same return address
with different names on them which was a
little bit of a two-edged sword there
trying to figure out the puzzle laid off
yeah before him yeah what happened after
i kind of coincident with that was i was
working on a lot of the new technologies
where uh i was now full on the ibm pc
for the first time where i was really a
long hold out on apple ii forever and i
you know i loved my apple it was the
computer i always wished i had when i
was growing up and when i finally did
have one i was i was kind of clinging on
to that well past it sort of good used
by the best computer ever made would you
say
um
i wouldn't make judgments like that
about it but it was positioned in such a
way especially in the school systems
that it impacted a whole lot of american
programmers at least where there was
programs that the apple twos got into
the schools and they had enough
capability that lots of interesting
things happened with them you know in
europe it was different you had your
amigas and ataris and you know um acorns
in the uk and things that that had
different things but in the united
states it was probably the apple ii made
the most impact for
a lot of programmers of my generation
but so i was really digging into the ibm
and this was even more so with the total
focus because i had moved to another
city where i didn't know anybody that i
wasn't working with i had a little
apartment and then at soft disk again
the things that that drew me to it i had
a couple programmers that knew more than
i did uh and they had a library they had
a set of books and a set of magazines
they had a couple years of magazines the
old dr dobbs journal and all of these
magazines that had
information about things and so
i was just in total immersion mode it
was eat breathe sleep computer
programming particularly the ibm for
everything that i was doing and i was
digging into a lot of these low-level
hardware details that people weren't
usually paying attention to the way the
the ibm ega cards worked um which was
fun for me i hadn't had experience with
things at that level and back then you
could get hardware documentation just
down at the register levels this is
where the crtc register is this is how
the the color registers work and how the
different things are applied and they
were designed for a certain reason they
were designed for an application they
were had an intended use in mind but i
was starting to look at
other ways that they could perhaps be
exploited that they weren't initially
intended for because you're coming on
like uh first of all what operating
system was there what what instruction
set was it like what what what are the
what are we talking about so this was
dawson x86 so 16-bit uh 8086 the 286s
were there and 386's existed they were
rare uh we had a couple for our
development systems but uh we were still
targeting the more broad i
it was all dos 16-bit um none of this
was kind of dos extenders and things how
different is it from the systems of
today's it's kind of a precursor that's
similar very little if you open up
command.exe
on or com on windows you see some of the
remnants of all of that but it was a
different world it was the 640k is
enough world and nothing was protected
it crashed all the time you had tsrs or
terminate and stay resident hacks on top
of things that would cause configuration
problems all the hardware was manually
configured in your auto exec so it was a
very different world but the code is
still the same similar you would say you
could still write it my earliest code
there was written in pascal that was
what i had learned i am kind of an
earlier point so between basic and c
plus plus there's pascal so when basic
assembly language um some of my
yeah my intermediate stuff was well you
had to for performance basic was just
too slow so most of the work that i was
doing as a contract programmer in my
teenage years was uh was assembly
language but then i wrote games in
assembly yeah complete games in assembly
language
and it's thousands and thousands of
lines of three-letter acronyms for the
the instructions that's you don't earn
the once again greatest programmer ever
label without being able to eradicate an
assembly okay that's again everybody
wrote there everybody serious wrote
their games in assembly language it was
kind of serious you see what he said
yeah everybody's serious yeah it was an
outlier to use uh pascal a little bit
where there was one famous program
called wizardry it was like one of the
great early role-playing games that was
written in pascal but it was almost
nothing used pascal there but i did
learn pascal and i remember doing all of
my like to this day i sketch in data
structures when i'm thinking about
something i'll you know i'll i'll open
up a file and i'll start writing struct
definitions for how data is going to be
laid out and pascal was kind of
formative to that because i remember
designing my rpgs in pascal record
structures and things like that and so i
had i've gotten the pascal compiler for
the apple 2gs that i could work on and
the first ibm game that i developed i
did in pascal and and that's actually
kind of an interesting story again
talking about the constraints and
resources where i had an apple 2gs i
didn't have an ibm pc i wanted to port
my applications to ibm because i thought
i could make more money on it so what i
wound up doing is i rented a pc for a
week
and bought a copy of turbo pascal and so
i had a hard one week and this was
cutting into what minimal profit margin
i had there but i had this computer for
a week i had to get my program ported
before i had to return the pc
yeah and that was kind of what the first
thing that i had done on the ibm pc and
what led me to the taking the job at
soft disk and turbo pascal
uh how's that different from regular
pascal is a different compiler or
something like that so it was uh it was
a product of borland which before
microsoft kind of killed them they were
they were the hot stuff developer tools
company yeah borland turbo pascal and
turbo c and turbo prologue i mean all
the different things but what they did
was they took a supremely pragmatic
approach of making something useful it
was one of these great examples where
pascal was an academic language and you
had things like the ucsdp system that
wizardry was actually written in that
they did they did manage to make a game
with that but it was
not a super practical system well turbo
pascal was it was called turbo because
it was blazingly fast to compile i mean
really ridiculously 10 to 20 times
faster than most other compilers at the
time but it also had very pragmatic
access to look you can just poke at the
hardware in these different ways and we
have libraries that let you do things
and it was a pretty good it was a
perfectly good way to write games and
this is one of those things where people
have talked about
different paths that computer
development could have taken where c
took over the world for uh reasons that
came out of unix and eventually linux
and
and that was not a foregone conclusion
at all and people can make
real reasoned rational arguments that
the world might have been better if it
had gone a pascal route i'm somewhat
agnostic on that where i do know from
experience it was perfectly good enough
to do uh do that and it had some
fundamental improvements like it had
range checked arrays as an option there
which could avoid many of c's real
hazards that happened in a security
space but c1 they were basically
operating at about the same level of
abstraction it was a systems programming
language
but visa pascal had more emphasis on
data structures i actually i um in the
in the tree of languages dipascal come
before sea
did it they were primarily
contemporaneous so pascal's lineage went
to modula 2 and eventually oberon which
was another
nicholas word
kind of experimental language but they
were all good enough at that level now
some of the classic academic-oriented
pascals were just missing fundamental
things like oh you can't access this
core system thing because we're just
using it to teach students but turbo
pascal showed that only modest changes
to it really did make it a completely
capable language and it had some reasons
why you could implement it as a single
pass compiler so it could be way way
faster although less scope for
optimizations if you do it that way uh
and it did have some range checking
options it had a little bit better
typing capability you'd have properly
typed enum sorts of things and other
stuff that c lacked but you know c was
also clearly good enough and it wound up
with a huge inertia from the unix
ecosystem and everything
with that garbage collection no it was
not garbage collected same kind of thing
same manual so you could still have your
use after freeze and all those other
problems but over um just getting rid of
array overruns at least if you were
compiled with that debugging option
certainly would have avoided a lot of
problems and could have a lot of
benefits but so anyways that was the
next thing i had to learn c because c
was where it seemed like most of the
most of the things were going so i
abandoned pascal and i started working
in c i started hacking on these hardware
things dealing with uh you know the
graphics controllers and the ega systems
and what we most wanted to do so at that
time we had
uh we were sitting in our darkened
office playing all the the different
console video games we're figuring out
what do we want to kind of what games do
we want to make for our gamer's edge
product there and so we had one of the
one of the first super nintendos sitting
there and we had a an older nintendo
looking at all those games and the core
thing that those consoles did that you
just didn't get on the pc games was this
ability to have a massive scrolling
world where most of the games that you
would make on the pc uh and early
earlier personal computers would be a
static screen you move little things
around on it
and you interact like that maybe you go
to additional screens as you know as you
move
but arcade games and consoles had this
wonderful ability to just have a big
world that you're slowly moving your
window through and that was for those
types of games the kind of action
exploration adventure games that was a
super super important thing
and pc games just didn't do that
and what i had had come across was a
couple different techniques for
implementing that on the pc and they're
not
hard complicated things when i explain
them now they're they're they're pretty
straightforward but just nobody was
doing you sound like einstein describing
his five papers is pretty
straightforward i understand but it
they're nevertheless revolutionary so
side scrolling is a game changer yeah
it's scrolling genius invention vertical
and some of the consoles had different
limitations about you could do one but
not the other and i and there were
similar things going on as advancements
even in the console space where you'd
have like the original mario game was uh
like just horizontal scrolling and then
later mario games added vertical aspects
to it and different things that uh that
you were doing to explore you know kind
of expand the capabilities there and so
much of the early game design for
decades was removing limitations letting
you do things that you envisioned as a
designer you wanted the player to
experience but the hardware just
couldn't really uh or you didn't know
how to make it happen it felt impossible
you can imagine that you want to create
a like this big world through which you
can side scroll like through which you
can walk
uh and then you ask yourself a question
how do i actually build that in a way
that's uh
like the latency is low enough
uh the hardware can actually deliver
that in such a way that's a compelling
yeah and we knew what we wanted to do
because we were we were playing all of
these console games playing all these
nintendo games and arcade games clearly
there was a whole world of awesome
things there that we just couldn't do on
the pc at least initially
because every programmer can tell it's
like if you want to scroll you can just
redraw the whole screen but then it
turns out well you're going five frames
per second i that's not an interactive
fun experience you want to be going 30
or 60 frames per second or something and
it just didn't feel like that was
possible it felt like the pcs had to get
five times faster for you to make a
playable game there
and
interestingly i wound up with two
completely different solutions for the
scrolling problem and this is i'm
this is a theme that runs through
everything where all of these big
technical advancements it turns out
there's always a couple different ways
of doing them and it's not like you
found the one true way of doing it and
we'll see this as we go into 3d games
and things later but so the scrolling
the first set of scrolling tricks that i
got was
there was the hardware had this ability
to uh you could shift like inside the
window of memory i am so the ega cards
at the time had 256 kilobytes of memory
and it was awkwardly set up in this
planar format where uh instead of having
256 or you know 24 million colors you
had 16 colors which is four bits so you
had four bit planes 64k apiece of course
64k is a nice round number for 16-bit
addressing so your graphics card had a
16-bit window that you could look at and
you could tell it to start the video
scan out anywhere inside there so there
were a couple games that had taken this
approach if you could make a two by two
screen or a one by four screen and you
could do scrolling really easily like
that you could just lay it all out and
just pan around there but you just
couldn't make it any bigger because
that's all the memory that was there
uh the first insight to the scrolling
that i had was well if we make a screen
that's just one tile larger you know in
the we usually had tiles that were 16
pixels by 16 pixels the little classic
mario block that you run into
lots of art gets drawn that way and your
screen is a certain number of tiles but
if you had one little buffer region uh
outside of that you could easily pan
around inside that 16 pixel region that
could be perfectly smooth but then what
happens if you get to the edge and you
want to keep going
the first way we did scrolling was what
i called adaptive tile refresh which was
really just a matter of you get to the
edge and then you go back to the
original point and then only change the
tiles that have actually that are
different between where it was in most
of the games at the time if you think
about sort of your classic super mario
brothers game you've got big fields of
blue sky uh long rows of the same brick
texture
and there's a lot of commonality it's
kind of like a data compression thing if
you take the screen and you set it down
on top of each other in general only
about 10 percent of the tiles were
actually different there so this was a
way to
go ahead and say well i'm going to move
it back and then i'm only going to
change those 10 20 uh whatever percent
tiles there and that meant that it was
essentially five times faster than if
you were redrawing all of the tiles and
that worked well enough for us to do a
bunch of these games for i am for
gamer's edge we had a lot of these
scrolling games like slordax and shadow
knights and
things like that that we were cranking
out at this high rate that had this
scrolling effect on it
and it worked well enough there were
design challenges there where if you
made the worst case if you made a
checkerboard over the entire screen you
scroll over one and every single tile
changes and your frame rate's now five
frames per second because it had to
redraw everything so the designers had a
little bit that they had to worry about
they had to make these relatively plain
looking levels but it was still pretty
magical it was something that we hadn't
seen before
and
uh the first thing that we wound up
doing with that was i had just gotten
this working and tom hall was sitting
there with me and we were looking over
at our super nintendo on the side there
with super mario 3 running and we had
the technology we had the tools set up
there and we stayed up all night and we
basically cloned the first level of
super mario brothers performance wise as
well yeah and so it and we had our
little character running and jumping in
there it was you know it wasn't
uh it was close to pixel accurate as far
as all the uh the backgrounds and
everything but the gaming was just stuff
that we cobbled together from previous
games that i had written i just kind of
like really kit-bashed the whole thing
together to make this demo
and that was one of the rare cases when
i said i i don't usually do these
all-night programming things there's
probably only two memorable ones that i
can think about you know one was the
all-nighter to go ahead and get i am to
get our dangerous dave and copyright
infringement is how we titled it because
we had a game called dangerous dave was
you know running around with the shotgun
shooting things uh and we were just
taking our most beloved game at the time
there the super mario 3 and sort of
sticking dave inside that with this new
scrolling technology that was going
perfectly smooth for
i am you know for them
as it ran and tom and i just kind of
literally the next morning you know kind
of left and we left a disc on i you know
on the desk for john romero and jay
wilbur to see and just said run this
and we eventually made it back in later
in the day and it was you know like they
grabbed us and pulled us in you know
pulled us into the room and that was the
point where they were like we got to do
something with this you know we're we're
going to make a company we're going to
go make our own games where this was
something that
we we were able to just kind of hit them
with a hammer of an experience like wow
this is just like so much cooler than
what we thought was possible there and
initially we tried to get nintendo to to
let us make super mario 3 on the pc
that's really what we wanted to do we
were like hey we can finish this it's
line of sight for this will be great
and
we sent something to nintendo and we
heard that it did get looked at in japan
and they just weren't interested in that
i but that's another one of those life
could have gone a very different way
where we could have been like nintendo's
house pc team
you know at that point and define the
direction of
you know uh
wolfenstein and uh
doom and quake could have been a
nintendo creation yeah so at the same
time that we were just doing our first
scrolling demos um we reached out to
scott miller at apogee and said it's
like hey we do want to make some games
you know these things that you think you
want those are those are nothing what do
you see what we can actually do now this
is going to be amazing
and he just like popped right up and
sent a check to us where we at that
point we still thought he might be a
fraud that he was just lying about all
of this but he was totally correct on
how much money he was making with his
shareware titles
and this was his his kind of real
brainstorm about this where shareware
was this idea that software doesn't have
a fixed price if you use it you send out
the goodness of your heart some money to
the creator and there were a couple
utilities that did make some significant
success like that but for the most part
it didn't really work you know there
wasn't much software in a pure shareware
model that that was successful
the apogee innovation was to take
something call it shareware split it
into three pieces you always made a
trilogy
and you would put the first piece out
but then you buy the whole trilogy for
some shareware amount which in reality
it meant that the first part was a demo
where you kind of like the demo went
everywhere for free and you paid money
to to get the whole set but it was still
played as shareware and we were happy to
have the first one go everywhere and it
wasn't a crippled demo where the first
episode of all these trilogies it was a
real complete game and probably 20 times
as many people played that part of it
thought they had a great game had found
fond memories of it but never paid us a
dime but enough people were happy with
that where
it was really quite successful at these
early games that we didn't think very
much of compared to commercial quality
games but they were doing really good
business some fairly crude things and
people it was good business people
enjoyed it and it wasn't like you were
taking a crap shoot on what you were
getting you just played a third of the
experience and you loved it enough to
hand write out a check and put it in an
envelope and address it and send it out
to apogee to uh to get the rest of them
so it was a really pretty feel-good
business prospect there because
everybody was happy you know they knew
what they were getting i when they send
it in and they would send in fan mail if
you're going to the trouble of
addressing a letter and i'm you know
filling out an envelope you write
something in it and there were just the
literal bags of fan mail for the
shareware um games so people loved them
i should mention that for you the
definition of wealth is being able to
have pizza whenever you want for me
there was a dream
because i would play shareware games
over and over the the part that's free
over and over and it was very deeply
fulfilling experience but you know i i
dreamed of a time when i could actually
afford the full experience and this is
kind of this dreamland beyond beyond the
horizon when would you could you could
find out what else is there in some
sense
even just playing the shareware was um
it's the limitation of that
you know life is is limited eventually
we all die in that way shareware was
like
somehow really fulfilling to have this
kind of mysterious thing beyond
what's free
always there it's kind of um i don't
know that was maybe it's because a part
of my childhood just playing shareware
games that was a really fulfilling
experience it's so interesting
how that model still brought joy
to so many people yeah 20x people that
played it yeah i felt very good about
that and i would run into people it's
like that would say oh i love that game
you know that you had early on commander
keen whatever and um and no they they
meant just the first episode that they
got to see everyone
the crap out of communicating and that
was
that was all good yeah yeah but so we
were in this position where scott miller
was just fronting us cash and saying
yeah make you know make a game
but
i we did not properly pull the trigger
and say all right we're going to we're
quitting our jobs we were like we're
going to do both we're going to keep
working at soft disk working on this and
then we're going to go ahead and make a
new game for apogee at the same time
and this eventually did lead to some
legal problems and we had we had trouble
it all got worked out in the end but it
was not a good call at the time there
and your legal mind at the time was not
stellar
you you were not thinking uh in terms of
in legal no i i definitely wasn't none
of us were uh
and in hindsight yeah it's like how did
we think we were gonna get away with
like even using our work computers to
write right software for you know our
our breakaway
new company it was not a good plan how
did commander keen come to be
so the design process we would start
from we had some idea of what we wanted
to do we wanted to do a mario like game
it was going to be a side scroller i was
going to use the technology we we had
some sense of what it would have to look
like because of the limitations of this
adaptive tile refresh technology it had
to have fields of relatively constant
tiles you couldn't just paint up a
background and then move that around
i the early design or all the design for
commander keen really came from tom hall
where
he was you know kind of the main
creative mind for the the early id
software stuff where we had an
interesting division of things where
tom was all creative in design i was all
programming john romero was an
interesting bridge where he was both a
very good programmer and also a very
good designer and artist and kind of
straddled between the areas but
commander keane was very much tom hall's
baby and
he came up with all the design and back
story for the different things of kind
of a
mad scientist little kid with i am you
know
building a a rocket ship and a zap gun
and uh visiting alien worlds and doing
all this that the background that we lay
the game inside of and there's not a
whole lot to any of these things you
know design for us was always just what
we needed to do to make the game that
was going to be so much fun to play
and we made our we laid out our first
trilogy of games you know the shareware
formula is going to be three pieces we
make entertain one two and three and we
just really started
uh busting on all that work and it went
together really quickly it was like
three months or something that while we
were still making games every month for
uh for gamer's edge we were sharing
technology between that i'd write a
bunch of code for this and we'd just
kind of use it for both
again not a particularly good idea there
that had consequences for us but
in three months we got our first our
first game out and all of a sudden it
was three times as successful as the
most successful thing apogee had had
before and we were making like thirty
thousand dollars a month
immediately from the commander keen
stuff
and that was again a surprise to us it
was more than we thought that was gonna
uh that that was gonna make and we said
well we're gonna certainly roll into
another set of titles from this and in
that three months i had come up with a
much better way of doing the scrolling
technology that was not the adaptive
tile refresh which in some ways was even
simpler and these things
so many of the great ideas of technology
are things that are back of the envelope
designs i make this comment about modern
machine learning where all the things
that are really important practically in
the last decade are each of them fits on
the back of an envelope there are these
simple little things they're not
super dense hard to understand
technologies and so the the second
scrolling trick was just a matter of
like okay we know we've got this 64k
window and the question was always like
well you could make a two by two but you
can't go
off the edge uh but i finally asked well
what actually happens if you just go off
the edge if you take your start and you
say it's like okay i can move over i'm
scrolling i can move over i can move
down i'm scrolling i get to what should
be the bottom of the memory window it's
like well what if i just keep going and
i say i'm going to start at i you know
what happens if i start at fffe at the
very end of the the 64k block and it
turns out
it just wraps back around to the top of
the block and i'm like oh well this
makes everything easy you can just
scroll the screen everywhere and all you
have to draw is just one new line of
tiles which everything you expose it
might be unaligned off various parts of
the
of the screen memory but it just works
that no longer had the problem of you
had to have fields of the similar colors
because
it doesn't matter what you're doing you
could be having a completely unique
world and you're just drawing the new
strip as it comes on but it might be
like you said unaligned so it can be all
over the place yes and it turns out it
doesn't matter i would have two page
flipped screens as long as they didn't
overlap they moved in series through
this uh two-dimensional window of
graphics and that was one of those like
well this is so simple this just i this
just works it's faster i'm there it
seemed like there was no downside funny
thing was i it turned out after we
shipped titles with this there were what
they called uh super vga cards the cards
that would allow higher resolutions and
i and different features that the
standard ones didn't
and on some of those cards uh this was a
weird compatibility quark again because
nobody thought this was not what it was
designed to do and some of those cards
had more memory they had more than just
256k and four planes they had five 12k
or a megabyte and on some of those cards
i scroll my window down and then it goes
into uninitialized memory that actually
exists there rather than wrapping back
around at the top
and
then i was in the tough position of do i
have to track every single one of these
and it was a mad house back then with
there were 20 different video card
vendors with all slightly different
implementations of their non-standard
functionality so either i needed to
natively program all of the the vga
cards there to
map in that memory and keep scrolling
down through all of that or i kind of
punted and took the easy solution of
when you finally did run to the edge of
the screen i accepted a hitch and just
copied the whole screen up there so on
some of those
uh those cards it was a compatibility
mode in the normal ones when it all
worked fine everything was just
beautifully smooth but if you had one of
those cards where it did not wrap the
way i wanted it to you'd be scrolling
around scrolling around and then
eventually you'd have a little hitch
where 200 milliseconds or something that
was not super smooth
as it froze a little bit and this was
the binary thing is it one of the
standard screens there's one of the
weird ones the super vga ones yeah okay
and so we would default to and i think
that was one of those that changed over
the kind of course of deployment where
early on we would have a normal mode and
then you would have you would enable the
compatibility flag if your screen did
this crazy flickery thing when you got
to a certain point in the game uh and
then later i think it probably got
enabled by default as just more and more
of the cards i kind of did not do
exactly the right thing and that's the
two-edged sword of doing unconventional
things with technology where you can
find something that nobody thought about
doing that kind of scrolling trick when
they set up those cards uh but the fact
that nobody thought that was the primary
reason when i was relying on that then i
wound up being broken on some of the
later cards let me uh take a bit of a
tangent but uh
ask about the hacker ethic because you
mentioned shareawares it's an
interesting world the world of
people that make money
the business and the people that
build systems the engineers
and
what is the
hacker ethic
you've been a man of the people
and you've embodied at least the part of
that ethic what does it mean what did it
mean to you at the time what does it
mean to you today so steven levy's book
hackers was a really formative book for
me uh as a teenager i mean i read it
several times and there was all of the
great lore of the early mit era of
hackers and you know ending up at the
end with it kind of went through the
early mit hackers and the silicon valley
hardware hackers and then uh the game
hackers in part three
and at that time as a teenager
i really
was kind of bitter in some ways like i
thought i was born too late i thought i
missed the the window there and i really
thought i belonged in that third section
of that book with the game hackers and
they were talking about you know the
williams at sierra and origin systems
with richard garriott and and it's like
i really wanted to be there and i knew
that was that was now a few years in the
past it was i you know it was not to be
but the early days especially the early
mit hacker days talking a lot about this
sense of
uh the hacker ethic that there was this
sense that
it was about sharing information being
good not keeping it to yourself and that
it's not a zero-sum game that you you
know you can share something with
another programmer and it doesn't take
it away from you you know you you then
have somebody else doing something and i
also think that there's an aspect of it
where it's this ability to to take joy
in other people's accomplishments where
it's not the cutthroat bit of like i
have to be first i have to be recognized
as the the one that did this in some way
but being able to see somebody else um
do something and say holy [ __ ] that's
amazing you know and just taking joy in
the ability of something amazing that
somebody else does
and
the
the big thing that i was able to do
through in software was uh this ability
to eventually release the source code
for most of our like all of our really
seminal game titles and that was a it
was a stepping stone process where
we were kind of surprised early on where
uh people were able to hack the existing
games and of course i had experience
with that i remember hacking my copies
of ultima so i give myself you know 999
gold and raise my levels and you know
break out the sector editor and so i was
familiar with all of that so it was just
it was with a smile when i started to
see people doing that to our games i am
you know making level editors for
commander keen or hacking up wolfenstein
3d
but i made the pitch
internally that we should actually
release our own tools for like what we
did uh what we used to create the games
and that was you know that was a little
bit debatable about well you know will
this let other will give people leg up
it's always like what's that going to
mean for the competition
but the really hard pitch was to
actually release the full source code
for the games and it was a balancing act
with the the other people inside the
company where
it's interesting how the programmers
generally did get certainly i am the
people that i worked closely with they
did kind of get that hacker ethic bit
where you wanted to share your code you
were you were proud of it you wanted
other people to take it do cool things
with it but
i interestingly the
the broader game industry is a little
more hesitant to embrace that than like
the group of people that we happen to
have at id software where it was always
a little interesting to me seeing how a
lot of people in the game modding
community were very possessive of their
code they did not want to share their
code they wanted it to be theirs it was
their you know claim to fame and that
was much more like what we tended to see
with artists where you know the artists
understand something about credit and i
you know wanting it to be known as their
work and a lot of the game programmers
felt a little bit more like artists than
like hacker programmers in that it was
about building something that maybe felt
more like art to them than the the more
tool-based and exploration
exploration-based
kind of hacking culture side of things
yes so it's so interesting that this
kind of
fear that credit will not be
sufficiently attributed to you
and that's one of the things that i do
bump into a lot because
i i try not to go cl i mean it's easy
for me to say because so much credit is
heaped on me for the the id software
side of things but when people come up
and that they want to pick a fight and
say no it's like that wasn't where first
person gaming came from and you can
point to you know you can point to some
of like things on obscure titles that i
was never aware of or like the old plato
systems or you know each personal
computer had something that was 3d ish
and moving around and i'm you know and
i'm happy to say it's like no i mean i
saw battle zone in star wars in the
arcades i had seen 3d graphics i had
seen all these things they're i'm
standing on the shoulders of lots of
other people but sometimes these
examples they pull out it's like i
didn't know that existed i mean there i
had never heard of that before then that
didn't contribute to what i made but
there's plenty of stuff that did and you
know i
i think there's good cases to be made
that obviously doom and quake and
wolfenstein were formative examples for
what
everything that came after that but i
don't feel the need to go fight and say
claim
primacy or initial invention of anything
like that but a lot of people do want to
i think when you fight for the credit in
that way and it does go against the
hacker ethic
you destroy something fundamental about
the culture about the community that
builds cool stuff
i think credit ultimately um
uh so i had this sort of um there's a
famous wrestler in freestyle wrestling
called uh
satya
and he always preached that you should
just focus on the art of the wrestling
and let people
um
write your story however they want
the
the the highest form of the art is just
focusing on the art and that's something
that is something about the the hacker
ethic is just focus on building cool
stuff sharing it with other cool people
and credit will get assigned correctly
uh
in the long arc of history yeah and i
generally think that's true and you've
got
i am
you know like there's some things there
there's a graphics technique that got
labeled carmax reverse i am you know
literally named and it turned out that i
wasn't the first person to to figure
that out like most scientific things or
mathematical things you might have like
oh this other person had actually done
that somewhat before and then there's
things that get attributed to me like
the inverse square root hack that i
actually didn't do i flat out that
wasn't me and it's like it's weird how
the memetic power of the internet i
cannot you're like the point of
programming yes
it's just everything just gets
attributed to you now even though you've
never sought that the credit of things i
mean but part of the the fact that the
humility behind that is what uh attracts
the attributions
let's talk about a game
you mean one of the greatest games ever
made i know you could talk about doing
quake and so on but to me wolfenstein 3d
was like wow
it blew my mind that that world like
this could exist so how did wolfenstein
3d come to be
in terms of the programming in terms of
the design in terms of some of the
memorable technical challenges
um and also actually just something you
haven't mentioned
you know
how do these ideas
come
to be inside your mind the adaptive side
scrolling
so the solutions to these technical
challenges
so i usually can introspectively pull
back pretty detailed uh accounts of how
technology solutions and design choices
on my part came to be where
i technically we had done two games 3d
games like that before where hover tank
was the first one which had flat shaded
walls but did have the scaled enemies
inside it and then catacombs 3d which
had textured walls scaled enemies and
some more
some more functionality like the
disappearing walls and some other stuff
but what's really interesting from a
game development standpoint is
those games catacombs 3d povertank and
wolfenstein
they
literally used the same code for a lot
of the character behavior that a 2d game
that i had made earlier called catacombs
did
where it was an overhead view game kind
of like gauntlet you're running around
and you can open up doors pick up items
basic game stuff
and the thought was that
this exact same game experience just
presented in a different perspective it
could be literally the same game just
with a different view into it would have
a dramatically different impact on the
players
so it wasn't
it wasn't a true 3d you're saying that
you could kind of fake it you can like
scale enemies meaning things that are
farther away you can make them smaller
so from the game was a 2d map like all
of our games use the same tool for
creation and we used the same map editor
for creating keen as wolfenstein and
evertank and catacombs and all this
stuff so the game was a 2d grid made out
of blocks and you could say well these
are walls these are where the enemies
start then they start moving around and
these early games like catacombs you
played it strictly in a 2d view it was a
scrolling 2d view and that was kind of
using an adaptive tile refresh at the
time to be able to do something like
that
and then
the thought that these early games all
it did was take the same basic enemy
logic but instead of seeing it from the
god's eye view on top you were inside it
and turning from side to side yawing
your view and moving forwards and
backwards and side to side i and it's a
striking thing where you always talk
about wanting to isolate and factor
changes in values and this was one of
those most pure cases there where
the rest of the game changed very little
it was our normal kind of change the
colors on something and draw a different
picture for it but it's kind of the same
thing but the perspective changed in a
really fundamental way and it was
dramatically different i can remember
the reactions where the artist adrian
that had been drawing the pictures for
we had a cool big troll thing in
catacombs 3d and we had uh these walls
that you could get a key and you could
make the blocks disappear get really
simple stuff blocks could either be
there or not there so our idea of a door
was being able to make a set of blocks
just disappear and i remember the
reaction where he had drawn these
characters and he was slowly moving
around and like people had no experience
with 3d navigation it was all still
keyboard we didn't even have mice
set up at that time but slowly moving
going up picked up a key go to a wall
the wall disappears in a little
animation and there's a monster like
right there and he practically fell out
of his chair it was just like ah
and
games just didn't do that you know the
games were the god's eye view you were a
little invested in your little guy you
can be like you know happy or sad when
things happen but you just did not get
that kind of startle reaction you
weren't interested in your face
something in the back of your brain some
reptile brain thing is just going oh
[ __ ] something just happened
and that was one of those early points
where it's like yeah this is going to
make a difference this is going to be
powerful and it's going to matter were
you able to imagine that in the idea
stage or no so
not that exact thing so again we had
cases like the arcade games battlezone
and star wars that you could kind of see
a 3d world and things coming at you and
you get some sense of it but nothing had
done the kind of worlds that we were
doing and the sort of action based
things 3d at the time
was really largely about the simulation
thoughts
and this is something that
really might have trended differently if
not for the id software approach in the
games where there were flight simulators
there were driving simulators you had
like hard driving and microsoft flight
simulator and these were doing 3d and
general purpose 3d and ways that were
more flexible than what we were doing
with our games but they were looked at
as simulations they weren't trying to
necessarily be fast or responsive i were
letting you do kind of exciting
maneuvers because they were trying to
simulate reality and they were taking
their cues from the big systems the
evans and sutherlands and the silicon
graphics that were doing things but we
were taking our cues from the console
and arcade games you know we wanted
things that were
sort of quarter eaters that were doing
fast-paced things that you could smack
you around rather than just smoothly
gliding you from place to place so
quarterly
quarter
and you know the funny thing is so much
that that built into us that wolfenstein
still had lives and you had like one of
the biggest power-ups in all these games
like was an extra life because you
started off with three lives and you
lose your lives and then it's game over
and there weren't save games in most of
this stuff it was it sounds almost crazy
to say this but it was an innovation in
doom to not have lives you know you
could just play doom as long as you
wanted you just restart at the the start
of the level and why not this is like we
we aren't trying to take people's
quarters they've already paid for the
entire game we want them to have a good
time and you would have some i you know
some old-timer purists that might think
that there's something to the epic
journey of making it to the end having
to restart all the way from the
beginning after a certain number of
tries but now more fun is had when you
just let people kind of keep trying when
they're stuck rather than having to go
all the way back and and learn different
things so you've recommended the book
game engine black book wolfenstein 3d
for technical exploration of the game so
looking back
30 years what are some memorable
technical innovations that made
this perspective shift into this world
that's so immersive that scares you when
a monster appears or some things you
have to solve
so one of the interesting things that
come back to the theme of deadlines and
resource constraints the the game
catacombs 3d um
we shipped we were supposed to be
shipping this for gamer's edge on a
monthly cadence and i had slipped i was
actually late it slipped like six weeks
because this was texture mapped walls
doing stuff that i hadn't done before
and at the six week point it was still
kind of glitchy and buggy there were
things that i knew that if you had a
wall that was like almost edge on you
could slide over to it and you could see
some things freak out or vanish or not
work and i hated that i i but i was up
against the wall we had to ship the game
uh it was still a lot of fun to play it
was novel nobody had seen it it gave you
that startle reflex uh reaction so it
was worth shipping but it had these
things that i knew were kind of flaky
and janky and not not what i was really
proud of so
one of the the things that i did very
differently in wolfenstein i was i went
catacombs used
almost a conventional thing where you
had segments that were one-dimensional
polygons basically that were clipped and
uh and back-faced and done kind of like
a very crude 3d engine from the
professionals but i wasn't getting it
done right i was not doing a good enough
job i didn't really have line of sight
to
um to fix it right there's stuff that of
course i look back it's like oh it's
obvious how to do this and do the math
right do your clipping right
check all of this how you handle the
precision but i did not know how to do
that at that time the first 3d engine
you wrote catacombs 3d
and hover tank had been a little bit
before that but that had the flat shaded
walls so the texture mapping on the
walls was what was bringing in some of
these challenges that was uh that was
hard for me and i couldn't solve it
right at the time can you describe what
flat shading is in texture mapping so in
the the walls work solid color one of 16
colors i'm in hover tank so that's easy
it's fast you just draw the solid color
for everything texture mapping is what
we all see today where you have an image
that is stretched and distorted onto the
walls or the surfaces that you're
working with um and it was you know it
was a long time for me to just figure
out how to do that without it distorting
in the wrong ways and
and i did not get it all exactly right
in catacombs and i i had these flaws
so that was important enough to me that
rather than continuing to bang my head
on that when i wasn't positive i was
gonna get it i went with a completely
different approach for drawing for
figuring out where the walls were which
was a raycasting approach which i had
done in catacombs 3d i had a bunch of c
code trying to make this work right and
it wasn't working right in wolfenstein i
wound up going to a very small amount of
assembly code so in some ways there
should be a slower way of doing it but
by making it a smaller amount of work
that i could more tightly optimize it
worked out and wolfenstein 3d was just
absolutely rock solid you know it was
you know nothing glitched in there the
game just was pretty much flawless
through all of that and i was super
proud of that i'm
but eventually like in the later games i
went back to the more span based things
where i could get more total efficiency
once i really did figure out how to do
it so there were two sort of key
technical things to wolfenstein one was
this raycasting approach which you still
to this day you see people go and say
let's write a raycasting engine because
it's an understandable way of doing
things that lets you make games very
much like that so you see raycasters in
javascript raycasters and python people
that are are basically going and
re-implementing that uh that approach to
taking a tiled world and casting out
into it it works pretty well but it's
not the fastest way of doing it can you
describe what raycasting is
so you start off and you've got your
screen which is 320 pixels across at the
time if you haven't sized down in the
window for for greater speed and at
every pixel there's going to be an angle
from you've got your position in the
world and you're going to just run along
that angle and keep going until you hit
a block
so up to 320 times across there it's
going to throw a cast array out into the
world from wherever your origin is until
it runs into a wall and then it can
figure out exactly where on the wall
it hits the performance challenge of
that is as it's going out every block
it's crossing it checks is this a solid
wall
so that means that in like the early
wolfenstein levels you're in a small
jail cell going out into a small hallway
it's super efficient for that because
you're only stepping across three or
four blocks but then if somebody makes a
room that covers our maps we're limited
to 64 by 64 blocks if you made one room
that was nothing but walls at the far
space it would go pretty slow because it
would be stepping across
80 tile tests or something along the way
by the way the physics of our universe
seems to be competing this very thing so
this maps nicely to the actual physics
of our world yeah you get intuitive i
follow a little bit of something like
stephen wolfram's work on i've you know
interconnected network information
states of that and that's
it's beyond what i can have an informed
opinion on but it's interesting that
people are considering things like that
and have uh and have things that can
back it up yeah that's yeah there's
whole different sets of interesting
stuff there so wolfenstein 3d had
raycast something raycasting and then
the other kind of key aspect was what i
called compiled scalars where the idea
of
you saw this in the earlier classic
arcade games like space harrier and
stuff where you would take a picture
which is normally drawn directly on the
screen and then if you have the ability
to make it bigger or smaller big chunky
pixels or fizzly small drop sampled
pixels
that's the fundamental aspect of what
our characters were doing in these 3d
games you would have it's just like you
might have drawn a tiny little character
but now we can make them really big and
make them really small and move it
around
that was the limited kind of 3d that we
had for characters to make them turn
there were literally eight different
views of them you didn't actually have a
3d model that would rotate you just had
these cardboard cutouts but that was
good enough for that startled fight
reaction
and it was kind of what we had to do
deal with there so a straightforward
approach to do that you could just write
out your doubly nested loop of i you've
got your stretch factor and it's like
you've got a point you stretch by a
little bit it might be on the same pixel
it might be on the next pixel it might
have skipped a pixel um you can write
that out but it's not going to be fast
enough where especially you get a
character for that right in your face
monster covering almost the entire
screen doing that with a general purpose
scaling routine would have just been
much too slow it would have worked when
they're small characters but then it
would get slower and slower as they got
closer to you until right at the time
when you most care about having a fast
reaction time the game would be chunking
down
so the fastest possible way to draw
pixels
at that time
was to i'm
instead of saying i've got a general
purpose i am
version that can handle any scale
i made i i used a program to make
essentially a hundred or more separate
little programs that was optimized for i
will take an image and i will draw it 12
pixels tall i'll take an image i'll draw
it 14 pixels tall up by every two pixels
even for that so you would have the most
optimized code so that in the normal
case where
most of the world is fairly large i like
the pixels are big you know we did not
have a lot of memory so in most cases
that meant that you would load a pixel
color and then you would store it
multiple times
so
that was faster than even copying an
image in a normal conventional case
because most the time the image is
expanded so instead of doing one read
one write for a simple copy you might be
doing one read and three or four writes
as it got really big and that had the
beneficial aspect of just when you
needed the performance most when things
are covering the screen it was giving
you the most acceleration for that by
the way were you able to uh
understand this through thinking about
it or were you testing like the right
speed and like this again comes back to
i can find the antecedents for things
like this so in i'm
back in the apple two days i'm the
graphics were
essentially single bits at a time and if
you wanted to make your little spaceship
if you wanted to make it smoothly go
across the world if you just took the
image and you drew it out at the next
location you would move by seven pixels
at a time so it would go chunk chunk if
you wanted to make it move smoothly you
actually had to make seven versions of
the ship that were pre-shifted you could
write a program that would shift it
dynamically but on a one megahertz
processor that's not going anywhere fast
so if you wanted to do a smooth moving
fast action game you made separate
versions of each of these uh sprites now
there were a few more tricks you could
pull that if it still wasn't fast enough
you could make a compiled shape where
instead of this program that normally
copies an image and says like get this
byte from here store it here get this
byte store this bite if you've got the
memory space you could say i'm going to
write the program that does nothing but
draw this shape it's going to be like
i'm going to load the immediate value 25
you know which is some bit pattern and
then i'm going to store that at this
location uh rather than loading
something from memory that involved
indexing registers and this other slow
stuff you could go ahead and say no i'm
going to hard code the exact values of
all of the image right into the program
now this was always a horrible trade-off
there but you didn't have much memory
and you didn't have much speed but if
you had something that you wanted to go
really fast you could turn it into a
program
and that was you know knowing about that
technique is what made me think about
some of these unwinding it for the pc
where people that didn't come from that
background were less likely to think
about that
i mean there's some deep parallels
probably to human cognition as well
there's something about
optimizing and compressing
the the processing of a new information
that requires you to predict the
possible ways in which
the game or the world might unroll and
you have something like compiled scalars
always there so if you have like optima
like you have a prediction of how the
world will unroll and you have some kind
of optimized
data structure for that prediction and
then you can modify if the world turns
out to be different you can modify a
slight way as far as building out
techniques so much of the brain is about
the associative context you know they're
just when you learn something it's in
the context of something else and you
can have faint tiny little hints of
things and i do think there are some
deep things uh you know around like
sparse distributed memories and boosting
that's like if you can just be slightly
above the noise floor of having some
hint of something you can have things
refined into pulling the memory back up
so having a being a programmer and
having a toolbox of like all of these
things that things that i did in all of
these previous lives of programming
tasks that still matters to me about how
i'm able to pull up some of these things
like in that case it was something i did
on the apple 2 then being relevant for
the pc and i have still cases when i
would when i would work on mobile
development then be like okay i did
something like this back in the the doom
days but now it's a different
environment but i have still had that
tie i can bring it in and i can
transform it into what the world needs
right now
and i i do think that's actually one of
the very core things with human
cognition and brain like i you know
brain like functioning is finding these
ways about you've got your brain is kind
of everything everywhere all at once you
know it's it is just a set of all of
this stuff that is just fetched back by
these queries that go into it and they
can just be slightly above the noise
floor with random noise in your neurons
and synapses that are affecting exactly
what gets pulled up so you're saying
some of these very specific solutions
for different games
you find that there's a kernel of a deep
idea that's generalizable to other
to other things yeah you can't predict
what it's going to be but that idea of
like i called out that compiled shaders
uh in the forward that i wrote for that
uh the game engine black book as you
know this is it's kind of an endpoint of
unrolling code but that's one of those
things that thinking about that and
having that in your mind and i'm sure
there are some programmers that you know
hear about that think about it a little
bit it's kind of the mind-blown moment
it's like oh you can just turn all of
that data into code and nowadays you
know you have instruction cache issues
and that's not necessarily the best idea
but there are different
it's an idea that has power and has
probably relevance in some other areas
maybe it's in a hardware point of view
that there's a way you approach building
hardware that has that same you don't
even have to think about iterating you
just bake everything all the way into it
in one place what is the story of how
you came to program doom
what are some memorable technical
challenges or innovations within that
game
so the path that we went after
after wolfenstein got out and we were on
this crazy arc where keen one through
three
more success than we thought king four
through six even more success
wolfenstein even more success so we were
on this this crazy trajectory for things
so actually our first box commercial
project was the commander keen i am game
but then wolfenstein was going to have a
game called spear of destiny which was a
commercial version 60 new levels so the
rest of the team took the game engine
pretty much as it was and started
working on that we got new monsters but
it's
basically reskins of the things there
and there's a really interesting aspect
about that that i didn't appreciate
until much much later about how
wolfenstein clearly did tap out its
limit about what you want to play um all
the levels and a couple of our license
things there was a hard creative wall
that you did not really benefit much by
continuing to beat on it
but
a game like doom and other more modern
games like minecraft or something
there's kind of a touring completeness
level of design freedom that you get in
games that wolfenstein clearly sat on
one side of you know all the creative
people in the world could not go and do
a masterpiece just with the technology
that wolfenstein had wolfenstein could
do wolfenstein but you really couldn't
do something crazy and different but it
didn't take that much more capability to
get to wolfenstein with the freeform
lines and a little bit more artistic
freedom to get to the point where people
still announce new doom levels today all
these years after without having
completely tapped out the creativity how
did you how did you put it touring
complete yeah i turned complete design
space designs
like you know we have the kind of
computational universality on a lot of
things and how difficult for creativity
but yeah there's things where a box can
be too small but above a certain point
you kind of are at the point where
you you really have almost unbounded
creative ability there and doom is the
first time you cross that line yeah
where there were
thousands of doom levels created and
some of them still have something new
and interesting to say to the world
about it is that line
can you introspect what that line was is
in the design space is it something
about the programming
uh capabilities that you were able to
add to the game
so the graphics fidelity was a necessary
part because the block limitations in
wolfenstein uh what we had right there
was uh was not enough the full-scale
blocks although minecraft i really did
show that perhaps blocks uh stacked in
3d and at one quarter the scale of that
or one-eighth in volume is then
sufficient to have all of that but the
the wall-sized blocks that we had in
wolfenstein was too much of a creative
limitation you know we licensed the
technology to a few other teams none of
them made you know too much of a of a
dent with that it just wasn't enough
creative ability but a little bit more
whether it was the variable floors and
ceilings and arbitrary angles in doom or
the smaller voxel blocks in uh in
minecraft is then enough to open it up
to to just worlds and worlds of new
capabilities what is binary space
partitioning
so these are one one of the technologies
yeah so jump around a little bit on the
on the story path there yes so while the
team was working on spirit destiny for
wolfenstein yes i am i had we had met
another development team raven software
while we were in wisconsin
and um they were doing they had rpg
background and i i still kind of loved
that and i offered to do a game engine
for for them to let them do a 3d
rendered rpg instead of the
like most rpg games were kind of hand
drawn they made it look kind of 3d but
it was done just all with artist work
rather than a real engine
and
after wolfenstein this was still a
tile-based world but i added floors and
ceilings and some lighting and the
ability to have some sloped floors in
different areas that was my intermediate
step for a game called shadowcaster
and it had slowed down enough it was not
fast enough to do our type of action
things so that they had the screen
cropped down a little bit so you
couldn't go the full screen with like we
would try to do in wolfenstein i am but
i learned a lot i got the floors and
ceilings and lightings and it looked
great they were great artists up there
and it was it was an inspiration for us
to look at some of that stuff
but i had learned enough from that that
i had the plan for i knew faster ways to
do the the lighting and shadowing and i
wanted to do this freeform geometry i
wanted to break out of this tile-based
90 degree world limitations
so we had that was when we got our next
stations and we were working with these
higher powered systems and i
we built an editor that let us draw kind
of arbitrary line segments and i was
working hard to try to make something
that could render this fast enough
um you know i was pushing myself pretty
hard i
and we were we were at a point where we
could see some things that looked
amazingly cool but it wasn't really fast
enough for the way i was doing it i for
this flexibility it was no longer i
couldn't just raycast into it and i had
these very complex sets of lines and
simple little worlds were okay but the
cool things that we wanted to do just
weren't quite fast enough
and i wound up taking a break at that
point and i did the the port i did two
ports of
our games uh wolfenstein to the uh to
the super nintendo it was uh it was a
crazy difficult thing to to do which was
an even slower processor it's like two i
couple megahertz uh processor
and it had been this whole thing where
we had farmed out the i am
the work and it wasn't it wasn't going
well and i took it back over
and
trying to make it go fast on there where
it really did not have much processing
power the pixels were stretched up
hugely and it's it was pretty ugly when
you looked at it but in the end it did
come out fast enough to play and still
be kind of fun from that but that was
where i started using uh bsp trees or
binary space partitioning trees it was
one of those things i had to make it
faster there it was a stepping stone
where it was reasonably easy to
understand in the grid world of
wolfenstein where it was all still 90
degree angles i'm
bsp trees were i eased myself into it
with that and it was a big success i'm
then when i came back to working on doom
i had this new tool in my toolbox it was
going to be a lot harder with the
arbitrary angles of doom this was where
i really started grappling with epsilon
problems and just you know up until that
point i hadn't really had to deal with
the fact that i am so many numeric
things this almost felt like a betrayal
to me whereas people had told me that i
had mathematicians up on a bit of a
pedestal where
i was people think i'm a math wizard and
i'm not i really everything that i did
was really done with a solid high school
math understanding i you know algebra 2
trigonometry and i'm
that was what got me all the way through
doom and quake and all of that of just
understanding basics of matrices and
knowing it well enough to do something
with it what's the epsilon problems you
run into so i when you wind up taking a
like a sloped line and you say i'm going
to intersect it with another sloped line
i am then you wind up with something
that's not going to be on these nice
grid boundaries with uh the wolfenstein
tile maps all you've got is horizontal
and vertical lines looking at it from
above and if you cut one of them it's
just obvious the other one gets cut
exactly at that point but when you have
angled lines you're doing a kind of a
slope intercept problem and you wind up
with rational numbers there where things
that are not going to evenly land on an
integer or even on any fixed point value
that you've got so everything winds up
having to snap to some fixed point value
so the lines slightly change their angle
you wind up if you cut something here
this one's going to bend a little this
way and it's not going to be completely
straight and then you come down to all
these questions of well this one is is
is a point on an angled line you can't
answer that in finite precision unless
you're doing something with actual
rational numbers and later on i did
waste far too much time chasing things
like that how do you do precise
arithmetic with rational numbers and it
always blows up eventually you know
exponentially as you do now so these are
these kind of things they're impossible
with computers so
they're possible again there are paths
to do doing it but you can't fit them
conveniently and any of the numbers you
need to start using big nums and
different factor trackings and different
things so you uh you have to if you have
any elements of ocd and you want to do
something perfectly you're screwed if
you're working with floating point yeah
so so you had to deal with this for the
first time yeah there was there were
lots of challenges there about like okay
they built this cool thing and the way
the bsp trees work is it basically takes
the walls and it carves other walls by
those walls in this clever way that you
can then take all of these fragments and
then you can for sure from any given
point get an ordering of everything in
the world and you can say this goes in
front of this goes in front of this all
the way back to the last thing and
that's super valuable for graphics where
uh kind of a classic graphics algorithm
would be painter's algorithm you paint
the furthest thing first and then the
next thing and then the next thing and
then it comes up and it's all perfect
for you uh that's slow because you don't
want to have to have drawn everything
like that but you can also flip it
around and draw the closest thing to you
and then if you're clever about it you
can figure out what you need to draw
that's visible beyond that and that's
what bsp trees allow you to do yeah so
it's combined with
a bunch of other things but it gives you
that ordering it's a clever way of doing
things and i remember i had learned this
from i one of my my graphics bible at
the time a book called foley and van
damme and again it was a different world
back there there was a small integer
number of books
and this book that yeah yeah this book
that was it was big fat college textbook
that i had i'd read through many times i
didn't understand everything in it some
of it wasn't useful to me but they had
the little thing about uh finite
orderings of you draw a little t-shaped
thing and you can say you can you can
make a fixed ahead of time order from
this and you can generalize this with
the bsp trees and and i got a little bit
more information about that it was kind
of fun later while i was working on
quake i got to meet uh bruce naylor who
is one of the original researchers that
developed those technologies uh you know
as for academic literature and that was
kind of fun but i was very much just
finding a tool that can help me solve
what i was doing and i was using it in
this very crude way in a two-dimensional
fashion rather than the general 3d the
epsilon problems got much worse in quake
and three-dimensionals when things angle
in every way but eventually i did sort
out the sort out how to do it reliably
on doom there were still a few edge
cases in doom that were not absolutely
perfect where they they even got
terminologies in the communities like
when you got to something where it was
messed up it was a hall of mirrors
effect because you'd sweep by and it
wouldn't draw something there and you
would just wind up with the leftover
remnants as you flipped between the the
two pages but bsp trees were important
for it but it's again worth noting that
uh after we did doom our major
competition came from ken silverman his
build engine which was used for duke
nukem 3d and some of the other games for
3d realms and he used a completely
different technology nothing to do with
i'm
with bsp trees so there's not just a one
true way of doing things i
there were critical things about to make
any of those games fast you had you had
to separate your drawing into you drew
vertical lines and you drew horizontal
lines just kind of changing exactly what
you would draw with them that was
critical for the technologies uh at that
time and like all the games that were
kind of like that wound up doing
something similar but there were still a
bunch of other decisions that could be
made and we made good enough decisions
on everything on doom we
we brought in multiplayer significantly
and it was our first game that was
designed to be modified by the user
community where we had this whole setup
of our wad files and p-wads and things
that people could could build with tools
that we released to them and they
eventually rewrote to be better than
what we released but they could build
things and you could add it to your game
without destructively modifying it which
is what you had to do in all the early
games you literally hacked the
the data files or the executable before
while doom was set up in this flexible
way so that you could just say run the
normal game with this added on on top
and it would overlay just the things
that you wanted to there
would you say that doom was kind of the
first true 3d game that you created so
no it's still doom would usually be
called a two and a half d game where it
had three dimensional points on it and
this is another one of these kind of
pedantic things that people love to
argue about about what was the first 3d
game i still like i'm like every month
probably i hear from somebody about well
was doom really a 3d game or something i
and
you know i give the the point where
characters had three coordinates so you
had like an x y and z the cacademian
could be coming in very high and come
you know and come down towards you uh
the walls had three coordinates on them
so on some sense it's a 3d game engine
but it was not a fully general 3d game
engine you could not i you could not
build a pyramid in doom because you
couldn't make a sloped wall
which was slightly different where in
that previous shadow caster game i
couldn't have vertexes and have a sloped
floor there but the changes that i made
for doom to get higher speed and a
different set of flexibility traded away
that ability but you literally couldn't
make that you could not i you could make
different heights of uh passages but you
could not make a bridge over another
area you could not go over and above it
so it still had some 2d limitations to
it that's more about the building versus
the actual experience because the
experience is
it felt like things would come at you
but again you couldn't look up either i
am right you know you could only pitch
it was four degrees of freedom rather
than six degrees of freedom you did not
have the ability to tilt your head this
way or pitch up and down so that takes
us to quake
what was the leap
there
what was some fascinating technical
challenges and there were a lot or not
challenges but innovations that you've
come up with so quake was kind of the
first thing where i did have to kind of
come face to face with my limitations
where it was the first thing where i
really did kind of
give it my all and still come up a
little you know come up a little bit
short in terms of what and when i wanted
to to get it done and the company ran
had some serious stresses through the
the whole project and
we uh we bit off a lot so the things
that we set out to do was it was going
to be really a true 3d engine where it
could do six degree of freedom you could
have all the all the viewpoints you
could model anything it had
a really remarkable new lighting model
with the the surface caching and things
that was one of those where it was
starting to to do some things that they
weren't doing even on the very high-end
systems
and it was going to be completely
programmable uh in the modding
standpoint where the thing that you
couldn't do in doom you could replace
almost all of the media but you couldn't
really change the game uh there were
still some people that were doing the
hex setting of the executable the
d-hacked things where you could change a
few things about rules and people made
some early capture of the flag type
things by hacking the executable but it
wasn't really set out to do that quake
was going to have its own programming
language that the game was going to be
implemented in it and that would be able
to be overwritten just like any of the
media code was going to be data for that
and you would be able to have expansion
packs that changed fundamental things
and mods and so on
and the the multiplayer was going to be
playable over the internet it was going
to support a client server rather than
peer-to-peer so we had the possibility
of supporting larger numbers of players
in disparate locations
with this full flexibility of the the
programming overrides with full six
degree of freedom modeling and viewing
and with this fancy new light mapped um
kind of surface caching side it was a
lot and this was one of those things
that if i could go back and tell um you
know tell younger me to do something
differently it would have been to split
those innovations up into two phases in
two separate games will be phase one and
phase two so it probably would have been
taking the doom rendering engine and
bringing in uh the tcp
uh client server focusing on the
multiplayer and the uh the quake c or
would have been doom c programming
language there so i would have split
that into programming language and
networking with the same doom engine
rather than forcing everybody to go
towards the the pen you know the quake
engine which really meant getting a
pentium you know while it ran on a 486
it was not a great experience there we
could have made more people happier and
gotten two games done in 50 percent more
time i so speaking of people happier our
mutual friend joe rogan it seems like
his the the most important uh moment of
his life is is uh centered around quake
so it was a definitive um
part of his life so would he agree with
your
uh thinking that they should split
uh so he is a person who loves quake and
played quake a lot
would he agree that you should have done
the doom engine with and focus on the
multiplayer for phase one
uh or
in your looking back it is is the the 3d
world that quake created
was also fundamental to the the
enrollment
you know i would say that what would
have happened is
you would have had a
a doom looking but quake feeling uh game
eight months earlier and then maybe six
months after quake actually shipped then
there would have been the full running
on a pentium um six degree of freedom
graphics engine type things there so
it's not that it wouldn't have cut it
wouldn't have been there it would have
been something amazingly cool earlier
and then something even cooler somewhat
later
where i would much rather in have gone
and done two one-year development
efforts i
cycle them through i be a little more
pragmatic about that rather than killing
us ourselves on the whole quake
development but i say it's obviously
things worked out well in the end but
looking back and saying how would i
optimize and do things differently that
did seem to be a clear case where
i going ahead and we had enormous
momentum on doom you know we did doom 2
as the kind of commercial boxed version
after our shareware success with the
original but we could have just made
another doom game
adding those new features in it would
have been huge we would have learned all
the same lessons but faster and it would
have given six degree of freedom and
pentium class systems a little bit more
time to get mainstream because we did
cut out a lot of people with the
hardware requirements for quake
was there any dark moments for you
personally psychologically in having
um in um having such harsh deadlines and
having this also many difficult
technical challenges
so i've never really had
really dark black places i mean i i
can't necessarily put myself in anyone
else's shoes but i understand a lot of
people have
you have significant challenges with
kind of their their mental health and
well-being
and i've been i've been super stressed
i've been you know unhappy as a teenager
in various ways but i've never
i've never really gone to
a very dark place i just seem to be
largely immune to what really wrecks
people i mean i've had plenty of time
when i'm very unhappy and miserable
about something but it's never hit me
like you know i believe it winds up
hitting some other people i've borne up
well under whatever stresses have i you
know have kind of fallen on me and i've
always coped best on that when all i
need to do is
is usually just kind of bear down on my
work i i pull myself out of whatever
hole i might be slipping into by
actually making progress
i i mean maybe if i was in a position
where i was never able to make that
progress i could have slid down further
but i've always been in a place where
okay a little bit more work maybe i'm in
a tough spot here but i i always know if
i just keep pushing eventually i break
through and i make progress i feel good
about what i'm doing
i am and that's been enough for me so
far in my life have you seen in the
distance
uh like um
you know ideas of depression or
contemplating suicide have you seen
those things far so it was interesting
when when i was a teenager i was you
know i i was probably on some level a
troubled youth i was unhappy most of my
teenaged uh you know years i you know i
really i wanted to be on my own doing
programming all the time i you know as
soon as i was 18 19 even though i was
poor i was doing exactly what i wanted
and i was very happy but high school was
not a great time for me and
i i had a conversation with like the
school counselor and they're kind of
running their script it's like okay as
kind of a weird kid here let's carefully
probe around it's like you know do you
ever think about ending it all i'm like
no of course not never not at all i this
is temporary things are going to be
better i'm
and and that's always been kind of the
case for me and obviously it's not that
way for everyone and other people do
react differently and
what was your um what was your escape
from the troubled youth like uh
uh you know
music
video games books
how did you escape from a world that's
full of cruelty and suffering and that's
absurd yeah i mean i i was not you know
i was not victim of cruelty and
suffering it's like i was an unhappy
somewhat petulant youth and you know in
my point where i you know i'm not
putting myself up with anybody else's
suffering but i was unhappy objectively
and i the things that i i did that very
much characterized my childhood were i
had um books comic books dungeons and
dragons arcade games video games like
some of my my fondest childhood memories
are the convenience stores the 7-elevens
and quick trips because they had a
spinner rack of comic books and they had
a little side room with two or three
video games arcade games in it and that
was uh that was very much my happy place
you know if i could i get my comic books
and uh if i could go to a library and
you know go through those the little
zero zero zero section where computer
books were supposed to be and there are
a few sad little books there but still
just being able to sit down and go
through that and i read you know i read
a ridiculous number of books both
fiction and non-fiction as a teenager
and i
you know as i my rebel my rebelling in
high school was just sitting there with
my nose in a book ignoring the class uh
and through lots of it and teachers had
a range of reactions to that some more
uh more accepting of it than others
i'm with you on that so let us return to
quake for a bit with the technical
challenges what what um
everything together from the from the
networking to the the graphics what what
are some things you remember that were
that were innovations yet to come up
with in order to make it all happen yeah
so there were a bunch of things on quake
where on the one hand the idea that i
built my own programming language to
implement the game in looking back and i
try to tell people it's like every every
high level programmer sometime in their
career goes through and they invent
their own language it just seems to be a
thing that's pretty broadly done people
they're like i'm going to go write a
computer programming language and
i
you know i don't regret having done it
but after that i i switched from quake c
my quirky little i am pseudo object
orienter entity oriented language there
quake 2 went back to using dlls with c
and then quake 3 i implemented my own c
interpreter or compiler which was a much
smarter thing to do that i should have
done originally for quake but building
my own language was an experience i
learned a lot from that i am and then
there was a generation of game
programmers that learned programming
with quake c which i feel kind of bad
about because you know i mean we give
javascript a lot of crap but i'm you
know quake c was nothing to write home
about there
uh but it was it allowed people to do
magical things you get into programming
not because you love the
the bnf syntax of a language it's
because the language lets you do
something that you cared about and
here's very much you could do something
in a whole beautiful three-dimensional
world and the idea and the fact that the
code for the game was out there you
could say i like the shotgun but i want
it to be more badass you go in there and
say okay now it does 200 points damage
and then you go around with a big grin
on your face blowing up monsters all
over the game
so yeah it's i you know it is not uh
what i would do today going back with
that language but that was a big part of
it
learning about the networking stuff i
because it's interesting where i learned
these things by reading books so i would
get a book on networking and find
something i read all about and learn
okay packets they can be you know out of
order or lost or duplicated these are
all the things that can theoretically
happen to packets so i wind up spending
all this time thinking about how do we
deal about all that and it turns out of
course in the real world those are
things that yes theoretically can happen
with multiple routes but they really
aren't things that you're 99.999
of your packets have to deal with i am
so there was learning experiences about
uh lots of that and like why when tcp is
appropriate versus udp and and how if
you do things in udp you wind up
reinventing tcp badly in almost all
cases so you know there's there's good
arguments for using both for different
game technology different parts of the
game process transitioning from level to
level and all
but the the graphics were the showcase
of what
what quake was all about it was this
graphics technology that nobody had seen
there
and it was a while before you know there
were competitive things out there
and it went a long time internally
really not working where we were even
building levels where uh the game just
was not at all shippable with large
fractions of the world like disappearing
not being there i've or being really
slow in various parts of it and it was
this act of faith it's like i think i'm
going to be able to fix this i think i'm
going to be able to make this work i'm
and
lots of stuff changed where the level
designers would build something and have
to throw it away as something
fundamental and the kind of graphics or
level technology change
and
the uh
so there were two big things that
contributed to making it possible at
that time frame i am
two new things there was certainly
hardcore optimized low level assembly
language this was where i had hired
michael a brash away from microsoft and
he had been one of my early inspirations
where that back in the soft disk days
the library of magazines that they had
some of my most treasured ones were
michael a brash's uh articles in dr
dobbs journal and it was it was amazing
after all of our success in doom we were
able to kind of hit him up and say hey
we'd like you to come work at id
software and he was in the senior
technical role at microsoft and
i am you know and he was on track for
and this was right when microsoft was
starting to take off and i did
eventually you know convince him that
what we were doing was going to be
really amazing with quake it was going
to it was going to be something nobody
had seen before it had these aspects of
what we were talking about and we had
metaverse talk back then we you know we
had read snow crash and we were we knew
about this and uh michael was i was big
into the science fiction and we would
talk about all that and kind of spin
this tale and it was some of the same
conversations that we have today about
the metaverse about how you could have
different areas linked together by
portals and you could have user
generated content and changing out all
these things so you really were creating
the metaverse with quake and we we
talked about things like philosophy you
used to be advertised as a virtual
reality experience you know that was the
first wave of virtual reality was in the
late 80s and early 90s you had like the
lawn mower man
you know movie and you had time in
newsweek talking about the early vpl
headsets and of course that cratered so
hard that people didn't want to look at
virtual reality for decades afterwards
where uh it was just it was spoken
mirrors it was not real in the sense
that you could actually do something
real and valuable with it but uh but
still we had that kind of common set of
talking points and we were talking about
what these games could uh could become
and how you'd like to see people
building all of these creative things
because we were seeing an explosion of
work with doom at that time where people
were doing amazingly cool things like we
saw cooler levels than we had built
coming out of the user community and
then people finding ways to you know
change the the characters in different
ways and it was great and we knew what
we were doing in quake was removing
those last things there was some quirky
things with a couple of the data types
that didn't work right for overriding
and then and then the core thing about
the programming model
and i was definitely going to hit all of
those in quake um
but the the graphics side of it was i
was still
i knew what i wanted to do and it was
one of these
hubris things where it's like well so
far i've been able to kind of
kick everything that i set out to go do
but quake was definitely a little bit
more than could be comfortably chewed at
that point and i but michael was one of
the
one of the strongest programmers and
graphics programmers that i knew he was
one of the people that i trusted to to
write assembly code you know better than
i could and there's there's a few people
that i can point to about things like
this where i'm a world-class optimizer i
mean i make things go fast but i
recognize there's a number of people
that can write tighter assembly code
tighter sim decode or tighter cuda code
then you know then i can write i'm you
know my best strengths are a little bit
more at the system level i mean i'm good
at all of that but
the most leverage comes from making the
decisions that are a little bit higher
up where you figure out how to change
your large scale problems so that these
lower level problems are easier to do or
it makes it possible to do them in a
in a uniquely fast way so most of my
you know my big wins in a lot of ways
from all the way from the early games
through you know through vr and the
aerospace work that i'm doing and or did
and hopefully the ai work that i'm
working on now is finding an angle on
something that means you trade off
something that you maybe think you need
but it turns out you don't need and by
making a sacrifice in one place you can
get big advantages in another place is
it clear at which level of the system
those big advantages can be gained
it's not always clear and that's why
the thing that that i try to make one of
my core values and i i proselytize to a
lot of people is trying to know the
entire stack you know trying to see
through everything that happens and it's
almost impossible on like the web
browser level of things where there's so
many levels to it but you should at
least understand what they all are even
if you can't understand all the
performance characteristics at each
level but it goes all the way down to
literally the hardware so what does the
what is this chip capable of and what is
this software that you're writing
capable of and then with this
architecture you put on top of that then
the ecosystem around it all the people
that are that are working on it so there
are there are all these decisions and
they're never made in a globally optimal
way but sometimes you can drive a thread
of global optimality through it you
can't look at everything it's too
complicated but sometimes you can step
back up and make a different decision
and we kind of went through this on the
graphics side on quake where i in some
ways it was kind of bad where michael
would spend his time writing like i'd
i'd rough out the basic routines like
okay here's our span rasterizer and he
would spend a month writing this you
know beautiful cycle optimized
piece of assembly language that does you
know does what i asked it to do and he
did it faster than like my original code
would do or probably what i would be
able to do even if i had spent that
month on it i but then we'd have some
cases when i'd be like okay well i
figured out at this higher level instead
of drawing these in a painter's order
here i do a span buffer and it cuts out
30 or 40 of all of these pixels but it
means you need to rewrite kind of this
interface of all of that and i could
tell that war on him a little bit but in
the end it was it was the right thing to
do where we wound up changing that
rasterization approach and we wound up
with a super optimized assembly language
core loop and then a good system around
it which minimized how much that had to
be called and so in order to be able to
do this kind of system level thinking
whether we're talking about
game development
aerospace
nuclear energy
ai
vr you have to be able to understand the
hardware
the low-level software the high-level
software the design decisions the whole
thing the the full stack of it yeah and
that's where a lot of these things
become possible when you're really when
you're bringing the future forward i
mean there's a pace that everything just
kind of glides towards where we have a
lot of progress that's happening at such
a dif so many different ways you kind of
slide towards progress just left your
own programs just get faster for a while
it wasn't clear if they were going to
get fatter more than they get quicker
than they get faster and it cancels out
but it is clear now in retrospect no
programs just get faster and have gotten
faster for a long time but if you want
to do something like back at that
original
talking about
scrolling games say what this needs to
be five times faster well we can wait
six years and just it'll naturally get
that much faster at that time or you
come up with some really clever way of
doing it so there are those
opportunities like that in a whole bunch
of different areas now
most programmers don't need to to be
thinking about that there's not that
many you know there's a lot of
opportunities for this but it's not
everyone's work a day type stuff so
everyone doesn't have to know how all
these things work they don't have to
know how their compiler works how you
know the processor chip manages cache
eviction and all these low-level things
but
sometimes there are powerful
opportunities that you can look at and
say we can bring the future five years
faster you know we can do something that
wouldn't it be great if we could do this
well we can do it today if we make a
certain set of decisions and it is in
some ways smoke and mirrors where you
say it's like doom was a lot of smoke
and mirrors where people thought it was
more capable than it actually was but we
picked the right smoke and mirrors to
deploy in the game where
by doing this people will think that
it's more general if we're going to
amaze them with what they've got here
and they won't notice
that it doesn't do these other things so
smart decision making at that point
that's where that
that kind of
global holistic top-down view uh can
work and
i'm
i'm really a strong believer that
technology
should be
sitting at that table having those
discussions because you do have cases
where you say well you want to be the
jonathan ivy or whatever where it's a a
pure design solution and
that's i in some cases now where you
truly have almost infinite resources
like if you're trying to do a a
scrolling game on the pc now you don't
even have to talk to a technology person
you can just have i you know any intern
can make that go run as fast as it needs
to there and it can be completely design
based but if you're trying to do
something that's hard either that can't
be done for resources like vr on a
mobile chipset or that we don't even
know how to do yet like artificial
general intelligence it's probably going
to be a matter of coming at it from an
angle like i mean for agi we have some
of like what are some of the hutter
principles about how you can you know
acer
some of the there are theoretical ways
that you can say this is the optimal
learning algorithm that can solve
everything but it's completely
impractical you know you just can't do
that so clearly you have to make some
concessions for general intelligence and
nobody knows what the right ones are yet
so people are taking different angles of
attack i hope i've got something clever
to come up with in that space
it's been surprising to me and i think
perhaps it is a principle of progress
that smoke and mirrors somehow is the
way you build the future
you kind of
you kind of fake it till you make it and
you almost always make it and i think
that's going to be the way we achieve
agi that's going to be the way we build
uh consciousness into our machines is
there's you know philosophers debate
about the touring test
is essentially about faking it till you
make it you start by faking it and i
think that always leads
to making it
because if you look at history arguments
when as soon as people start talking
about qualia and consciousness and
chinese rooms and things it's like i
just check out i just don't think
there's any value in those conversations
it's just like go ahead tell me it's not
going to work i'm going to do my best to
try to make it work anyways
i don't know if you work with legged
robots and a bunch of these
um
they they make they sure as heck make me
feel like they're cautious
in a certain way that's not here today
but is um
you could see the kernel yeah it's like
uh
the the the flame the beginnings of a
flame we don't have line of sight but
there's glimmerings of light in the
distance for all of these things yeah
i'm hearing murmuring in a distant room
um
well let me ask you a human question
here you you've uh in the game design
space you've done a lot of incredible
work throughout but in terms of game
design
you have changed the world and there's a
few people around you that did the same
so famously there's some animosity
there's much love but there's some
animosity between you and john romero
what is at the core of that animosity
and human tension and so there really
hasn't been i
for a long time and even at the
beginning it's like yes i am
i did push romero out of the company and
and this is one of the things that i
look back if i could go back telling my
my younger self
um some advice about things
the original
founding
kind of corporate structure of id
software
really led to a bunch of problems we
started off with us as equal partners
and we had a buy sell agreement because
we didn't want outsiders to be telling
us what to do inside the company and
that did lead to a bunch of the problems
where i was sitting here going
it's like all right i'm i'm working
harder than anyone i'm doing these
technologies you know nobody's done
before but we're all equal partners and
then i see you know somebody that's not
working as hard and i
and it's i mean i can't say i was the
most mature about that i was you know 20
something years old and i am
and it did it did bother me when i'm
like everybody okay we need all pull
together and we've done it before
everybody we know we can do this if we
get together and we grind it all out but
not everybody wanted to do that for
for all time you know and i was the
youngest one of the the crowd there i i
had different sets of kind of
backgrounds and motivations and left at
that point where
it was i'm all right either everybody
has to be contributing like up to this
level or they need to get pushed out was
not i am that was not a great situation
and i look back on it and no that we
pushed people out of the company that
could have contributed uh if there was a
different framework for them and the
modern kind of silicon valley like let
your stock vest over a time period and
maybe it's non-voting stock and all
those different things we knew nothing
about any of that i mean we we didn't
know what we were doing in terms of
corporate structure or anything so if
you think the framework was different
some of the human tension could have
been a little bit it almost certainly
would have i i mean i look back at that
and
and it's like even trying to summon up
in my mind it's like i know i was really
really angry about i am you know like
romero not working as hard as i wanted
him to work or not carrying his load on
the design for quake and coming up with
things
there but you know he was definitely
doing things he made some of the best
levels there he was working with our i
some of our external teams like raven on
the licensing side of things but i am
yeah but there were differences of
opinion uh about it but he landed you
know right on his feet he went he got 20
million dollars from idos to go do ion
storm and he got to do things his way
and spun up three teams simultaneously
because that was always one of the one
of the challenging things in it id where
we were doing these single string one
project after another and i think some
of them you know wanted to grow the
company more and i didn't because i knew
people that were saying that oh
companies turned to [ __ ] when you got 50
employees i it's just a different world
there and i loved our little
dozen people working on the projects but
you can look at it and say well business
realities matter it's like you're super
successful here and we could we could
take a swing and a miss on something but
you do it a couple times and you're out
of luck uh there's
there's a reason companies try to have
multiple teams running at one time i am
and so that was again something i didn't
really appreciate back then
so if you look past all that you did
create some amazing things together what
did you love about john romero what did
you respect and appreciate about him
what did you admire about him what did
you learn from him
when i met him he was the coolest
programmer i had ever met i you know he
had done all of this stuff he had he had
made all of these games he had worked at
i you know one of the companies that i
thought was the coolest at origin
systems and he knew all this stuff he
made things happen fast and he could it
was also kind of a polymath about this
where he could do he made his own he
drew his own art he made his own levels
as well as um you know he worked on
sound design systems on top of actually
being a really good programmer and we
had you know we went through
a little it was kind of fun where one of
the early things that we did where there
was kind of the young buck bit going in
where i was uh the new guy and he was
the kind of the he was the top man
programmer at the soft disc area and
eventually we had sort of a challenge
over the weekend that we were gonna like
race to to implement this game to port
one of our pc games back down to the
apple too and that was where we finally
kind of became clear it's like okay
carmack stands a little bit apart on the
programming side of things and uh but
romero then very gracefully moved into
well he'll work on the tools he'll work
on the systems uh do some of the game
design stuff as well as contributing on
starting to lead the design aspects of a
lot of things
so he was you know enormously valuable
in the early stuff and so much of doom
uh and even quake have his stamp on it
in a lot of ways but um
you know he wasn't at the same level of
focus that that i brought to the the
work that we were doing there and he
really did
i
we hit such a degree of success
it was all in the press about that the
the rockstar game programmers yeah yeah
it's the beatles problem yeah i mean
you know he ate it up and he did
personified there was the whole game
developers with you know with ferraris
that uh that we had there
and i thought that you know that led to
some
some challenges there
but so much of the uh you know the stuff
that was great in the games did come
from him and i would certainly not take
that away from him and even after i
after we parted ways and he took his
swing with uh with idos in some ways he
was like he was ahead of the curve with
mobile gaming as well where uh one of
his companies after idos was working on
uh feature phone game development and i
wound up doing some of that uh just
before the iphone crossing over into the
iphone phase there and that was
something that clearly did turn out to
be a huge thing although he was he was
too early for what he was working on at
that time
you know we've had uh pretty you know
cordial relationships where i was happy
to talk with him anytime i'd run into
him at at a conference i have actually
had some other people just say it's like
oh you shouldn't you know you shouldn't
go over there and give him the time of
day or felt that
masters of doom was i
you know like portray played things up
in a way that i shouldn't be too happy
with but i'm i'm okay with all of that
and you've got love in your heart yeah i
mean i just talked with him by like last
year or i guess it was even this year
about mentioning that i'm going off
doing this ai stuff i'm i'm going big
into artificial intelligence and he had
a bunch of ideas for how ai is going to
play into gaming and you know asked if i
was interested in collaborating and it's
not in line with what with what i'm
doing but i do you know i wish almost
everyone the best i mean i i know i may
not have parted on the best of terms
with i you know with some people but i
was thrilled to see tom hall i writing
vr games now he wrote working on a game
called demio which is
really an awesome vr game it's like
dungeons and dragons we all used to play
dungeons and dragons together that was
one of the things that was what we did
on sundays in the early days i would
dungeon master and they'd all play and i
you know so it really made me smile
seeing tom involved with an rpg game in
virtual reality
you were the cto of oculus vr since
2013 and maybe lessen your involvement a
bit
in uh
2019
oculus was acquired by facebook now meta
in 2014.
you've spoken brilliantly about both the
low-level details the experimental
design and the big picture vision of
virtual reality
let me ask you about the uh the
metaverse the big question here both
philosophically and technically
how hard is it to build the metaverse
what is the metaverse in your view you
started with discussing and thinking
about quake as a kind of a metaverse
as you think about it today what is the
metaverse
the thing that could create this
compelling user value this experience
that will change the world and how hard
is it to build it
so the term comes from neil stephenson's
book snow crash which many of us had
read back in the 90s it was one of those
kind of formative books and there was
this sense that
the
the possibilities and kind of the the
freedom and unlimited capabilities to
build a virtual world that that does
whatever you want whatever you ask of it
has been a powerful draw for generations
of developers you know game developers
specifically and people that are
thinking about more
more general purpose applications
so we were talking about that back in
the doom and quake days about how do you
wind up with an interconnected set of
worlds that you kind of visit from one
to another and as web pages were
becoming a thing you start thinking
about how what is the interactive kind
of 3d based equivalent of this and there
were a lot of really bad takes you had
like verbal then
virtual reality markup languages and
there's aspects like that that
that came from people saying well what
would what kind of capabilities should
we develop to
to enable this and that kind of
capability first work has usually not
panned out very well
on the other hand we have successful
games that started with things like doom
and quake and communities that formed
around those and uh whether it was
server lists in the early days or you
know literal portaling between different
games and then modern things that are on
completely different order of magnitude
like minecraft and fortnite that have
100 million plus users
um
you know i still think that that's the
right way to go to build the metaverse
is you build something that's amazing
that people love and people wind up
spending all their time in
because it's awesome and you expand the
capabilities of that so yeah even if
it's a very basic experience
minecraft is minecraft is an amazing
case study in so many things
basically what's going on
with that is really enlightening
and there are other cases where like
right now roblox is basically a game
construction kit aimed at kids and that
was a capability first play and it's
achieving scale that's on the same order
of those things so
it's not impossible but my preferred bet
would be you make something amazing that
people love and you make it better and
better and that's where i could say we
could have gone back and followed a path
kind of like that in the early days if
you just kind of take the same game
whether it's when activision
demonstrated that you could make call of
duty every year and not only is it not
bad people kind of love it and it's a
it's very profitable the idea that you
could have taken something like that it
take a great game
release a new version every year that
lets the capabilities grow and expand to
start saying it's like okay it's a game
about running around and shooting things
but now you can have i bring your media
into it you can i add persistence of
social sense sinus signs of life or
whatever you want to add to it i i still
think that's you know quite a good
position to take and i think that while
meta is doing a bottoms-up capability
approach with horizon worlds where it's
a fairly general purpose creators can
build whatever they want in their sort
of thing
i am you know it's it's hard to compare
and compete with something like fortnite
which also has enormous amounts of
creativity even though it was not
designed originally as a general purpose
sort of thing
so there's we have examples on both
sides me personally i would have bet on
uh trying to do entertainment valuable
destination first and expanding from
there so
can you imagine the thing that will be
kind of if we look back a couple
centuries from now
and you think about the experiences
that marked the singularity the
transition
in
where most of our world moved into
virtual reality what do you think those
experiences will look like
so i do think it's gonna be kind of like
the way the web
slowly took over where you're you're the
the frog in the pot of water that's
slowly heating up where having lived
through all of that i remember when it
was shocking to start seeing uh seeing
the first website address on a billboard
when you're like hey my computer world
is in infecting the real world you know
this is spreading out uh in some way but
they're still when you look back and say
well what what made the web take off and
it wasn't a big bang sort of moment
there it was a bunch of little things
that turned out not even be the things
that are relevant now
that brought them into it so well i
wonder if from i mean like you said
you're not a historian
so maybe there's a historian
out there that could really identify
that moment
data-driven way it could be like myspace
or something like that
maybe the first major social network
that really reached into
non-geek world or something like that i
think that's kind of the fallacy of
historians though looking for some of
those kind of primary dominant causes
where so many of these things are like
we see an exponential curve but it's not
because like one thing is going
exponential it's because we have
hundreds of little sigmoid curves
overlapped on top of each other and they
just happen to keep adding up so that
you've got something kind of going
exponential at any given point but not
no single one of them was the critical
thing there were you know dozens and
dozens of things i mean seeing the
transitions of stuff like as obviously
myspace giving way to other things but
even like blogging giving way to uh to
social media and getting resurrected in
other guyses and the meme things that
happened there dancing baby gif or
whatever the all your base now belong to
us whatever those early memes that led
to the modern memes and the humor on the
different the different evolution of
humor on the internet i'm sure the
historians will also write books about
uh from the different websites that
support to create the infrastructure for
that humor like reddit and all that kind
of stuff
so people will go back and they will
name firsts and critical moments but
it's probably going to be a poor
approximation of what actually happens
and we've already seen like in the vr
space where
it didn't play out the way we thought it
would in terms of what was going to be
like when
the modern era of vr basically started
with my e3 demo of doom 3 on the rift
prototype so we're like first person
shooters in vr match made in heaven
right
and that didn't work out that way at all
they have you know they have the most
comfort problems with it and then the
most popular virtual reality app is beat
saber which nobody predicted back then
what's that make you
uh like
from first principles if you were to
like reverse engineer that why are these
like silly fun games the most it
actually makes very clear sense when you
when you analyze it from from hindsight
and look at the engineering reasons
where it's not just that it was a
magical quirky idea it was something
that played almost perfectly to what
turned out to be the real strengths of
vr where the one thing that i really
underestimated importance in vr was the
importance of the controllers you know i
was still thinking we could do a lot
more with uh with the gamepad and just
the amazingness of taking any existing
game being able to move your head around
and look around that that was you know
that was really amazing but the
controllers uh were super important but
the problem is so many things that you
do with the controllers just
suck it feels like it breaks the
illusion like trying to pick up glasses
with the controllers where you're like
oh use the grip button when you're kind
of close and it'll snap into your hand
all of those things are unnatural
actions that you do them and it's still
part of the vr experience but
beat saber winds up by playing only to
the strengths it completely hides all
the weaknesses of it because you are
holding something in your hand you keep
a solid grip on it the whole time it
slices through things without ever
bumping into things you never get into
the point where you know i'm knocking on
this table but in vr my hand just goes
right through it so you've got something
that slices through so it's never your
brain telling you oh i should have hit
something you've got a lightsaber here
it's just you expect it to slice through
everything uh audio and music turned out
to be a really powerful aspect of
virtual reality where you're blocking
the world off and constructing the world
around you
and i and being something that can run
efficiently on even this relatively
low-powered hardware and can have a
valuable loop in a small amount of time
where a lot of modern games you're
supposed to sit down and play it for an
hour just to get anywhere sometimes new
game takes an hour to get through the
tutorial level and that's not good for
vr for a couple reasons you do still
have the comfort issues if you're moving
around at all but you've also got just
you know discomfort from the headset
battery life span on the mobile versions
so having things that do break down into
three and four minute windows of play
that turns out to be very valuable from
a gameplay standpoint
so it winds up being kind of a perfect
storm of all these things that are
really good it doesn't have any comfort
problems you're not navigating around
you're standing still all the stuff
flies at you it has placed audio
strengths i it adds the whole fitness in
vr nobody was thinking about that back
in the at the beginning and it turns out
that that is an excellent daily fitness
thing to be doing if you go play uh an
hour of beat saver or supernatural or
something that is legit solid exercise
uh and it's more fun than doing it just
about any other way there so that's kind
of the arcade stage of things
if i were to say with my experience with
vr
the thing that i think is powerful is
the
maybe it's not here yet
but the degree to which it is immersive
in the way
that quake is immersive it takes you to
another world for me because i'm a fan
of role playing games
uh the elder scrolls series
uh like
skyrim or even daggerfall it just takes
you to another world and when you're not
in that world you miss not being there
and then you just you kind of want to
stay there forever because life is
shitty
and you just want to go to these places
is that i there was a
there was a time when i we were kind of
asked to come up with like what's your
view about vr and i am you know my pitch
was that it should be better inside the
headset than outside it's the world as
you want it yeah and everybody thought
that was dystopian and like that's like
oh you're just gonna forget about the
world outside and i don't get that
mindset where the idea that if you can
make the world better inside the headset
than outside
you've just improved the person's life
that's has a headset that can wear it
and there are plenty of things that we
just can't do for everyone in the real
world everybody can't have richard
branson's private island but everyone
can have a private vr island and it can
have the things that they want on it and
there's a lot of these kind of rivalrous
goods in the real world that vr can just
be better at we can do a lot of things
like that that can be very very rich so
yeah i want the i think it's going to be
a positive thing this world where people
want to go back into their headset where
it can be better than somebody that's
living in a tiny apartment can have a
palatial estate in virtual reality they
can have all their friends from all over
the world come over and visit them
without everybody getting on a plane and
i and meeting in some place and dealing
with all the other logistics hassles
there is real value in the you know the
presence that you can get for remote
meetings it's
it's all the little things that we need
to sort out but those are things that we
have line of sight on people you know
that have been in like a good vr meeting
using workrooms where you can say oh
that was better than a zoom meeting but
of course it's more of a hassle to get
into it not everyone has a headset
interoperability is worse you can't have
you cap out at a certain number there's
all these things that need to be fixed
but that's one of those things you can
look at and say we know there's value
there we just need to really grind hard
to file off all the rough edges and make
that possible so you do think we have
line of sight
because
there's a there's a reason like
i i do this podcast in person for
example
doing it remotely
it's not the same and if you if somebody
were to ask me why it's not the same i
wouldn't be able to write down exactly
why um but you're saying
that it's possible whatever the magic is
for in-person interaction
that immersiveness of the experience
we are almost there yes so the idea of
like i'm
doing a vr interview with someone i'm
not saying it's here right now but you
can see glimmers of what it should be
and we largely know what would need to
be fixed and improved to like you say
there's a difference between a remote
interview doing a podcast over zoom or
something and face to face there's that
sense of presence that immediacy the
super low latency responsiveness being
able to see all the subtle things there
just occupying the same field of view
and all of those are things that we
absolutely can do in vr and that simple
case of a small meeting with a couple
people that's the much easier case than
everybody thinks the ready player won
multiverse with a thousand people going
across uh you know a huge bridge to
amazing places that's harder in a lot of
other technical ways not to say we can't
also do that but that's further away and
has more challenges but this small thing
about being able to have a meeting with
one or a few people and have it feel
real feel like you're there uh like you
have the same interactions and talking
with them you get subtle cues as we
start getting eye and face tracking and
some of the other things on high-end
headsets a lot of that is going to come
over
and it doesn't have to be as good this
is an important thing that people miss
where
there was a lot of people that
especially rich people that would look
at vr and say it's like oh this just
isn't that good and i'd say it's like
well you've already been courtside
backstage and you know on pit row and
you've done all of these experiences
because you get to do them in real life
but most people don't get to and even if
the experience is only half as good if
it's something that they never would
have gotten to do before it's still a
very good thing and as we can just we
can push that number up over time it has
a minimum
viable value level when it does
something that is valuable enough to
people as long as it's better inside the
headset on any metric than it is outside
and people choose to go there we're on
the right path and we have a value
gradient that i'm just always hammering
on we can just follow this value
gradient just keep making things better
rather than going for that one
close your eyes swing for the fences
kind of
silver bullet approach well i wonder if
there's a value gradient for in-person
meetings because if you get that right
i mean that would change the world yeah
it doesn't need to
i mean you don't need uh ready player
one i but
i wonder if there's that value gradient
you can follow along
because
if there is and you follow it then uh
there will be a certain like phase shift
that's a certain point where people will
shift from um
from zoom to this
uh i wonder
what what are the bottlenecks is it
software is it hardware is it like is it
is it all about latency so i have big
arguments internally about strategic
things like that where i
like the next headset that's coming out
and that we've made various
announcements about is going to be a
higher end headset more expensive more
features lots of people want to make
those those trade-offs i you know we'll
see what the market has to say about the
exact trade-offs we've made here but if
you want to replace zoom you need to
have something that everybody has i'm
and so you like cheaper i like cheaper
because also
lighter and cheaper wind up being uh a
virtuous cycle there where expensive and
more features tends to also lead towards
heavier and it just kind of goes it's
like let's add more features the
features are not uh
you know they have physical presence and
weight and draw from batteries and all
of those things so i've always favored a
lower end uh cheaper faster approach
that's why i was always behind the
mobile side of vr rather than the higher
end pc headsets and i think that's you
know that's proven out well
but there's i you always ideally we have
a whole range of things but if you've
only got one or two things it's
important that those two things cover
the
uh you know the scope that you think is
most important when we're in a world
when it's like cell phones and there's
50 of them on the market covering every
conceivable ecological niche you want
that's going to be great but we're not
going to be there for a while where are
the bottlenecks
is it the hardware the software yeah so
right now i
you can play you can get uh workrooms on
quest and you can set up these things
and it's a pretty good experience it's
surprisingly good i haven't tried it
it's surprisingly good
the voice latency is better on that than
a lot better than a zoom meeting so
you've got a more a better sense of
immediacy there the expressions that you
get from the the current hardware with
just kind of your controllers and your
head is pretty realistic feeling you've
got a pretty good sense of being there
with someone with are these like uh
avatars of people like do you do do you
get to see their body yeah
and they're sitting around a table yeah
and it feel it feels it's better than
zooming better than you yeah better than
you'd expect for that it is definitely
yeah i'd say it's it's quite a bit
better than zoom when everything's
working right but there's still all the
rough edges of the reason zoom became so
successful is because they just nailed
the usability of everything it's high
quality with a absolutely first-rate
experience and we are not there yet with
any of the vr stuff i'm trying to to
push hard to get
i i keep talking about it's like it
needs to just be one click to make
everything happen and we're getting
there in our our home environment not
the whole work rooms application but the
main home where you can now kind of go
over and click an invite and it still
winds up taking five times longer than
it should but we're getting close to
that where you click there they click on
their button and then they're sitting
there in this good presence with you but
latencies need to get a lot better user
interface needs to get a lot better um
ubiquity of the headsets needs to get
better we need to have 100 million of
them
out there just so that everybody knows
somebody that uses this all the time
well i think it's a virtuous cycle
because i do think
the interface
is the thing that makes or breaks
this kind of revolution it's so
interesting how like uh you said one
click but it's also like how you achieve
that one click
i don't know what is um
can i ask a dark question maybe let's
keep it outside of meta but
this is about meta but also google and
big company
are they able to do this kind of thing
it seems like let me put on my cranky
old manhattan is
they seem to
not do a good job of
creating these user-friendly interfaces
as they get bigger and bigger as a
company like google has created some of
the greatest interfaces ever
uh early on and it's i mean creating
gmail
just so many brilliant
interfaces and she seems to be getting
crappier and crappier at that same with
meta same with uh
uh microsoft it's just it seems to get
worse and worse at that as this i don't
know what is it because you become more
conservative careful
risk-averse
is that why can you speak to that then
really eye-opening to me working inside
a tech titan where
i am you know i i had my small companies
and then we're acquired by a you know a
mid-sized game publisher and then uh
oculus getting acquired by meta and meta
has grown by a factor of many just in
the
the eight years since the acquisition
so i did not have experience with this
and it's
it was interesting because i remember
like previously my benchmark for uh kind
of use of resources was some of the
government programs i interacted with on
the aerospace side and i remember
thinking there was okay there's an air
force program and they spent 50 million
dollars and they didn't they didn't
launch anything they didn't even build
anything it was just kind of like they i
you know they made a bunch of papers and
had some parts in uh in a warehouse and
nothing came of it it's like 50 million
dollars
i am and i have i've had to radically
recalibrate my sense of like how much
money can be spent with uh without a
product at the end of resources
where
on the ver the plus side vr has turned
out we've built
pretty much exactly what you know we
just passed the 10-year mark then from
my like my first demo of the rift and if
i could have said what i wanted to have
it would have been a standalone inside
out tracked 4k resolution headset that i
that could still plug into a pc for
high-end rendering and that's exactly
what we've got on quest 2. right now
first of all let's pause on that with me
being cranky and everything it's what
meta achieved uh with oculus and so on
is incredible
i mean this is
this
when i thought about the future of vr
that's what i imagined in terms of
hardware i would say and maybe in terms
of the experience as well but
it's still not there somehow
on the one hand we did kind of achieve
it and win and we've got we've sold you
know we're a success right now but
the amount of resources that have gone
into it it winds up getting clouded up
in accounting where last mark did
announce that they spent 10 billion
dollars a year like on reality labs now
reality labs covers a lot it was vr was
not the large part of it also had portal
and spark and the big ar research
efforts and it's been expanding out to
include ai and other things there where
uh there's a lot going on there but 10
billion dollars was just a number that i
had trouble processing it's just i feel
sick to my stomach thinking about that
much money being spent but that's how
they they demonstrate commitment to this
where it's not i'm
more so than like yeah google goes and
cancels all these projects
different things i like that while meta
is really sticking with the funding of
vr and ar is still further out with it
so there's something to be said for that
i
it's not just going to vanish the work's
going in i just wish it could be
all those resources could be applied
more effectively because i see all these
cases i point out these examples of how
a third party that we're kind of
competing with in various ways there's a
number of these examples and they do
work with a tenth of the people that we
do internally uh and a lot of it comes
from yes there's the small company can
just go do it while in a big company you
do have to worry about i you know is
there some sdk internally that you
should be using because another team's
making it you have to have your
cross-functional group meetups for
different things you do have more
concerns about you know about privacy or
diversity and equity and
safety of different things parental
issues and things that a small startup
company can just kind of you know cowboy
off and do something interesting and
there's a lot more
that is a problem that you have to pay
attention to in the big companies but
i'm not willing to believe that we are
within even a factor of two or four of
what the efficiency could be you know i
i am constantly
kind of crying out for it's like we can
do better than this and you wonder what
the mechanisms to unlock that efficiency
are you know i i don't
there is some sense in a large company
that
like an individual engineer might not
believe that they can change the world
maybe you you delegate a little bit of
the
responsibility to be the one who changes
the world in a big company i think but
the reality is
like the world will get changed by a
single engineer anyway
so if whether inside google or inside a
startup it doesn't matter it's just like
google and meta needs to help those
engineers believe they're the ones that
are going to decrease that latency it'll
take one john carmack like the 20 year
old
carmack
that's inside meta right now to change
everything and i try to point that out
and push people it's like try to go
ahead and when you see something because
there is you get the silo mentality
where you're like okay i know
something's not right over there but
that's i'm staying in my lane here i
and there's there's a couple people that
i can you know i can think about that
are willing to just like hop all over
the place and man i treasure them the
people that are just willing to they're
fearless you know they will go over and
they will go rebuild the kernel and
change this distribution and go in and
hack the firmware over here to to get
something done right and that is
relatively rare you know there's
thousands of developers and you've got a
small handful that are willing to
operate at that level
and you know and it's potentially risky
for the the politics are you know are
real in a lot of that and i'm in the you
know very much the privileged position
of i am you know i'm more or less
untouchable there where i've been dinged
like twice for it's like you said
something insensitive in that post and i
and you should probably not say that i
am but for the most part yes i you know
i get away with i every week i'm posting
something you know pretty loud and
opinionated in you know internally and i
think that's useful for the company
but i'm
yeah it's not if it's rare to have a
position like that and i can't
necessarily offer advice for how someone
can do that i well you could offer
advice to a company in general to give a
little bit of freedom
for the young wild the wildest ideas
come from
the young minds
uh and so you need to give the young
minds freedom to to think big and wild
and and crazy and for that they have to
be opinionated they have to be um
they have to think crazy ideas and
thoughts and pursue them with a full
passion without being slowed down by
bureaucracy or managers and all that
kind of stuff
obviously startups really empower that
but big companies could too and that's
that's the design challenge for
companies for big companies to see how
can you enable that how can you power
the big company there are so many
resources there and they do
amazing things do get accomplished but
there's so much more that could come out
of that and you know i'm hope i'm always
hopeful i'm an optimist in almost
everything you know i think things can
get better i think that they can improve
things that you go through a path and
you're learning kind of what does and
doesn't work and i'm not i'm not ready
to be fatalistic about the kind of the
outcome of any of that uh me neither i
know too many good people inside of
those large companies that are
incredible
you have a friendship with elon musk
uh often when i talk to him he'll bring
up how incredible of an engineer and
just a big pink shader thinker you are
his a huge amount of respect uh for you
i just
i've never been a fly on the wall
between the discussion between the two
of you i just wonder is there something
you guys
debate argue about discuss is there some
interesting problems that the two of you
think about
you come from different worlds maybe
there's some intersection in the in
aerospace maybe there's some
intersection
in your new efforts in artificial
intelligence in terms of thinking is
there something interesting you could
say about sort of the debates the two of
you have so i think in some ways we do
have a kind of similar background where
we're almost exactly the same age and we
had kind of similar programming
backgrounds on the personal computers
and you know even some of the the books
that we would read and things that would
kind of turn us into the people that we
are today
and i think there is a degree of
sensibility similarities where you know
we kind of call [ __ ] on the same
things and kind of see the same
opportunities in different technology
and there's that sense of you know i
always talk about the speed of light
solutions for things and he's thinking
about kind of minimum manufacturing and
engineering and
operational standpoints for things
and so i mean i first met elon right at
the start of the aerospace era where i
wasn't familiar with uh you know i was
still in my game dev bubble i really
wasn't familiar with all the startups
that were going and being successful and
what went on with paypal and all of his
different companies but you know i met
him as i was starting to do armadillo
aerospace and you know he came down with
kind of his right-hand propulsion guy
and we we talked about rockets you know
what can we what can we do with this and
it was kind of specific things about
like how are how are our flight
computers set up what are different
propellant options i am you know what
can happen with different uh different
ways of putting things together
and then
in some ways he was certainly the
biggest player in the sort of alt space
community that was going on in the early
2000s
he was
the most well-funded although you know
his funding in the larger scheme of
things compared to a
uh like a nasa or something like that
was really tiny uh it was a lot more
than i had at the time
i
but it was interesting i had a point
years later when i realized okay my like
my financial resources at this point are
basically what elon's was when he went
all in on spacex and tesla
and there's
i i think in many corners he does not
get uh the respect that he should about
being a wealthy person that could just
retire and he went all in where he was
really going to i
you know he could have gone bust and
there's plenty of people you look at the
you know the sad
athletes or or entertainers that had all
the money in the world and blew it he
could have been the business case
example of that
but i
you know the the things that he was
doing space exploration electrification
of transportation uh solar city type
things these are big world level things
and i have a great deal of admiration
that he was willing to throw himself so
completely into that because
in contrast with myself i was doing
armadillo aerospace with this tightly
bounded uh it was john's crazy money at
the time that had a finite limit on it
it was never going to impact me or my
family uh if it completely failed and i
was still hedging my bets working at id
software at the time when he had been
you know really all in there
and i have a huge amount of respect for
that and people do not the other thing i
get irritated with is people that say
it's like oh elon's just just a business
guy you know he just got like he was
gifted the money and he's just kind of
uh investing in all of this when uh he
was really deeply involved in a lot of
the decisions you know
not all of them were perfect but i you
know he cared very much about engine
material selection propellant selection
and i you know for years he'd be kind of
telling me it's like get off that
hydrogen peroxide stuff it's like you
know liquid oxygen is the only proper
oxidizer for this and i
you know and like the the times that
i've gone through the factories with him
we're we're talking very detailed things
about like how this weld is made you
know how this sub assembly goes together
i you know what our like startup
shutdown behaviors of the different
things so he is you know really
in there at a very detailed level and i
think that he is the the best modern
example now of someone that tries to
that can effectively micromanage some
decisions on things on both tesla you
know and spacex to some degree where he
cares enough about it i worry a lot that
he stretched too thin that you get
boring company and neuralink and twitter
and all the other possible things there
where i know i've got i
i've got limits on how much i can pay
attention to uh that i have to kind of
box off different amounts of time and i
look back at like at my aerospace side
of things it's like i did not go all in
on that i did not commit myself at a
level that it would have taken to be
successful there
and
i yeah and it's kind of a weird thing
just uh like having a a discussion with
he's the richest man in the world right
now but he i you know he operates on you
know on a level that is still
uh very much in my wheelhouse on a
technical side of things
so doing that systems level type of
thinking where you can go to the low
level details and go up high to the big
picture
uh do you think
in uh aerospace
arena in the next five ten years do you
think we're gonna put a human on mars
like what do you think is the
interesting
uh no i do in fact i i made a bet with
someone with a group of people kind of
this about whether boots on mars by 2030
and this was kind of a fun you know a
fun story because i was at an intel
sponsored event and we had a bunch of
just world-class brilliant people and we
were talking about computing stuff but
the after dinner conversation was like
what are some other things how they're
going to go in the future and one of the
ones tossed up on the whiteboard was
like boots on mars by 2030
and most of the people in the room
thought yes you know they thought that
like spacex is kicking ass we've got all
this possible stuff i
seems likely that it's going to go that
way and i said no i think less than 50
chance that it's going to make it there
and people you know we're kind of like
oh i you know why the pessimism or
whatever and of course i'm an optimist
at almost everything but for me to be
the the one kind of outlier saying no i
don't think so um then i started saying
some of the things i said well let's be
concrete about it let's i bet ten
thousand dollars that it's not gonna
happen
and this was this was really a startling
thing to see that i again room full of
brilliant people but as soon as like
money came on the line and they were
like do i want to put 10 000 i was not
the richest person in the room uh there
are people much better off than i was
there's a spectrum but
i am you know as soon as they started
think it's like oh i could lose money by
by
keeping uh keeping my position right now
and
all these engineers they engaged their
brain they started thinking it's like
okay
launch windows uh launch delays like how
many times would it take to get this
right what historical precedence do we
have and i and then it mostly came down
to it's like well what about in transit
by 2030 and then i've you know what
about i you know different things or
would you hand would you go for 2032 but
one of the people did go ahead and was
optimistic enough to make a bet with me
so i have a ten thousand dollar bet that
by 2030. i think it's going to happen
shortly thereafter i think there will
probably be infrastructure on mars by
2030 but i don't think that we'll have
humans on mars on 23rd i think it's
possible but i think it's less than a 50
chance so i felt safe making that bet
well i think you had an interesting
point uh correct me if i'm wrong that's
a dark one that's um
that should perhaps help people
appreciate elon musk
which is
in this particular effort
elon is a critical
is critical to the success spacex seems
to be
uh critical to 20 you know
humans on mars by 2030 or thereabouts so
if something happens to elon
then all of this
collapses
and this is in contrast to the the other
ten thousand dollar bet i made kind of
recently and that was self-driving cars
at like a level five running around uh
cities and people have kind of nitpicked
that that we probably don't mean exactly
level five but the guy i'm having the
bet with i is we're going to be we know
what we mean about this jeff fatwood
yeah coding horror and
all yeah
but i
yeah i mean it's just he doesn't think
that people are going to be riding
around in robo taxis in 2030 uh in major
cities just like like you take an uber
now and i think it will you think it
will and i think and the difference is
everybody looks at this it's like oh but
tesla's been wrong for you they've been
promising it for years and it's not here
yet and the reason this is different
than the bet with mars is mars
really is more than as comfortable a bet
on elon musk i am you know that is you
know that is his thing and he is really
going to move heaven and earth to try to
to make that happen and perhaps not even
spacex yeah perhaps
just elon musk yeah because if if elon
went away and spacex went public and got
a board of directors i
there are more profitable things they
could be doing than focusing on human
presence on mars so this really is a
sort of personal thing there
and in contrast with that self-driving
cars have a dozen credible companies
working really hard and while
yes it's going slower than most people
thought it would
betting against that is a bet against
almost the entire world in terms of all
of these companies that have all of
these incentives it's not just
you know one guy's passion project i
and i do think that it is solvable i
although there's i recognize it's not
100 chance because it's possible the
long tail of self-driving problems winds
up being an agi complete problem uh i
think there's plenty of value to mine
out of it with narrow ai and i think
that it's you know it's going to happen
probably more so than people expect but
it's that whole sigmoid curve where you
over you know you overestimate the
near-term progress and you underestimate
the long-term progress and i think
self-driving is going to be like that
and i think 2030 is still a pretty good
bet
yeah unfortunately
um self driving is a problem that uh
is safety critical meaning that
if if you don't do it well people get
hurt
but the other side of that is people are
terrible drivers so
it is not going to be that's probably
going to be the argument that gets it
through is like we can save 10 000 lives
a year by taking imperfect self-driving
cars and letting them take over a lot of
driving responsibilities it's like was
it 30 000 people a year die in auto
accidents right now in america and a lot
of those are preventable and the problem
is you'll have people that every time a
tesla crashes into something you've got
a bunch of people that literally have
vested interest shorting tesla to come
out and make it the worst thing in the
world and people will be fighting
against that but optimist in me again i
think that we will have systems that are
statistically safer than human drivers
and we will be saving
thousands and thousands of lives every
year when we can hand over more of those
responsibilities to it i do still think
as a person who studied this problem
very
deeply from a human side as well
it's still an open problem how good
slash bad humans are driving
it's a kind of
funny thing we say about each other oh
humans suck at driving
um
everybody except
you of course like we think we're good
at driving
but i
after really studying it i i think you
start to notice
you know because i've watched uh
hundreds of hours of humans driving with
the projects of this kind of thing
you've noticed that
even with the distraction even with
everything else
humans are able to
to do some incredible things
with the the with the attention even
when you're just looking at the
smartphone just to get cues from the
environment to make less seconds
decisions
to use instinctual type of decisions
that actually save your ass time and
time and time again
and are able to do that with so much
uncertainty around you in such tricky
dynamic environments
i don't know i don't i don't know
exactly
how hard is it to beat
that kind of
skill of common sense reasoning this is
one of those interesting things that
there have been a lot of studies about
how experts in their field usually
underestimate the progress that's going
to happen because an expert thinks about
all the problems they deal with and
they're like damn i'm going to have a
hard time solving all of this and they
filter out the fact that they are one
expert in a field of thousands and you
know you think about yeah i can't do all
of that and you sometimes forget about
the scope of the the ecosystem that
you're embedded in and if you think back
eight years very specifically the state
of ai and machine learning where was
that we we had just gotten resnets
probably at that point and you look at
all the amazing magical things that have
happened in eight years and they do kind
of seem to be happening a little faster
in recent years also and you project
that eight more years into the future
where again i think there's a 50 chance
we're gonna have signs of life of agi
you know which we can put through
driver's ed if we need to to actually
build self-driving cars and i think that
the narrow systems are going to to have
real value demonstrated well before then
so signs of life
in agi you've mentioned that
okay first of all
you're one of the most brilliant people
on this earth you could be solving a
number of different problems as you've
mentioned
your mind was attracted to nuclear
energy obviously virtual reality with
the metaverse is something you could
have a tremendous impact on so i do want
to say a quick thing about nuclear
energy where i
you know this is something that i re
this so precisely feels like aerospace
before spacex where from everything that
i know about all of these i the physics
of this stuff hasn't changed and the
reasons why things are expensive now are
not fundamental
i somebody should be going into a really
hard elon musk style at uh
vision economical fission not fusion
where the fusion is the the kind of the
the darling of people that want to go
and do nuclear because it doesn't have
the taint that fission has in a lot of
people's minds but it's an almost
absurdly complex thing where
nuclear fusion is you look at the
tokamax or any of the things that people
are building and it's doing all of this
infrastructure just at the end of the
day to make something hot so that you
can then turn into energy through a
conventional power plant and all of that
work which we think we've got line of
sight on but even if it comes out then
you have to do all of that immensely
complex expensive stuff just to make
something hot where nuclear fission is
basically you put these two rocks
together and they get hot all by
themselves that is just that much
simpler it's just orders of magnitude
simpler and the actual rocks the refined
uranium is not very expensive it's a
couple percent of the the cost of
electricity that's why i made that point
where you could have something which was
five times less efficient than current
systems and if the rest of the plant was
a whole bunch cheaper you could still be
super super valuable so how much of the
pie do you think
could be solved by nuclear energy by
fission
so how how much could it become the
primary source of energy on earth
it could be most of it like the reserves
of uranium as it stands now could not
power the whole earth but i am you know
you get into breeder reactors and
thorium and things like that that you do
for conventional fission uh there is
enough fur for everything
now i mean solar photovoltaic has been
amazing you know it's i
i one of my current projects is working
on an off-grid system and it's been fun
just kind of again putting my hands on
all the
stripping the wires and wiring things
together and doing all of that and just
having followed that a little bit from
the outside over the last couple decades
there's been semiconductor like magical
progress
in what's going on there so i'm all for
all of that but it doesn't solve
everything and nuclear really still does
seem like the smart money bet for what
you should be getting for baseband on a
lot of things and solar may be cheaper
for uh you know peeking over air
conditioning loads during the the summer
and things that you can push around in
different ways but it's one of those
things that's
it's just strange how we've had the
technology sitting there but these
non-technical reasons on the social
optics of it has been this major forcing
function for something that you know
really should be at the the cornerstone
of all of the world's concerns with
energy it's interesting how the
non-technical factors have really
dominated something that is so
fundamental to kind of the existence of
the human race as we know it today
and much of the troubles of the world
including
wars in different parts of the world
like ukraine is energy based and
yeah it's just sitting right there to be
solved
that said
uh i mean to me personally i think it's
clear that if agi were to be achieved
that would change the course of human
history
agi wise i was
you know i was making this decision
about what do i want to focus on after
vr and i'm still working on vr
regularly i spend a day a week kind of
consulting with meta and i you know baz
styles me the consulting cto is kind of
like the sherlock holmes that comes in
and consults on some of the specific
tough issues and i'm still pretty
passionate about all of that but i have
been
figuring out how to compartmentalize and
force that into a smaller box to work on
some other things and i did come down to
this decision between working on
economical nuclear fission or artificial
general intelligence
and uh the vision side of things i've
i've got a bunch of interesting things
going that way but
it would take that would be a fairly big
project thing to do i don't think it
needs to be as big as people expect i do
think something original spacex sized um
you build it power your building off of
it and then the government i think will
come around to what you need to is
everybody loves an existence proof i
think it's possible somebody should be
doing this but it's going to involve
some politics it's going to involve
decent sized teams and a bunch of this
cross-functional stuff that i don't love
while
the artificial general intelligence side
of things
um
it seems to me like this is
the highest leverage moment for
potentially a single individual
potentially in the history of the world
where
the things that we know about the brain
about what we can do with artificial
intelligence
uh nobody can say absolutely on any of
these things but
i am not a madman
for saying that it is likely that the
code for artificial general intelligence
is going to be
tens of thousands of lines of code not
millions of lines of code this is code
that conceivably one individual could
write unlike writing a new web browser
or operating system
and based on the progress that ai has
machine learning has made in the recent
decade
it's likely that the important things
that we don't know
are relatively simple there's probably a
handful of things and my bet is that
i think there's
less than six key insights that need to
be made each one of them can probably be
written on the back of an envelope we
don't know what they are but when
they're put together in concert with
gpus at scale and the data that we all
have access to that we can make
something that behaves like a human
being or like a living creature and that
can then be educated in whatever ways
that we need to get to the point where
we can have universal remote workers
where anything that somebody does
mediated by a computer and doesn't
require physical interaction uh that an
agi will be able to do we can already
simulate the you know the equivalent of
the zoom
the zoom meetings with avatars and uh
synthetic deep fakes and whatnot we can
definitely do that uh we have super
human capabilities on any narrow thing
that we can uh that we can formalize and
make a loss function for but there's
things we don't know how to do now
but i don't think they are
unapproachably hard now that's
incredibly hubristic to say that it's
like but i think that what i said a
couple years ago is a 50 chance that
somewhere there will be signs of life of
agi in 2030 and i've probably increased
that slightly i may be at 55 60 now
because i do think there's a little
sense of acceleration there
so i wonder what the and by the way you
also written that i i bet with hindsight
we will find that clear antecedents of
all the critical remaining steps for agi
are already buried somewhere in the vast
literature of today so the ideas are
already there
i think that's likely the case one of
the things that appeals to so many
people including me about the promise of
agi is we know that we're only drinking
from a straw from the the fire hose of
all the information out there i mean you
look at just in a very narrowly bounded
field like machine learning like you
can't read all the papers that that come
out all the time you can't go back and
read all the clever things that people
did in the 90s or earlier that people
have forgotten about because they didn't
pan out at the time when they were
trying to do them with 12 neurons
i am
so that this idea that yeah i think
there are gems buried in some of the
older literature that was not the path
taken by everything and you can see a
kind of herd mentality on the things
that happen right now it's almost funny
to see like oh google does something and
open ai does something meta does
something and you know they're the same
people that all talk to each other and
they're all one-upping each other and
they're all capable of implementing each
other's work given a month or two after
somebody has an announcement of that
but there's a there's a whole world of
possible approaches to machine learning
and i think that we probably will in
hindsight go back and see it's like yeah
that was kind of clearly predicted by
this early paper here i you know and
this turns out that if you do this and
this and take this result from
from animal training and this thing from
neuroscience over here and put it
together and set up this curriculum for
them to learn in that that's kind of
what it took
you don't have too many people now that
are still saying it's not possible or
it's going to take hundreds of years and
10 years ago you would get you would
collect get a collection of experts and
you would have a decent chunk on the
margin that either say not possible or
a couple hundred years might be
centuries and the median estimate would
be like 50 70 years and it's been coming
down and i know with me saying eight
years for something that still puts me
on the optimistic side but it's not
crazy out in the fringes and just being
able to look at that at a a meta level
about the trend of the the uh the trend
of the predictions going down there
the idea that something could be
happening relatively soon
now
i do not believe in fast takeoffs you
know that's one of the safety issues
that people say it's like oh it's going
to go foom and the ai's going to take
over the world there's a lot of reasons
i don't think that's a credible position
and i think that we will go from a point
where we start seeing things that that
credibly look like uh look like animals
behaviors and i have a human voice box
wired into them uh it's like i tried to
get elon to say it's like you're you're
pig neurolink give it a human voice box
and let it start
learning human words i i think that you
know i think animal intelligence is
closer to human intelligence than a lot
of people like to think and i think that
culture and modalities of io are
make the gulf seem a lot bigger than it
actually is there's just that smooth
spectrum of how the brain developed and
cortexes and scaling of different things
going on there cultural modalities of io
yes language is
um
sort of lost in translation conceals a
lot of intelligence and
so when you think about signs of life
for agi you're thinking about
human interpretable science so the
example i give if we get to the point
where you've got a learning disabled
toddler some some kind of real special
needs uh child that can still interact
with their favorite tv show and video
game and can be trained and learned in
some appreciably human-like way at that
point you can deploy an army of
engineers cognitive scientists education
developmental uh developmental education
people and you've got so many advantages
there unlike real education where you
can do rollbacks and a b testing and you
can find a golden path through a
curriculum of different things
if you get to that point learning
disabled toddler i think that it's uh
it's going to be a done deal but do you
think we'll we'll know it when we see it
so uh there's there's been a lot of
really interesting general learning
progress from deep mind
uh open the eye a little bit too
i tend to believe that tesla autopilot
deserves a lot more credit than is
getting
for
making progress on the general
yeah on sort of on the doing the
multitask learning thing and increasing
the number of tasks and automating that
process of
uh sort of
learning from the edge discovering the
edge cases and learning from the edge
cases that is
it's really approaching from a different
angle the general learning problem of
agi but the more clear approach comes
from deep mind where you have these kind
of game situations and you
uh build systems
there but i i don't know
um people seem to be quite
um
yeah there will always be people that
just won't believe it and i
fundamentally don't care i mean i don't
care if they don't believe it i you know
when it starts doing people's jobs and i
mean like i don't care about the
philosophical zombie argument absolutely
absolutely but will you do you think you
will notice that something special has
happened here and or
um
because to me i've been noticing a lot
of special things i think
a lot of credit should go to deep bind
for alpha's zero
that was truly special so self-play
mechanisms achieve
sort of solve problems that used to be
thought unsolvable like the game of go
also i mean protein folding starting to
get into that space where learning is
doing
at first there's not it wasn't entirely
learning and so and now it's end-to-end
learning
of the of a very difficult previously
thought unsolvable problem of protein
folding
and so um
yeah it would do where where do you
think would be a
really magical moment for you
there have been incredible things
happening in recent years like you say
all of the the things from deepmind and
open ai that have been
huge showpiece things but when you
really get down to it and you read the
papers and you look at the way the
models are going you know it's it's
still like a feed forward you push
something in something comes out i on
the end i mean maybe there's diffusion
models or monte carlo tree rollouts and
different things going on but it's not a
being it's not close to a being i am
that's that's going through a you know a
lifelong learning process do you want
something that kind of gives signs of a
being like what's the difference
between
a neural network
a feed forward neural network and a
being
where's the fundamentally the brain is a
recurrent neural network generating an
action policy i mean it's implemented on
a biological substrate and it's
interesting thinking about things like
that where we know fundamentally the
brain is not a convolutional neural
network or a transformer those are
specialized things that are very
valuable for what we're doing but it's
not the way the brain's doing now i do
think consciousness and ai in general is
a substrate independent mechanism where
it doesn't have to be implemented the
way the brain is but if you've only got
one existence proof there's certainly
some value in caring about what it says
and does
i am
and so the the idea that anything that
can be done with a narrow ai that you
can quantify up a loss function for or
reward mechanism you're almost certainly
going to be able to produce something
that's more resource effective to train
and deploy and use in an inference mode
you know train a whole lot using an
inference but uh a living being is going
to be something that's a continuous
lifelong learned task agnostic thing
and
learning is really important too and the
long-term memory
so memories is a big
part of that we've got
you know again i have all the respect in
the world for the amazing things that
are being done now but sometimes they
can be taken a little bit out of context
with things like
like there's some smoke and mirrors
going on like the gato the recent work
the multi-task learning stuff you know
it's amazing that it's the one it's one
model that plays all the atari games i
am as well as doing all these other
things but i of course it didn't learn
to do all of those it was instructed in
doing that by other reinforcement
learners going through and doing that
and even in the case of all the games
it's still going with a specific
hand-coded reward function in each of
those atari games where it's not that
you know how does it just wants to spend
its summer afternoon playing atari
because that's the most interesting
thing for it so it's again not a general
it's not learning the way humans learn
and there's i believe a lot of things
that are challenging to make a loss
function for that you can train uh
through these existing conventional
things we're going to chip away at all
the things that people do um
that we can turn into narrow
ai problems and
billions of probably trillions of
dollars of value are going to be created
by that
but there's still going to be a set of
things and we've got questionable cases
like the self-driving car where it's
possible it's not my bet but it's it's
plausible that the long tail could be
problematic enough that that really does
require a full-on artificial general
intelligence i
the counter argument is that data solves
almost every everything is an
interpolation problem if you have enough
data and tesla may be able to get enough
data
from all their deployed stuff to be able
to work like that but maybe not and
there are all the other problems about
like say you want to have a strategy
meeting and you want to go ahead and
bring in all of your remote workers and
your consultants and you want a world
where some of those could be ais that
are you know that are talking and
interacting with you in a an area that
is too murky to have a crisp loss
function
but they still have things that on some
level they're they're rewarded on some
internal level for building a valuable
to humans uh kind of life and ability to
interact with things
see i i still think that uh self-driving
cars solving that problem will take us
very far towards agi you might not need
agi
but i am really inspired by what
autopilot is doing uh waymo
so these some of the other companies i
think waymo leads the way there
is also really interesting but they
don't have quite as ambitious of an
effort in terms of learning based
sort of data-hungry approach to driving
which i think is very close to the kind
of thing that would take us far
towards agi yeah and it's a it's a funny
thing because as far as i can tell elon
is completely serious about all of his
concerns about agi you know being an
existential threat and you know i i
tried to draw him out to talk about ai
and he just didn't want to and i think
that you know i get that little
fatalistic sense from him and it's weird
because his company could very well be
the leading company leading towards a
lot of that where
uh tesla being a super pragmatic company
uh that's doing things because they
really want to solve this actual problem
it's a different vibe than the research
oriented companies where it's a great
time to be an ai researcher you've got
your pick of trillion dollar companies
that will you know that will pay you to
kind of work on the problems you're
interested in but that's not necessarily
driving hard towards the the core
problem of agi as something that's going
to produce a lot of value by doing
things that you know that people
currently do or would like to do
i mean i have million questions to you
uh
about your ideas about agi but do you
think
it needs to be embodied do you think it
needs to have a body
to start to
notice the signs of life and to develop
the kind of system that's able
to reason perceive the world in the way
that an agi should and
act in the world so should we be
thinking about robots or can this be
achieved in a purely digital so i have a
clear opinion on that and that's that no
it does not need to be embodied in the
physical world where you could say most
of my career is about making simulated
virtual worlds you know in games or
virtual reality and so on a fundamental
level i believe that you can make a
simulated environment that provides much
of the value of what the real
environment does and restricting
yourself to
operating at real time in the physical
world with physical objects i think is
an enormous handicap i mean that's one
of the real lessons driven home by all
my aerospace work is that i've you know
reality is a [ __ ] in so many ways there
we're dealing with all the mechanical
components like everything fails
murphy's law even if you've done it
right before on your fifth one it might
come out differently so yeah i think
that anybody that
that is all in on the embodied aspect of
it they are tying a huge weight to their
ankles and i think that
i i would
almost count them out anybody that's
making that a cornerstone of their
belief about it i would almost write
them off as being worried about them
getting to agi first i was very
surprised that elon's big on the uh the
humanoid robots i mean like the nasa
robonaut stuff was always almost a gag
line like what are you doing people well
that's very interesting because i he has
a very pragmatic view of that that's
just the
um a way to solve a particular problem
in a factory now i do think that once
you have an agi robotic bodies humanoid
bodies are going to be enormously
valuable i just don't think they're
helpful getting to agi well here's a
very sort of practical view which i
disagree with and i argue with him but
it's a practical view that there's
you know you could transfer the the
problem of driving to the problem of
uh robotic manipulation because so much
of it is perception it's perception and
action and it's just a different context
and so you can apply all the same kind
of data engine
learning processes to a different
environment and so why not apply to the
humanoid robot environment but
i think
i i do think that there's a certain
magic to the embodied robot
that may be the thing that finally
convinces people yes but again i don't
really care that much about convincing
people you know the the world that i'm
looking towards is you know you i
you you go to the website and say i want
five frank one a's to you know to work
on my team today and they all spin up
and they start showing up in your zoom
meetings
to push to push back but also to agree
with you but first to push back i do
think you need to convince people
for them to welcome that thing into your
life into their life i think there's
enough businesses that operate on an
objective kind of profit loss sort of
basis that i mean if you look at how
many things
again talking about the the world as an
evolutionary space there when you do
have free markets and you have
entrepreneurs uh you're going to have
people that are going to be willing to
go out and try whatever crazy things and
when it proves to be beneficial you know
there's fast followers in all sorts of
places
yeah and and you're saying that i mean
you know quake in vr
is a kind of embodiment but just in a
digital world and if if you're able to
demonstrate if you're able to do
something productive in that kind of
digital
reality
uh
then then agi doesn't need to have a
body yeah it's like one of the really
practical technical questions that i
kind of keep arguing with myself over if
you're doing a training and learning and
you've got like you can watch sesame
street you can play master system games
or something is it enough to have just a
video feed that that is that video
coming in or should it literally be on a
virtual tv set in a virtual room even if
it's you know a simple room just to have
that sense of you're looking at a 2d
projection on a screen versus having the
screen beamed directly into your retinas
and i
you know i think it's possible to maybe
get past some of these signs of life of
things with the uh just kind of
projected directly into the receptor
fields but eventually for more uh kind
of human
emotional connection for things probably
having some vr room with a lot of
screens in it for the ai to be learning
in is likely helpful it may be a world
of different ais interacting with each
other self-play i do think is one of the
critical things where socialization wise
one of the other limitations i set for
myself thinking about thing these is i i
need something that is at least
potentially real time because i want
it's nice you can always slow down time
you can run on a subscale system and and
test an algorithm at some lower level
and if you've got extra horsepower
running it faster than real time is a
great thing but i want to be able to i
am to have
the ais either socially interact with
each other or critically with actual
people your sort of child development
psychiatrist that comes in and interacts
and does the the good boy bad boy sort
of thing i as they're going through and
exploring different things and it's nice
to
i come back to the value of constraints
in a lot of ways and if i say well one
of my constraints is real-time operation
i mean it might still be a huge data
center full of computers but it should
be able to interact on a zoom meeting
with people and that's how you also do
start convincing people even if it's not
a robot body moving around which
eventually gets to irrefutable levels
but if you can go ahead and not just
type back and forth to a gpt bot on
something but you're literally talking
to them in an embodied over zoom form
and working through problems with them
or exploring situations having
conversations that are fully stateful
and learned i think that you know i
think that that's a valuable thing so i
do keep all of my eyes on on things that
can be implemented within sort of that
30 frames per second i
kind of work and i think that's feasible
do you think the most compelling
experience is that first will be
for pleasure or for business as they ask
in airports
so uh meaning is is it if it's
interacting with
ai agents will it be
sort of uh like friends
um
entertainment
almost like a therapist or whatever that
kind of interaction or is it in the
business setting something like you said
brainstorming different ideas
so
this is all a different formulation of
kind of a touring test or the spirit of
the original touring test where do you
think the biggest
benefit will first come so it's going to
start off hugely expensive i mean you're
going to
if
we're still all guessing about what
compute is going to be necessary i fall
in the side of i don't think you run the
numbers and you're like 86 billion
neurons 100 trillion synapses i don't
think those all need to be weights i
don't think we need models that are
quite that big evaluated quite that
often you know i base that on we've
we've got reasonable estimates of what
some parts of the brain do we don't have
the we don't have the neocortex formula
but we kind of get some of the other
sensory processing and it doesn't feel
like we need to we can simulate that in
computers for less weights but still
it's probably going to be thousands of
gpus to be running uh you know a human
level agi depending on how it's
implemented that might give you sort of
a clan of 128 kind of run-in batch
people depending on whether there's
sparsity in the way that the weights and
things are set up if it is a reasonably
dense thing then just the memory
bandwidth trade-offs means you get 128
of them at the same time and either it's
all feeding together learning in
parallel or kind of all running together
uh kind of talking to a bunch of people
but still if you've got thousands of
gpus uh necessary to run these things
it's going to be kind of expensive where
it might start off i'm a thousand
dollars an hour for your you know even
post development or something for that
which would be something that you would
only use for a business uh you know
something where you think they're gonna
help you make a strategic decision or
point out something super important but
i also am completely confident that we
will have another
factor of a thousand in cost performance
increase in agi type calculations uh not
in general computing necessarily but
there's so much more that we can do with
packaging making those right trade-offs
all those same types of things that in
the couple next couple decades 1000x
easy and then you're down to a dollar an
hour and
then you're kind of like well i should
have an entourage of ais that are you
know following me around helping me out
on anything that i want them to do
that's one interesting trajectory but
i'll i'll i'll push back because i have
um
so uh for in that case if you want to
pay thousands of dollars
it should actually provide some value
i think it's easier
for cheaper to provide
to provide value via a dumb ai
uh
that will take us towards agi to just
have a friend
i think there's an ocean of loneliness
in the world
and i think an effective friend that
doesn't have to be perfect doesn't have
to be intelligent it has to be empathic
having emotional intelligence having
ability to remember things
having ability to listen
most of us don't listen to each other
one of the things that love
and when you care about somebody when
you love somebody is when you listen and
that
is something we treasure about each
other and and
if an ai can do that kind of thing
um i think that
provides a huge amount of value and very
importantly
provides value in its ability to listen
and understand versus provide really
good advice i think providing really
good advice
is very difficult is another next level
step that would um
i think it's just easier to uh to do
companionship yeah i wouldn't disagree i
mean i think that there's very few
things that i would argue can't be
reduced to a uh
some kind of a narrow ai i think we can
do trillion dollars of value easily and
all the things that can be done there
and a lot of it can be done with smoke
and mirrors without having to go the
whole thing i mean there's going to be
the equivalent of the doom uh
the doom version for the agi that's not
really agi it's all smoke and mirrors
but it happens to do enough valuable
things that it's enormously uh useful
and valuable to people
but at some point you do want to get to
the point where you have the fully
general thing and you stop making
bespoke specialized systems for each
thing and you wind up
start using the higher level language
instead of writing everything in
assembly language
what about consciousness
the c word do what do you think that's
fundamental
to solving agi or is it a quirk of human
cognition
so i think most of the arguments about
consciousness don't have a whole lot of
merit
i think that consciousness is kind of
the way the brain feels when it's
operating
yes and this idea that
you know i do generally subscribe to
sort of the pandemonium theories of
consciousness where there's all these
things bubbling around and i think of
them as kind of slightly randomized
sparse distributed memory bit strings of
things that are kind of happening
recalling different associative memories
and eventually you get some level of
consensus and it bubbles up to the point
of being a conscious thought there and
the little bits of stochasticity that
are sitting on in i in this as it cycles
between different things and recalls
different memory that's largely our
imagination and creativity
um
so i don't think there's anything deeply
magical about it certainly not symbolic
i think it is generally the flow of
these uh
associations drawn up with static
stochastic noise overlaid on top of them
i think so much of that is like it
depends on what you happen to have in
your field of view as some other thought
was occurring to you that overlay and
blend into the next key that queries
your memory for things and that kind of
determines how you know how your chain
of consciousness goes so that's kind of
the qualia the subjective experience of
it is not
is not essential for intelligence i
think so i don't think there's anything
really important there
what about some other human qualities
like fear of mortality and stuff like
that like um the fact that this ride
ends
is that is that important like you you
me you know we talk so much about this
conversation about the value of
deadlines and constraints
um do you think that's important for
intelligence actually a super
interesting angle that uh that i don't
usually take on that about has death
being a deadline that forces you to make
better decisions because i have heard
people talk about how if you have
immortality people are going to stop
stop trying and working on things
because they've got all the time in the
world
i am but i would say that
i don't expect it to be a super critical
thing that uh that a sense of mortality
and death impending death is necessary
there because those are things that they
do wind up providing reward signals to
us and we will be in control of the
reward signals and there there will have
to be something fundamental that causes
that engenders curiosity and goal
setting and all of that i am something
is going to play in there at the reward
level
i am you know whether it's positive or
negative or both
i don't have any strong opinions on
exactly what it's going to be i but
that's that type of thing where i doubt
that might be one of those half dozen
key things that has to be sorted out on
exactly what the master reward that's
the meta reward over all of the uh the
local task specific rewards have to be
that could be that big negative reward
of death
maybe not death but ability to walk away
from an interaction so it bothers me
when people treat ai systems like
servants
so it doesn't bother me but i mean it
it's it really is drawing the line
between what an ais system could be it's
limiting the possibility of an asset
could be is treating them as justice
tools
now that's of course for from a narrow
ai perspective
there's so many
uh problems that narrow ai could solve
just like you said
as
in in its form of a tool
but it could also be a being
which is much more than a tool and to be
a to become a being you have to respect
that thing for being a being and for
that it has to be able to have um
to make its own decisions to walk away
to say i had enough of you i would like
to break up with you now
uh you've not treated me well and i
would like to move on so uh i think that
actually that choice
to end things
so i i
a couple of things on that so on the one
hand uh it is kind of disturbing when
you see people being like people that
are mean to robots and you know mean to
alexa whatever and that seems to speak
badly about humanity but there's also
the exact opposite side of that where
you have so many people that imbue
humanity in inanimate objects or things
that are toys or that are are relatively
limited so
i think there may even be more more
danger about people putting more
emotional investment into a lot of these
proto ais in different ways yeah um and
then the ai would manipulate that
but as far as like the ai ethnic sides
of things
i
really stay away from any of those
discussions or even really thinking
about it it's similar with the safety
things where i think it's just premature
and there's a certain class of people
that enjoy thinking about impractical
things things are not in the world and
you know of pragmatic effect around you
and i think that
begin again because i don't think
there's going to be a fast takeoff i
think we actually will have time to have
these debates when we know the shape of
what we're debating
and some people do take a principled
approach that they think it's going to
go too fast that you really do need to
get ahead of it that you need to be
thinking about this because we have slow
processes of coming to any kind of
consensuses or even coming up with ideas
about this
and
maybe that's i maybe that's true
i wouldn't put any of my money or
funding into something like that because
i don't think it's a problem yet and i
think that we will have these signs of
life when when we've got our learning
disabled toddler we should really start
talking about some of the safety and
ethics issues but probably not before
then can you elaborate briefly about why
you don't think there'll be a fast take
off
is there some deep intuition you have
about it does it because it's grounded
in the physical world or why yeah so
it is my belief that we're going to
start off with something that requires
thousands of gpus and
i i don't know if you've tried to go get
a thousand gpu instance on a cloud
anytime recently but these are not
things that you can just go spin up
hundreds of i
there are real challenges to i mean
these things are going to take data
centers and data centers take years to
build you know and the last few years
we've seen a few of them kind of coming
up going in different places they're big
engineering efforts you can hear people
bemoan about the fact that i know oh the
the network was wired all wrong and it
took them a month to go unwire it and
rewire it the right way these aren't
things that you can just magic into
existence
and the ideas of i am like the old
tropes about it's going to escape onto
the internet and take over other systems
there's the fast takeoff ones are
clearly nonsense because you just can't
open tcp connections above a certain
rate no matter how smart you are even if
you have perfect hacking ability that
take over the world in an instant sort
of thing just isn't plausible at all and
even if you had access to all of the
resources these are going to be
specialized systems where you're going
to wind up with something that is
architected around exactly this chip
with this interconnect and it's not just
going to be able to be plopped somewhere
else now interestingly it is going to be
something that the entire
um the entire code for all of it will
easily fit on a thumb drive that's total
spy movie thriller sorts of things where
you could have hey we cracked the secret
to agi and it fits on this thumb drive
and anyone could steal it now they're
still gonna have to build the right data
center to deploy it and have the right
kind of life experience curriculum to
take it up to the point where it's
valuable but the real core of it the the
magic that's going to happen there is
going to be very small you know it's
again tens of thousands of lines of code
not millions of lines of code it is
possible to imagine a world as you
mentioned in the spy thriller
view if it's
if it's just a few lines of code
we can imagine a world where the surface
of computation is growing maybe growing
exponentially
meaning
there's you know the
refrigerators start getting a gpu and uh
just
every first of all the smartphones the
billions of smartphones but maybe if
there
become
highways through which code can spread
across the entirety of the computation
surface
then you don't
any longer have to book aws
um
gpus there's real fundamental issues
there when you start getting down to
taking an actual problem and putting it
on an abstract machine like that that
has not worked out well in practice and
the idea that
there was always
like it's always been easy to come up
with ways to get com compute faster to
say more flops or more more gigaops or
whatever there that's usually the easy
part but you then have interconnect and
then memory for what goes into it and
when you talk about saying well cell
phones well you're limited to like a 5g
connection or something on that and if
you say how if you take your
your calculation and you factor it
across
a million cell phones instead of
a thousand gpus in a warehouse you might
be able to have some kind of a substrate
like that but it could be operating then
at 1 1000 the speed and so yes you could
get you could have an agi working there
but it wouldn't be a real-time agi it
would be something that is operating at
really a snail's pace you know much much
slower than kind of human level thought
for things yeah i'm not worried about
that problem you're transferring the
problem into the interconnect the
communication the shared memory
the the collective intelligence aspect
of it which is extremely difficult as
well yeah i mean it's back to the very
earliest days of super computers you
still have the the balance between
bandwidth storage and computation and
sometimes they're easier to get one or
the other but it's been remarkably
constant across all those years that you
still need all three
what do your efforts
now
you mentioned to me that you're really
committing to ai at this stage what what
do you see your life in the next few
months years look like
what what do you hope to achieve uh
achieve here so i literally just this
week signed a term sheet to to take some
investment money for my company where
the last two years i had backed off from
meta and i was still doing my consulting
cto role there but i had styled it as i
was going to take the the victorian
gentleman scientist route where i was
going to be the you know the wealthy
person that was going to go pursue
science and learn about this and do
experiments and honestly i'm surprised
there aren't more people like that that
are like me technical people that made a
bunch of money and are interested in
some of these possibly the biggest
leverage point in human history i mean i
know of i've heard of a couple
organizations that are basically led by
one rich techie guy that uh gets a few
people around him to try to work on this
but i'm surprised that there's not more
that there aren't like a dozen of them
i
i mean maybe people are still think that
it's an unapproachable problem that it's
kind of beyond their ability to to get a
wrench on and have some effect on like
whatever startups they've run before but
i
that was my kind of
like with all the stuff i've learned
whether it's gaming aerospace whatever i
i go through a larval phase where i'm
like okay i'm sucking up all of this
information trying to see is this
something that i can actually do is this
something that's practical to devote a
large chunk of my life to and i've gone
through that with the
with the ai machine learning space of
things and i and i think i've got my
arms around it i've got the measure of
it where some of the most brilliant
people in the world are working on this
problem but nobody knows exactly the
path that it's going on we're throwing a
lot of things at the wall and seeing
what sticks i
but i have a
you know another interesting thing just
learning about all of this the the
contingency of your path to knowledge
and talking about the associations and
the context that you have with them
where people that learn in the same path
will have similar thought processes and
i think it's useful that i come at this
from a different background different
history than the people that have had
the largely academic backgrounds for
this where i have huge blind spots that
that they could easily point out but i
have a different set of experiences in
history and approaches to problems and
systems engineering that
i'm
you know that might turn out to be
useful and i can afford to take that bet
where i'm not going to be destitute i am
i was you know i've been i have enough
money to fund myself working on this for
the rest of my life but what i was
finding is that i was
i'm i was still
not committing where i had a foot firmly
in the vr and meta side of things where
in theory i've got i've got a very nice
position there i only have to work one
day a week for my my consulting role but
but i was engaging every day i'd still
be like my computer's there i'd be going
and checking the workplace and notes and
testing different things and
communicating with people
but
uh but i did make the the decision
recently that no i'm gonna get serious
i'm still gonna keep my ties with meta
but i am seriously going for the agi
side of things and it's actually a
really interesting point because a lot
of
the machine learning the ai community is
quite large
but really
basically almost everybody has taken the
same
trajectory through life
uh in that community and it's so
interesting to have somebody like you
with a fundamentally different
trajectory and that's where the big
solutions can come because there's a
kind of silo
and
it's it is a bunch of people kind of
following the same kind of set of ideas
and i was really worried that i didn't
want to come off as you know like an
arrogant outsider for things where i
have all the respect in the world for
the work that's you know it's been a
miracle decade it's we're in the midst
of a scientific revolution happening now
and everybody doing this is i you know
these are the the einsteins and boars
and whatever's of our our modern era
i am and i was really happy to see that
the the people that i've sat down and
talked with everybody does seem to
really be quite great about just happy
to talk about things willing to
acknowledge that we don't know what
we're doing we're figuring it out as we
go along
and i mean i've got a you know a huge
debt on this where this all really
started for me because sam altman
basically tried to recruit me to open ai
and it was at a point when i didn't know
anything about what was really going on
in machine learning uh and in fact it's
funny how the first time you reached out
to me it's like four years ago for your
ai podcast for people
yeah for people who uh
uh listening to this should know that
first of all obviously i'm i've been a
huge fan of yours for the longest time
but we've agreed to talk like yeah like
four years ago back when this was called
the artificial intelligence podcast we
wanted to
do a thing and we said you said yes and
then i said it's like i don't know
anything about modern ai that's right i
said i could kind of take an angle on
machine perception because i you know
i'm doing a lot of that with the sensors
and the virtual reality but
we could probably find something to talk
about and then so i mean and that's
where when did sam talk to you about
open ai around the same time no i was a
little bit it was a bit after that so
i had done the the most basic work i had
kind of done the neural networks from
scratch where i had gone and written it
all in c just to make sure i understood
back propagation at the at the lowest
level and my my nuts and bolts approach
but but after sam approached me i
you know it was flattering to think that
he thought that i i could be useful at
open ai largely for kind of like systems
optimization sorts of things i am
you know without being an expert but i
asked uh you know ilya sutscover to give
me a reading list and he gave me a you
know a binder full of all the papers
that like okay these are the important
things if you really read and understand
all of these you'll know like 80 of what
most of the you know the machine
language researchers work on and and i
went through and i read all those papers
multiple times and highlighted them and
went through and kind of figured the
things out there and then started
branching out into my own sets of
research on things and eventually
started writing my own experiments and
doing
kind of figuring out you know finding
out what i what i don't know what the
limits of my knowledge are and starting
to get some of my angles of attack on
things the things that i think are a
little bit different from uh from what
people are doing
and
i've had a couple years now like two
years since i i kind of left the
full-time position at meta and
now i've kind of pulled the trigger and
said i'm gonna get serious about it but
some of my lessons all the way back to
armadillo aerospace about how i know i
need to be more committed to this where
there is that
it's both a freedom and a cost in some
ways when you know that you're wealthy
enough to say it's like this doesn't
really mean anything i can i can spend
you know i can spend a million dollars a
year for the rest of my life and
it doesn't mean anything it's fine
uh but that is an opportunity to just
kind of meander i and i could see that
in myself when i'm doing some things
it's like oh this is a kind of
interesting curious thing let's look at
this for a little while let's look at
that it's not really bearing down on the
problem so there's a few things that
that i've done that are kind of tactics
for myself to make me more effective
like one thing i noticed i i was not
doing well is i had a google cloud
account with uh to get gpus there and i
was finding i was very rarely doing that
for no good psychological reasons where
i'm like oh i can always think of
something to do other than to spin up
instances and run an experiment i can
you know keep working on my local titans
or something uh but it was really stupid
i mean it was not a lot of money i
should have been running more
experiments there so i thought to myself
well
i'm gonna go buy a quarter million
dollar dgx station i'm gonna just like
sit it right there and it's gonna mock
me if i'm not using it if the fans
aren't running on that thing i'm not
properly utilizing it and that's been
helpful you know i've done a lot more
experiments since then it's been it's
been interesting where i thought i'd be
doing all this low level envy link
optimize stuff but ninety percent of
what i do is just spin up four instances
of an experiment with different hyper
parameters on it oh
you are you're doing i'm like really
sort of building up intuition by doing
ml experiments of different kinds
but so the next big thing though is i am
you know i decided that i was going to
take some take some investor money
because
i i have an overactive sense of
responsibility about other people's
money i am yeah and it's like i
i don't want i mean a lot of my my push
and my passionate entreaties for things
that meta are it's like i don't want
zuck to have wasted his money investing
in oculus i want it to work out i want
it to change the world i want it to be
worth all of this time money and effort
going into it and i expect that it's
going to be that like that with my uh
with my company where it's a huge
forcing function yeah this investment
investors that are are going to expect
something of me now we've all had the
conversation that this is a low
probability long-term bet it's not
something that there's a million things
i could do that i would have line of
sight on the value proposition for this
isn't that i think there are there are
unknown unknowns in the way
but it's one of these things that it's
you know
it's hyperbole but it's potentially one
of the most important things humans ever
do and it's something that i think is
within our lifetimes if not within a
decade um to happen so
yeah this is just now happening like
term sheet like the ink is barely links
barely dry on drying i mean as i
mentioned you're offline like somebody i
admired um some of you know andre
kapathi i think the two of you different
trajectories in life but
approach problems similarly in that he
codes stuff from scratch up all the time
and
i he's created a bunch of little things
outside of
even outside the course at
stanford
that have been tremendously useful to
build up intuition about stuff
but also to help people and uh they're
all in the realm of ai
um
do you see yourself potentially doing
things like this or build you know not
necessarily solving a gigantic problem
but on the journey on the path to that
building up intuitions uh and um
uh sharing code or ideas or systems
that um give inklings of agi but also
kind of are useful to people in some way
so yeah first of all andre is awesome i
learned a lot when i was going through
my larval phase from his blog posts and
his stanford course and you know super
valuable i got to meet him first a
couple years ago when i was first kind
of starting off on my gentleman
scientist bit
and just uh just a couple months ago
when he went out on his sabbatical he
stopped by in dallas and we talked for a
while and i'm i had a great time with
him and then when i heard he actually
left tesla i did of course along with a
hundred other people say hey if you ever
want to work with me uh it would be an
honor yeah so i'm he thinks that he's
going to be doing this educational work
but i think someone's going to make him
an offer he can't refuse
before he gets too far along on it oh
his cur his current interest is
educational it's like yeah
um he's a special mind yeah is there
something you could speak to what makes
him so special
something you understand like he did
he was very much a programmer's
programmer that was doing machine
learning work rather than
it's a different feel than an academic
where you can see it in paper sometimes
where somebody that's really a
mathematician or a statistician at heart
and they're they're doing something with
machine learning but uh you know andre
is about getting something done and you
could see it in like all of his earliest
approaches to it's like okay here's how
reinforcement learning works here's how
recurrent neural networks work here's
how transformers work here's how i am
you know crypto works
and i am and yeah it's just
he's a hacker's you know one of his old
posts was like a hacker's guide to
machine learning yeah and you know he
deprecated that and said don't really
pay attention to what's in here but it's
that thought that uh that carries
through in a lot of it where it is that
back again to that hacker mentality and
the hacker ethic with what he's doing
and in sharing all of it yeah and a lot
of his approach to a new thing
like like i said larva stage is let me
code up the simplest possible thing to
build up intuition about it yeah like i
say i sketch with structs and things
when i'm just thinking about a problem
i'm thinking in some degree of code
you are also among many things a martial
artist both judo and jiu-jitsu
how has this helped make you the person
you are
so i mean i was a competent club player
in
judo and grappling i mean i was you know
by no means any kind of a superstar but
it was i went through a few phases with
it where i did some i'm when i was quite
young a little bit more when i was 17 i
am and then i got into it kind of
seriously in my mid-30s
and you know i went pretty far with it
and i was
you know pretty good at some of the
things that i was doing and i did
appreciate it quite a bit where
and on the one hand it's always if
you're going to do exercise or something
it's a more motivating form of exercise
if someone is if someone is crushing you
you're like motivated to to do something
about that to up your attributes and be
better about getting out there
but there's also that sense that i'm you
know i was not i was not a sports guy i
did do wrestling in uh in junior high
and i often wish that i think i would
have i would have been good for me if
i'd carried that on into high school and
had a little bit more of that i mean
it's like i i you know filled a little
bit of wrestling vibe with always going
on about in great embracing the grind
and like that push that i associate with
the wrestling team that that i in
hindsight i wish i had gone through that
and pushed myself that way
but even getting back into judo and jiu
jitsu in in my mid-thirties as usually
the old man on the mat with that there
was still the you know the sense that i
you know working out with the the group
and having the the guys that you're
beating beating each other up with it
but you just feel good coming out of it
and i can remember those driving home
aching in various ways and just thinking
it's like oh that was that was really
great and
i you know it's mixing with a bunch of
people that had nothing to do with any
of the things that uh that i worked with
you know every once in a while some
would be like oh you're the doom guy and
i but for the most part it was just
different slice of life i'm you know a
good thing
and i i made the call when i was 40
that's like maybe i'm getting a little
old for this i i had separated a rib and
tweaked a few things and uh
without any really bad injuries and i
was like have i dodged enough bullets
should i you know should i hang it up i
went back uh i've
i've gone a couple times in the last
decade trying to get my kids into it a
little bit i didn't really stick with
any of them but it was fun to get back
on the mats i really hurts for a while
when you haven't gone i
gone for a while but
i still debate this pretty constantly my
brother's only a year younger than me
and he's going kind of hard in jiu jitsu
right now and i you know he was just he
won a few medals at the last tournament
he was at competing yeah and i was
thinking yeah i guess we're in the
executive division if you're over 50
or over 45 or something and it's not out
of the question that i go back at some
point and do some of this but again i'm
just reorganizing my life around more
focus probably not going to happen i'm
pushing my exercise around to give me
longer uninterrupted intellectual focus
time pushing it to the beginning or the
running and stuff like that walking yeah
yeah running in calisthenics and some
things like that but it allows you to
still think about a problem but if
you're going to a judo club or something
you're you've got it fixed it's going to
be seven o'clock or whatever 10 o'clock
on saturday uh although i talked about
this a little bit when i was on rogan
and shortly after that carlos machado
did reach out and i had trained with him
for years i back in the day and he was
like hey we've got kind of a small
private club with a bunch of uh
executive type people and
uh
it gets it does tempt me
yeah i don't know if you know him but
john donahue moved
here to austin
uh with gordon ryan and a few other
folks and he has a very interesting way
very deep systematic way of thinking
about jiu jitsu
that
reveals the the chess of it the
the the like the
the science of it
and i do think about that more as kind
of an older person considering the
martial arts where i can remember the
the very earliest days getting back into
judo and i'm like teach me submissions
right now you know it's like learn the
arm bar learn the choke i
but yeah as you get older you start
thinking more about it's like okay i
really do want to like learn the entire
canon of judo it's like are all the
different things there and like all the
different approaches for it not just the
you know if you want to compete there's
just a handful of things you learn
really really well but sometimes there's
interest in learning a little bit more
of the scope there and figuring some
things out from you know at one point i
had wasn't exactly a spreadsheet but i
did have a you know a big long text file
with like here's the things that i
learned in here like ways you chain this
together and while when i went back a
few years ago it was good to see that i
whipped myself back into reasonable
shape about doing the basic grappling
but i know there was a ton of the
subtleties that were just that were gone
but could probably be brought back
reasonably quickly and there's also the
benefit i mean you're exceptionally
successful now
um
you're brilliant
and the problem the old problem with the
ego yeah
is uh i still pushed kind of harder than
i should i mean that was i was one of
those people that i yeah i'm i'm on the
smaller side for uh for a lot of the
people competing and i would you know
i'd go with all the big guys and i'd go
hard and i'd push myself a lot and that
would be one of those where
i would i
you know i'd be dangerous to anyone for
the first five minutes but then
sometimes after that i'm already dead
and i knew it was terrible for me
because it made the no it meant i got
less training time with all of that when
you go and you just gas out you know
relatively quickly there and i like to
think that i would be better about that
where after i gave up judo i started
doing the half marathons and tough
mudders and things like that and so when
i did go back to the the local judokai
club i thought it's like oh i should
have better cardio for this because i'm
a runner now and i do all of this and
didn't work out that way it was the same
old thing where just push really hard
strain really hard and
and of course when i worked with good
guys like carlos it's like he just the
whole flow like water thing is real and
he's just like that's true with judo too
some of the best people like i've
trained with olympic gold medalists and
for some reason with them everything's
easier everything it's
you actually start to feel
the science of it the music of it the
dance of it and it's everything is
effortless
um
you understand that there's an art to it
it's not just an exercise it was
interesting where i did go to the
codecon in japan i kind of the
birthplace of judo and everything and i
remember i rolled with one old guy i
didn't didn't start standing just
started on groundwork nuaza and it was
striking how different it was from
carlos he was still he was better than
me and he got my arm and i you know i
had to tap there but it was a completely
different style where i just felt like i
could do nothing he was just enveloping
me and just like slowly ground it down
and took my arm and bent it while with
carlos you know he's just loose and free
and you always thought like oh you're
just gonna go grab something but you
never had any chance to do it but it was
very different feeling that's a good
summary of the difference between jiu
jitsu and judo in jiu jitsu there's it
is a dance and you feel like there's a
freedom and actually
um
anybody that's like gordon ryan one of
the best
the best grappler in the world nogi
grappler in the world uh there's a
feeling like you can do anything
uh but when you actually try to do
something you can't just magically
doesn't work but with the best judo
players in the world yeah it does feel
like there's a blanket that weighs a
thousand pounds on top of you and
there's not a feeling like you can do
anything you just you're trapped and
that's uh that's a style that's a
difference in the style of martial arts
but it's also
uh once you start the study you
understand it all has to do with human
movement and the physics of it and the
leverage and all that kind of stuff and
that's like
yeah that's super fascinating at the end
of the day for me
the biggest benefit is and the humbling
aspect when another human being
kind of
tells you that you know there's a
hierarchy or there's a
um
you're not that special and in the most
extreme case when you tap to a choke you
are basically
living because somebody lets you live
and that's that is one of those if you
think about it that is a closer brush
with mortality than than most people
consider
and that kind of
humbling act is good to take to your
work then where it's harder to get
humbled you know
yeah because nobody's nobody that does
any martial art is coming out thinking
i'm the best in the world at anything
because everybody loses
let me ask you for advice
what advice would you give to young
people today
uh about life
about career how how they can have a job
how they can have an impact how they can
have a life they can be proud of
so it was kind of fun i got invited to
give the commencement speech back at the
i went to college for two semesters and
and dropped out and went on to do my
tech stuff
but they still wanted me to come back
and give a commencement speech
and i i've got that pinned on my twitter
account i still feel good about
everything that i said there
and
you know my my biggest point was that
the path for me might not be the path
for everyone and in fact the advice the
the path that i took and even the advice
that i would give based on my
experience and learnings probably isn't
the best advice for everyone because
what i did was all about this knowledge
in depth it was about not just having
this surface level ability to make
things do what i want but to really
understand them through and through to
let me do the systems engineering work
and to sometimes find these
inefficiencies that can be bypassed
and and that the whole world doesn't
need that you know most programmers
don't need or engineers of any kind
don't necessarily need to do that they
need to do a little job that's been
parceled out to them uh be reliable let
people depend on you do quality work
with all of that
but
people that do have an inclination for
wanting to to know know things deeper
and learn things deeper
i'm you know the
there are just layers and layers of
things out there and it it's amazing
it's if you're the right person that is
excited about that
i
the world's never been like this before
it's better than ever i mean everything
that was wonderful for me is still there
and there's whole new worlds to explore
on the different things that you can do
and that i am
you know it's hard work embrace the
grind with it and understand as much as
you can and then be be prepared for
opportunities to present themselves
where you can't just say this is my goal
in life and just push at that i mean you
might be able to do that but you're
going to make more total progress if you
say i'm preparing myself with this broad
set of tools and then i'm being aware of
all the way things are changing as i
move through the world and as the whole
world changes around me and then looking
for opportunities to deploy the tools
that you've built
and there's going to be more and more of
those types of things there where
an awareness of what's happening where
the inefficiencies are what things can
be done what's possible versus what's
current practice and then finding those
areas where you can go and make an
adjustment and make something that may
affect millions or billions of people in
the world make it better when maybe from
your own example
how are you able to recognize this about
yourself that you saw the layers in in a
particular thing and you were drawn to
discovering deeper and deeper truths
about it is that something that was
obvious to you that you couldn't help or
is there some actions you had to take to
actually allow yourself to dig deep so
in the earliest days of personal
computers i remember the the reference
manuals and the very early ones even had
schematics of uh computers in the
background in the in the back of the
books as well as firmware listings and
things and i could look at that and at
that time when i was a younger teenager
i didn't understand a lot of that stuff
how the different things worked uh i was
pulling out the information that i could
get but i always wanted to know all of
that there was like kind of
magical information sitting down there
it's like the elder laura that some
graybeard wizard i you know is the
keeper of and so i always felt that pull
for wanting to know more wanting to
explore the
uh the mysterious areas there
and
you know and that followed right in
through all the things that got the
value exploring the video cards leading
to the i'm you know the scrolling
advantages you know exploring some of
the academic papers and things learning
about bsp trees and the different things
that that i could do
um with those systems and just the the
huge larval phases going through
aerospace just reading
bookshelves full of books i mean again
that point where i have enough money i
can buy all the books i want it was
it was so valuable there where i was
terrible with my money when i was a kid
my mom thought i would always be broke
because you know i'd buy my comic books
and just be out of money but it was like
all the pizza i want all the diet coke i
want video games and then books books
and it didn't take that much as soon as
i was making 27k a year i i felt rich
and i was just getting all the things
that that i wanted but
that sense of you know that books have
always been magical to me and that was
one of the things that really made me
smile is uh andre had said he found when
he came over to my house he said he
found my library inspiring just
it was great to see you know i still
look he's kind of a younger guy i
sometimes wonder if younger people these
days have the same relationship with
books that i do where they were such a
cornerstone for me in so many ways but
that sense that yeah i always wanted to
know it all i know i can't and that was
like one of the last things i said you
can't know everything but you should
convince yourself that you can know
anything you know any one particular
thing
it was created and discovered by humans
you can learn it you can find out what
you need on there and you can learn it
deeply yeah you can drive a nail down
through whatever layer cake problem
space you've got and learn a cross
section there and not only can you have
an impact doing that you can just
you can attain happiness doing that
there's something so fulfilling about
becoming a craftsman of a thing yeah and
i don't want to tell people that look
this is a a good career move just you
know grit your teeth and you know and
bear barrett i you know you want people
you want
and i do think it is possible sometimes
to find the joy in something like it
might not immediately appeal to you but
i had told people early on like in in
software times that i
you know it a lot of game developers are
in it just because they are so
passionate about games but i was always
really more flexible in what appealed to
me where i said i think i could be quite
engaged doing operating system work or
even database work i i would find the
interest in that i because i think most
things that are significant in the world
have a lot of layers and complexity to
them and a lot of opportunities hidden
within them
so that would probably be the most
important thing to encourage to people
is that i'm you can like weaponize
curiosity you can deploy your curiosity
to find i to kind of like make things
useful and valuable to you even if they
don't immediately appear that way deploy
your curiosity yeah that's very true uh
we've mentioned this debate point
whether mortality or fear of mortality
is fundamental
to creating an agi but let's talk about
whether it's fundamental to human beings
do you think about your own mortality
i really don't and
and you probably always have to like
take with a grain of salt anything
somebody says about fundamental things
like that i'm
but i don't think about
really
aging impending death legacy with uh
with my children things like that and
clearly it seems most of the world does
a lot a lot more than i do yeah i so i
mean i think i'm an outlier in that
where
it's
yeah it doesn't wind up being a real
part of my uh my thinking and motivation
about things so daily existence is about
sort of the people you love
and the problems
before you i'm very much focused on what
i'm working on right now i i i do take
that back there's one aspect where the
the kind of finiteness of the life does
impact me and that is about thinking
about the scope of the problems that i'm
working on when i you know when i
decided to work on when i was like
nuclear fission or agi these are big
ticket things that i that are impact
large fractions of the world and i was
thinking to myself at some level that
okay i mean i've i may have a couple
more swings
at bat with me at full capability but
yes my my mental abilities will decay
with age you know mostly inevitably i i
don't think it's a zero percent chance
that we will address some of that before
it becomes a problem for me i think
exciting medical stuff in the next
couple decades
but i do have this kind of vague plan
that when i'm not at the top of my game
and i don't feel that i'm you know in a
position to put a dent in the world some
way that i'll probably wind up doing
some kind of recreational retro
programming or i'll you know i'll i'll
work on some i am you know something
that i would not devote my life to now
but i can while away my time as the old
man gardening in the code worlds
and then to step back even
bigger let me ask you about why we're
here we human beings
what's the meaning of it all what's the
meaning of life john carmack so very
similar with that last question i know a
lot of people fret about this question a
lot and i just really don't i really
don't give away no we are i you know we
are biological creatures that
happenstance of evolution uh you know we
have innate drives that evolution
crafted for survival and passing on of
genetic codes i'm
i don't
i don't find a lot of value in trying to
go much deeper than that i i have my
motivations some of which are you know
some of which are probably genetically
coded and many of which are contingent
on my upbringing and the path that i've
had through my life
i i don't run into like spates of
depression or enwy or anything that uh
that winds up being a challenge and
forcing a degree of soul-searching with
things like that i seem to be okay i'm
you know kind of without that um
as a brilliant ant in the ant colony
without looking up to the sky wondering
why the hell am i here again
so the
the why of it the incredible
mystery of the fact that we started
first of all the origin of life on earth
and from that from single cell organisms
the entirety of the evolutionary process
took us somehow to this incredibly
intelligent thing that is able to
build wolfenstein 3d and doom and quake
and
uh take a crack at the problem of agi
and create things that eventually
supersede human beings that doesn't the
why of it
is um it's been my experience that
people that focus on uh that don't focus
on the here and now right in front of
them tend to be less effective i mean
it's not 100
you know vision matters to some people
but i it doesn't seem to be a necessary
motivator for me and i think that the
process of getting there is usually done
it's like the magic of gradient descent
people just don't believe that just
looking locally gets you to all of these
spectacular things that's been you know
the decades of looking at
i am
really some of the smartest people in
the world that would just push back
forever against this idea that it's not
this grand sophisticated vision of
everything but little tiny steps local
information winds up leading to all the
best answers so the meaning of life is
uh
following
locally wherever the gradient ascent
takes you
this was an incredible conversation
officially the longest conversation i've
ever done on the podcast uh which means
a lot to me because i get to do it with
one of my heroes john i can't tell you
how much it means to me that you would
sit down with me you're an incredible
human being um i can't wait what you do
next but you've already changed the
world you're an inspiration to so many
people and again we haven't covered like
most of what i was planning to talk
about so i hope we get a chance to talk
someday in the future i can't wait to
see what you do next thank you so much
again for talking to me thank you very
much
thanks for listening to this
conversation with john carmack to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you some words from john
carmack himself
focused hard work is the real key to
success
keep your eyes on the goal and just keep
taking the next step towards completing
it
if you aren't sure which way to do
something
do it both ways and see which works
better
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you